foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely days are over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter is
over Alice Lee secures victory for the
archbishops what an incredible
performance welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives unbelievable and you see
Arjun he shakes his head but pranav with
a second huge
oh entering its Fifth Season 16 teams
will reboot the PCL Legacy with a new
format and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion he's blundered oh my gosh
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
foreign
hello and welcome everyone to the fifth
and final week of the main event of the
protest League season 2023 and this week
is going to be about heartbreaks and
celebration as the teams battle it out
in elimination matches a roller coaster
and further ride with you and with me is
Michael commentator Grandmaster Robert
has Robert welcome how excited are you
hey Tanya I'm so glad I commentate with
you and I'm very excited I think the
players and the managers and captains
they're super stressed because as you
said this is win or go home time for all
the remaining teams in the Pro chess
League
wow Goldberg or go home as they say and
we kick off with
certain the fun
protest League we start the day with St
Louis taking on the Croatia Bulldogs in
an elimination match these two teams are
on two wins two losses one win you go
through one loss and you're out Robert
the second match it's the chest cross
taking on Blitz and we've got some big
breaking news coming in that for this
very very crucial match the chess bras
have got to deliver without a certain
Magnus Carlsen in their team
yeah Magnus Carlsen had a step out of
the lineup at the last minute it's good
news when your team captains and
managers have secured the likes of Anish
giri so while Magnus is out Anish giri
swapped in it is not the best start to
the fifth and final week of the season
for the chess Bros because they'll have
all they can handle in the Blitz
we hope the world champion feels better
soon and also of course as you're
mentioning one win is all these teams
need to make it through but some of the
teams have already punched their tickets
into the playoffs let's bring up our
standings the first team to do that
Robert were the Indian yogis we've got
five teams there who are already in the
playoffs it is the fight this week but
the remaining three spots and we see
that with a two and two score for the
Saint Louis archbishops the Croatia
Bulldogs and the chess bras
yeah we have five teams already securing
their spot in the playoffs they're all
deserving squads as you mentioned the
India yogis they look great undefeated
as were the Gotham Knights but today
we're going to focus on those teams
right after those with the blue Mark
next to their name we have the
archbishops and the Bulldogs and Tanya
these two teams very balanced rosters
hard to predict who's the favorite
between them but you know they both want
it so bad
that's what the fight is about it is
about getting those three went to make
it to the playoffs we started with 16
teams Robert by the end of this week we
will be down to just eight themes we see
some big names at the top there who've
already made it to the playoffs the
yogis the Gotham Knights water
performance by Levy's team it's been
this season the Shanghai tigers as well
with Jew Vengeance scoring some big wins
and of course the Wizards weaving their
magic now while these teams weave their
Magics on the flip side we've also had
teams which have been knocked out of the
protest league and let's bring that up
now the First theme to have been knocked
out were the Charlotte cobras of course
the consolation prize on that was that
we got Daniel to commentate on the
protest League
he was able to join us so many times
unfortunately because his team was
suffering but that's the nature of the
pro chess league and you look right
above the cobras another team that was
eliminated in just three matches the
Berlin Bears had the best start you
could possibly ask for in the Pro chess
League Josephine heinemann had the upset
of the Season against Hikaru Nakamura in
the first game of the season and yet
they went down swinging in just three
matches so the teams are so strong in
this league there are no easy matches
and for the Blitz the Garden State
passers and team MGD one they don't want
to fall to the red line they do not want
to be eliminated from this competition
absolutely and that's the dream to make
it through and we see big names there as
well with blitz at the top of our of our
standings with two wins and two losses
now this is a team that's being headed
by the 2021 World Blitz Champion Maxine
washer and the three times World bets
Champion Alexander Grisha and yet
they're fighting for their life uh today
when they play in that elimination match
up against the Charlotte uh not the
Charlotte but the Canada chess bras big
games coming up we've got the St Louis
archbishops going up first against the
Bulldogs and this is their roster
talking about biggies talking about big
hitters look at this being led by none
other than the 2018 World Championship
Challenger Fabiano caruana at the top
2766 with all the way down what has been
super impressive about this team Robert
has been their fourth board
yeah when you said talking about biggie
I thought you went up a Biggie and Tupac
but you're talking about Fabiano caruana
and you know he may be from Brooklyn so
we know where it's at so Fabiano he is
the number one player on this team but
as you're highlighting Alice Lee she's
been punching above her rating that's
been huge for them because it allows
them to trot out such a star lineup like
they have today and Tony if they make
the playoffs no team wants to face them
because look at their list of reserves
lenier Dominguez Jeffries Young and the
rest of the cast oh no you know that
every single team that's in the playoffs
is rooting for the Bulldogs
wow that's actually a really cool
Insight you know we we always as fans
and commentators May the best team wins
but of course the competitors don't want
to face the archbishops now this team
had quite a devastating start they were
down 2-0 in their matches every week
they've been facing elimination but what
momentum they've picked up they've been
winning match after match and definitely
it looks like there's been a lot of
shift in the way they've been
approaching these games and honestly has
had some of the biggest moments of her
chess career here at the protest League
that big win against Michael bluebomb
that blew our minds she's been picking
up really critical points for her team
to push them over to the winning line
but today's task is not going to be easy
as they're facing the Croatia bulldogs
and extremely balanced team here top to
bottom we see a lot of 2600s a lot of
2500s led by Bogdan and I have to say
Robert when I say Bogdan now I always
imagine that moment the most shocking
moment I think of the protest league so
far where he just forgot to promote a on
into a queen what happened there what
was that
that was shocking is what it was because
he could have just simply picked his
Pawn up pushed a t to the side and
received a queen in return He just
something was going on in time trouble
where he was not able to make the right
move and he lost that game and it was a
critical one for the Bulldogs but if we
know anything about Bulldogs they have
not just bark but a lot of bite and as
you look at their roster it is led by a
2700 in dayach but they have Paulina
shuvalova a nearly 2500 rated player on
board four we have bardia dineshfar on
board three these are very strong
players and to add to that we have their
reserves Mustafa IL Maz has played a big
role for this squad so Tanya another
team that is probably more dangerous
than their lineup initially looks but
they have some stars that are waiting to
strike come playoff time
these guys are looking at chomping and
doing the way today against the Saint
Louis Archbishop to to punch their
ticket into the playoff they are really
known for their grit and determination
in these matches somehow they just seem
to sneak their way into Victory now
while we were talking about the Saint
Louis Archbishop having this up and down
trajectory to this point these guys
their marches have been a lot more
balanced the Croatia Bulldogs looking
for that big win it's going to be a
blood bot but how much of a bloodbot
let's bring up our featured question for
today uh Robert because it is about how
many decisive games there will be in the
matchup that's coming up with the
archbishops taking on the Bulldogs what
do you think are they going to go for
blood here Robert will we see more than
12 wins or less than 11 wins
tough question you know these are the
fun things that Sports and games have
added these days and it you should get
involved so use that command predict but
Tanya I'm gonna go with the under today
I love Fighting Chess and just because
there will be some draw sprinkled in
there doesn't mean that it won't be
fighting but I I just think that we have
such a solid lineup from both sides it's
hard for me to see 12 victories out of
16 possible games I'm going with the
under
I'm going with you over there Robert I
think today the teams are coming out
with full guns blazing we are going to
see an absolute dogfight in both these
matches that are coming up and we've got
to take a look but before we do that
chat you've got to use the command uh
exclamation predict you put in your
votes what do you think more than 12
wins or less than 11 Robert says under I
say over we will find out it is all
about the lineups right now who is going
to be fighting for these wins Robert
let's take a look at the squad that the
players that the teams have chosen oh
look at this lineup you see the top
board starting with two seven those are
super Grand Masters not just ordinary
GMS at the top they put on their capes
and they come to play in five minutes
and poked on Daniel day out and Tanya as
we look from board to board we have to
give an even on board too about the same
rating a slight nod to the archbishops
on board three but on board four we've
been talking about Alice Lee but Paulina
she's saying what about me I'm 2500 and
I'm board four for the Bulldogs that's
scary because we know that she can beat
anybody in the archbishop's lineup
oh Paulina shavalova is such a strategic
positional player who's always ready for
these big long fights till the very end
and she's gonna definitely try to get as
many points we've often seen they've
bought four be very decisive for these
themes now the one thing that stands out
is how the Saint Louis Archbishop has
this heavy hitter on board one but it
just seems the Bulldogs have a more
well-rounded balance team talk to bottom
uh and often we've seen just having that
one player score heavy including a
certain Magnus it just isn't enough so
every board truly counts today all also
Robert notice how these four players the
squad that's been chosen by the Saint
Louis Archbishop is in fact the same one
that they picked in in week three and
week four the two wins that they had
against the Berlin Bears and the Spanish
shrimps so Fabi sticking to the fabulous
four I like the name of that Squadron if
it ain't broke don't fix it and Tanya
this is the lineups you know the round
by round situation you start with the
lopsided matchups I love the first round
of the pro chess league matches
and that's because these are the most
lopsided rounds where we see the biggest
upsets happen and oh my God we've seen
that play out over the five weeks it's
Fabiano caruana taking on Polina
shivalova we see the top board take on
the bottom board and as the rounds
progress it becomes more equal in
strength you know I want to ask you
Robert which game are you most excited
about but before you give your answer
I'm gonna give mine that fourth bird
Alice Lee can she do what she's been
doing against the very top seeds she
starts against bogdon Daniel that's the
one that I'm most excited to watch of
course you knew I was gonna pick that
one so you decided to take it for
yourself I see this sharing is caring
mentality this broadcast is going to
have but I actually was going to start
at the top so same idea or just
different uh Team situation the board
four versus Board One matchup is fasting
to me because if we just look at board
two versus Board three those matches
they're usually pretty level some people
will end up winning but I love the
lopsided nature of One Versus four but
as I was saying before Tanya for the
Bulldogs Paulina shuvall was nearly 2500
so it's not the typical 400 plus rating
spread in that matchup it's just a
couple hundred points and she will have
a legitimate shot so that is my Marquee
matchup of round one
and that both three Alexander engine he
is the man who beat Maxine washer
legrath not once but twice earlier in
the season he needs to do the same today
against the fabi-led St Louis Archbishop
let's take a look at the match format
what the teams need to do because Robert
it is all about touching that golden
score of eight and a half points and you
do that you win the match now we say
it's up to four rounds because
mathematically and we've seen this
happen so practically as well it is
possible to get to the score in just
three rounds but this match looking at
the lineup looking at the Players the
performance and what's at stake this
one's going to go down to the wire
it certainly will go down to the wire
that is the nature of the pro chest
League when you have all four boards
playing the other team's uh four boards
you're gonna get some wins here and
there but it's just going to be a tight
match and I really think that these two
teams do not have much separation Tanya
it's gonna be a lot of fun and we
AK audiency the players are getting
ready to kick off action and what they
have prepared the openings are gonna
matter it's going to be about nerves and
time scrambles it's everything at stake
uh today Robert for these themes well
wine for that top three spots if I mean
I know as commentators we all hate that
spot but I'm gonna put two in it if you
had to make a prediction for this
upcoming match who's taking it
oh gosh you are putting me on the spot
aren't you
I just don't know why don't I just throw
this back to China why don't you answer
your own question come on who is taking
this
I was not prepared for that you know I
am rooting for a playoff for a tie break
in this one I want to see the blitz I
want to see this go down to the wire
we've got lift off already and the board
that you had your eye on we've got a
Queen spawn opening and it's it looks
like it's gonna start with the nimso but
instead it's the Queen's Gambit decline
most probably okay and we see it's a big
choice for white at this moment because
you can always swap on D5 and First
bishop G5 is played and Tanya I'm always
curious what openings these top boards
will play because they don't want to
just make a draw normally the Mantra is
you draw with black you hold steady and
you try your best to win with the white
pieces in the Pro chess league with
these matchups where there's clear
separation between the players 500 is
not just looking for a draw here
100 he wants to try and complex get the
position and try and get a game even
though he's playing Black he knows that
today is the day he needs to get that
hundred percent score we've seen board
one do that very often so he needs to
join the likes of Hikaru off Magnus off
way Yi who have scored four out of four
for that team and we see an interesting
opening battle here because
Paulina has not yet taken a decision
with that G1 Knight very often that
Knight develops before that Bishop does
which is why I think Fabi as well is
taking a little bit of his time and now
the question to Polina does she want to
go Knight F3 and she does it so we've
got a very classical Queens Gambit
decline opening yeah and Fabiano he's
playing quite quickly at this point
Paulina she's moving a little more
gingerly she has not spent that much
time but I get the sense where she's
just trying to figure out what to do
next and for Fabiano one of the big
questions is do you play C6 and he
answers that honey I would say he could
play for C5 sometimes you just want to
break open the position even if it hands
yourself an isolated Pawn
and I think the reason the reason you
want to do that is because he wants to
keep the position as alive as possible
not trade off too many pawns not trade
off too many pieces he's just aiming for
a long game against Polina who is well
she's almost 2500 a very strong player
but Fabi a big favorite in this one he
wants a long game and that's the reason
he doesn't go for the Liquidation in the
center A6 so C6 A6 some Quiet Moves
there by Fabi yeah he's playing checkers
while she's playing chess we got all
these pawns on the light squares over
here but it makes sense because you
often want to strike with B5 and you may
be provoking the move C5 trying to take
advantage of some of this weakened dark
squares but anytime C5 is played Black
can try to Chisel at the pawn structure
with B6 maybe even try to play for E5
it's a big decision right now for
Paulina
that's why she goes into a bit of a
thing but because alter King is in the
center she needs to find the time to go
castle and she says now is the moment
I'm not going to fix the center she
keeps it flexible she goes for short
castle and Fabi finally taking a
decision and he captures pushes the
bishop away he wants to next develop his
own Bishop to B7 and then I that break
in the center in these structures Robert
we often see black either play for C5 or
E5 I think this one Bobby wants to get
C5 in yes you definitely do because
where's this bishop on C8 going it's
going to be seven but there's a pawn in
front of it so as Tanya is saying you
want to throw that pawn forward up to C5
get the bishop to B7 and use the long
diagonal tier Advantage I actually think
that black has a great start to this
game not that Fabian was better but he's
definitely not worse and at some point
the tables can start turning in
Fabiano's favor if he gets that activity
with C5 Bishop B7 and he's got this more
advanced Pawn on the queen side in beef
the B5 Pawn that can go up to B4
it's on the board as you were dogging C5
has been played eventually the bishop
will land on B7 so Fabi getting that
activity in you don't want to capture on
C5 because after Knight C5 black just
ends up putting pressure on the D3
bishop and gains a lot of tempo and
momentum to finish development but if
you don't then you're actually risking
getting an isolated Queen spawn on D4
now while Polina goes into a think tank
this is a critical moment in the opening
but she says I am playing Fabi I need to
take control of the clock not going to
going into any long things she offers a
trade and it looks like Fabi accepts it
after capturing the bishop on E7 Bishop
coming to E4 white should be doing great
in that position yeah that's what
Fabiano he decides not to trade Knights
as Tanya was indicating a bishop on e4
would hit this rook in the corner and
just gives it a nice diagonal so the F6
square perfectly well defended by
Black's pieces the bishop can go out to
B7 soon so I feel like black is steady
here no issues whatsoever for Fabiano
how are the rest of the squad doing
you've got to take a look let's bring up
our bird's eye view because we've got
action on all boards and we've been
talking about this that in the protest
League you could have a Magnus on the
top one you could have Hikaru you could
have Fabi on the top board with every
each and every game each and every
player has to make a contribution and
it's super important to focus on each of
these boards and uh Robert I see on the
bottom right Alice Lee against Bogdan
and it looks like that Alice should be
pretty pleased with the opening outcome
that she's had I like her Bishop on B2
but some questions to be answered a pawn
has been pushed in the center attacking
that Knight meanwhile on the bottom left
I see again early phases of the opening
being played out it looks like pretty
level game going on all around yeah the
games do look pretty steady in the top
right the Queens are gone so that's
already into an end game between bardia
and as far and Benjamin Bach and as you
were mentioning Alice Lee's pushed a
pawn against
in the bottom right hitting her
opponent's Queen so I Italian which one
should we go to we have
choices you know it okay another one I
want to drop it I'm not even gonna say
it
look at that wild position on the board
I mean the Knight was attacked and now
Alice says I don't care about that night
I just want to push your queen out she
goes for B4 uh Bogdan trying to think
where he wants to retreat I think C7
looks like the natural Square you bring
your queen back and again big questions
to Alice what does she do with the
Knight I'm guessing the Knight is going
to go into the center to the D4 square
but that looks very risky with a rook
coming to d8 pinning the Knight there
could be some pressure down the D file
and we see the chat I mean they're going
crazy for Alice Lee they love supporting
her she's young but she's very talented
and can take down a super gym member she
almost took down way that game was very
close but in the end she couldn't just
quite land a knockout in a complicated
position but Tanya right now I'm looking
at this I'm seeing a position where
black is very stable has Connect Four I
know we talk about different board games
all the time here but there's uh that
one going on but I think the Knight has
to jump into D4 and just avoid the queen
trade for now but because blacks sort of
Pawn chain here is causing white some
problems
that I have better chances in the end
game he wants to trade off the Queen
Alice has shown such excellent play in
the middle game he wants to try to
liquidate as many pieces as possible to
ease out the pressure in this one yeah
and I think that when you push pawns
you're indeed danger of overextending
there's a big difference in the pawn
structure we see Black's Pawn structure
towards the center hitting this Knight
whereas White's Queen Side Pawn
structure a quick Bishop E6 will go
right after this pawn and she does trade
Queens a bigger knife to G5 Battalion
after H6 this Knight is going to be
forced back to the rim and I just get
the sense that white pieces don't have
the best footing whereas when this
Knight goes back the bishop hops out
here attacks this Pawn at some point
black can strike with A5 trying to open
the queen side I just like the
foundation of bugs on Daniel Day
action's position a little bit more not
saying that white is you know in danger
of losing in the next few moves but I
just get the sense that it's just a
little bit easier to play for black
I agree with you in your move eight six
as you called out A's on the board
hitting that Knight freeing that E6
Square to bring out the bishop once the
Knight falls down falls back to H3 black
can also think about advancing the pawns
further to G5 wow tactics everywhere
Alice is so good at this we saw her not
defend her Knight attack her opponent's
Queen and again she doesn't defend her
Knight attack her opponent's rook and it
all seems to work out you can't pick up
the night because of rook d8 and if you
trade the Rooks first uh Robert in this
position after Rook D1 maybe we can just
bring up our analysis board as well yes
and Rook D1 and you take on G5 there's a
check on d8 picking up that Bishop on C8
it's not just about equalizing material
but that's a dominating position for
white with horrible pieces on the queen
side for black you know what's crazy I
thought this would just be a winning
advance for white turns out that black
actually traps this Rook over here
somehow like it looks like you have this
pin for eternity you're gonna win the
game but black is actually gonna go over
here this is beyond you know human uh
foresight just to be able to get this
position you assume that white has to be
winning it turns out that bogdon Daniel
Dash could have gone for this it
wouldn't have been easy to see but when
you go for the game and you look at game
review you're like oh darn it I had a
win and you're like nah that was too
much to ask for
yeah that is those are some superhuman
moves but of course rookie had a normal
way to continue and now this is going to
be cool quite a grind for both these
players with Bogdan he does seem to have
a pleasant end game the bishop will come
out to E6 attacking C4 while Alice tries
to neutralize Black's edge here with
more space that Bogdan has created that
pawn structure on the king side giving
him clear play the Black Knight can jump
to E5 97 95 always in the air let's
bring up our other boards and get an
update on what's Happening as the
players fight it out now let's bring up
our birds eye view and I see on the top
right bhardia dhaneshwar has been such a
huge player for the Bulldogs he's been a
massive scorer in that team he's up
against Benjamin Bach and you mentioned
it's an end game but this is a fiery end
game the bishop has landed on F6 and
Robert I think we have to do a deep dive
into this one yeah I just wanted to note
as well that five on a core one looked
like he had a nice advantage against
Paulina happens in the board one versus
Board four matchups but dineshfar here
he is the lower rated player he's the
board three for the Bulldogs against the
board too for the archbishops and
Benjamin Bakken I love this position for
white you're about to slam a rook down
on D7 because black has to take this
Knight the E5 Pawn is under attack two
different times so if you move your king
which is in check everybody then you
lose the pawn so you have to take but
with a rook on D7 and the next for
coming over this bishop can even slide
over to H3 and cause black some problems
here I'm liking the look of this for
white and yet the engine says Ah what
are you talking about blocks doing okay
the game that we just saw right now with
the connect back for E4 has been played
you're hitting that night white has to
fall back with the Knight and whether
you go to D2 or to E1 the F Pawn can
advance further all the way to F5 defend
that pawn on e4 lock out that bishop and
G2 you're talking about Connect Four
well here it will be connect three with
very similar Dynamics as in the Alice
League game earlier yeah it's going to
be annoying for this light Square Bishop
for white and his Rook on D7 which looks
so promising once this Knight moves this
Knight can hop forward to E5 you
mentioned that in the other game it
kicks The Rook hits the pawn on C4 so it
looks like Benjamin Buck is just in time
to Parry off the threats because if he
was delayed for a single move it's no
exaggeration he could have been nearly
lost with white so active with the Rook
on D7 a second Rook appearing on the D
file a bishop maybe sliding out here to
poke and prod at Black's position so E4
very timely shot by Benjamin Bach
wow but I still think there is some
Precision here required as well white
can fall back with that Knight to E1
hitting that pawn on e4 Robin you can
jump in with the Knight to E5 but white
will anyway double up on the D file I'm
still liking white stances I see our
eval bars say that the position is
pretty even but it just looks like it's
going to be easier for white hair to
double up on the D file to start
targeting the queen side pawns here and
wow is Benjamin Bach down to two minutes
40 seconds on the clock that is a
massive massive advantage to Bard there
yes uh surprising to see that Benjamin
bug spent so much time by his position
hopefully for him is getting easier to
play because he can't play F5 and he
does and the King they need to go to E8
to kick this Rook away or go up to F7
this Rook slides over to d8 eventually
once the king gets out the way and I
just get the sense that unless bardia
can come up with a concrete threat that
the worst is behind black I mean you
just connect the Rooks you trade him and
then it seems like you're not in any big
trouble
all right while bardia is trying to
create trouble but it looks like
Benjamin is in time it looks like
Paulina might not be in time in her game
against Fabi let's bring up our bird's
eye view let's just spin out of this and
take a look at what is happening on the
top board for the Saint Louis Archbishop
because I do see that Fabi has got a
huge advantage on his match okay so
let's get that bird's eye view up let's
look in the top left as Tanya was saying
oh goodness that wow is sinking low and
that's because that Knight has sunk its
teeth into the C3 Square in the top left
we will bring up that board and by the
way in the bottom right Alice Lee looks
like she's in trouble as well that's
what happens in these board one board
four match-ups but Tanya you called our
attention here there's a knight on C3
looking promising but where's The
Knockout Punch coming from
I'm not seeing it but I'm loving black
spawn structure and I don't see three
you pointed out also look at the pawn
structure there we've got a beep on
which is already a passer and one of the
things that stands out is this potential
pain along the a to G8 diagonal and tabi
immediately takes advantage of that
plant says Bishop on D5 what a nice spot
they're hitting that queen and the
Knight a huge x-ray there the big
question here is is white in time with
the move E4 and Paulina says she's got a
plate but I see our eval bar it seems to
say it's not possible I still don't see
oh wow oh my God what is happening here
what a move you can't take on B4 Robert
because the bishop on C4 hangs what
calculation Fabi in beast mode today
yeah because the queen has to look at
this how do you stay in touch with the
bishop good A2 the Knight takes you you
move anywhere else over here here you
lose the bishop for free and if you go
Queen takes before after the Queens are
traded here I'm gonna put this on the
board it just takes two seconds
everybody trade Queens Rook takes C4
that that's an extra piece that's a pass
Pawn that is game over in Fabiano
caruana's favor so we look at this
position I actually think that unless
you might resign because she's playing a
super GM who's played for a world
championship title she's gonna be
without a minor piece and without any
chances in this game that might be the
knockout blow that I was asking about
it is indeed the one and we saw the eval
bar say Well done Fabi this was the way
to go E4 looks like a blunder but it was
such a natural move by Paulina trying to
get rid of that Bishop there really
wasn't much that could have been done
she moves back to Queen to B2 the bishop
is snapped up this as you mentioned is
game over territory Fabi they're looking
super strong super calm Molina just
playing it out it is a team event you
want to try and keep going but I don't
believe this is going to last more than
a couple of moves now it's a clean extra
night with a pass Pawn to boot so 500
carwana he has this win locked up he
took a drink I don't what kind of cup
was that did you see that I love it that
one was very fancy schmancy stuff
I don't know what is in the cup I don't
know what kind of cup it is but I want
what he's had
[Music]
well he is it is seemed to be working
for him whatever he's drinking he's got
a winning position with the black pieces
in about 30 moves beating one of the
strongest uh players here in the protest
league for the fourth board Paulina
shavalova going down to Fabiano caruana
yeah look at that a pawn
this can't be stopped it's a night
protecting although there is a trick The
Rook is threatening to take here well
you can't do it just yet but the Knight
is pinned to this Rook unfortunately for
white there's a back ranked Checkmate so
even though this looks fancy you're
gonna steal a pawn for free you'll get
checkmates or white has to spend even
more time just to get out of it and I
think black could say let's get out of
this pin by going for the back Rank and
the pass Pawn as well there this looks
like a black should have this one in the
back maybe bring the Rook to B4 and to
B1 is a better move order but either way
it looks like Fabiano's taking this and
that's gonna be good news for the
archbishops to get out to an early lead
I love it I love the idea I've just put
your Rook on the B file take advantage
of the back crank weakness that white
has and you're threatening Rook we want
to promote the queen so are we taking it
a bit slow he just wants to be super
precise on this one but this is
definitely going Saint Louis
archbishop's way I'm actually quite
surprised at how much time Fabi is
taking in this position
it's very instructive for everybody that
when you have a winning position you
know you're winning there's no need to
rush and it does play Rook B8 so he's
giving up this Knight on C3 but if we
just can quickly analyze this for a
second here it's it's a really important
thing to note that when you have a Pawn
on A2 you need to get your Rook to that
last Square to break the blockade down
so after Rook takes Knight we're gonna
analyze this we might not even have to
because 500 is showing it he could all
right we don't even need the
announcement he was too fast Rook B4 at
the end unfortunately for white your
Pawn is too slow because this is not
just a check it's a mate the King has no
left it's all war here and this king is
the losing the battle
wow and it only if there was one pawn
move in front of the king then white
could have actually Advanced her own
deep on all the way to D7 but that's not
a possibility anymore so Fabi they're
combining all these tactical ideas to
finish the game Rook B1 and now you take
on A1 of D7 you give it oh he could have
given a Chuck anyone but he does go the
other way Rook D1 that is some stunning
tactics and that is it
is Advantage St Louis Archbishop as
Fabiano caruana takes the first point he
doesn't he goes away Fabiano has left
the building so we should go to the
teammates because the three games are
still in session 500 gets the first win
baton as we look at the Evo bars
throughout these matches it looks like
in the bottom left we haven't even
checked that came out in which is a bit
better but still that's an end game
territory and in the bottom right Alice
Lee she's fighting she's giving it all
she can possibly give which game should
we go to of the remaining three well
it's end game territory in all of them
but I see a Benjamin bogged down to 70
in seconds on the clock with a minor
piece and game and we know how tricky
these can be a very symmetrical Pawn
structure we see on the top right just
how equal the position looks according
to the eval bar but with 17 seconds
anything can happen here
yeah no the mistakes happen when you
don't have time the good news is
mistakes usually happen when your
opponent has Knights but Benjamin is the
one with both the knights so there are
no night Forks the F5 Pawn is the only
Pawn that this bishop can attack and
it's going to be upon race potentially
because I'm already looking and you know
our Dia is thinking what if I trade all
the minor pieces here and maybe we can
bring up an analysis board and just look
at it very quickly because the king is
about to Sprint for white so as we just
look at this line after Knight takes
Knight Knight takes back Bishop takes
I'm already thinking is the white king
just running up the board here and Tanya
if the king tries to defend the answer
is absolutely the bar goes up because
the king doesn't get the G7 in time your
king cannot move like a knight even if
you know you would like it too so after
the swap on C6 in the live board after
Knight C6 once we trade all these pieces
here I think the black king will have to
go in the other direction and this is so
hard to calculate when you don't have
enough time
and that's exactly what bhardia is
thinking he's gone into a long thing
here because he is trying to figure out
and navigate his way all through these
calculations that you pointed out Robert
will he go for the King Pawn ending this
is a big moment and as you're pointing
out the analysis white takes the pawn
black takes the pawn it is a race but it
looks like black might just be in time
it wouldn't matter because you have to
be careful where you place the king it
might come up under check when you Queen
on h8 so D4 might not be a very accurate
Square very important details for
Benjamin to take care of which is
seconds on the clock yeah said that I
put the King on a better Square because
that would be right because then when we
get this Mutual promotion right
simultaneous acqueen in here the
difference is that once this queen
happens it's not checked to this King on
D4 it's a very important point and that
means black can actually steal this
opponent F4 it's a good call by you
Tanya and that is what bardia dinesha is
gonna go for it that was what's going to
happen Robert the more time he takes
on ending on this one
could actually be good for black so it
puts Benjamin on the spot he needs to
find the moves quickly it's happening
he's traded the bishop for the night
yeah and is he gonna go this way or is
he gonna give this fork and try to take
the pawn but then the Knight gets a bit
trapped over there maybe that's
something
yeah 95 going have to see we're just
gonna Pawn race no matter which way we
look at it
I'm predicting a Kingpin I think and
it's happening the line that we were
just looking at it's going to appear on
the board we see white racing towards
the H Pawn black picking up the C Pawn
he needs to find the right Square for
the king don't go to D4 Robert do not do
that don't go D4 and for white critical
moment here if you go to G5 you actually
are gonna lose the game that looks like
the most natural move protecting your
Pawn we just showed you a simultaneous
Queenie situation where black wins this
Pawn but if we can bring up the
announcement word ever so quickly King
G5 is a bad move because the black king
steps back and if white has hopes of
promoting after C4 H5 I don't just push
my Pawn I can do that but King E6 this
is of critical importance if you push I
go back if you push again I stop you in
your tracks I win your Pawn so that is
bad news for uh bardia dinesfar he goes
King G6 he realizes that he needs to
keep the king out of there but we just
looked at this Tanya black is gonna
promote win this pawn and I just feel
like white has no real winning chances
at the end of the line
want to win the F5 Pawn first because
after you move your king to D3
actually black queens first so you do
pick up the F4 pawn and then white has
to give a few checks so this will just
fizzle out into checks and white picking
up the F5 Pawn picking up the F4 Pawn
both players find the right Square for
the King this is the line that we were
looking at black Queen's first Robert
you set queen F4 now Queen H3 check is a
possibility Queen d8 check is a
possibility it looks like black will
just not be in time to hide the king
anywhere
yeah no this looks like uh as you're
saying the queen can give a check and
the black king has nowhere to run but
maybe it's just gonna Dart over here and
go after this Pawn so to be very very
careful if you are Borneo Dinesh for it
now he's the one as well as Buck down in
some time trouble but yeah if he can
just take this pawn it should be an easy
draw this is the wrong remaining Pawn in
a king upon end game because I think
actually can you can take it already
the king gets back to C2 in time
that's nicely pointed out that you take
on F5 and queen F5 King F5 and we see
this happen wow these players have
calculated it in just seconds that is
some precise end game play and now white
white king will March over to the queen
side when black captures on A2 White's
King needs to land on C2 and that is an
elementary draw in these positions the
players know it and they're playing it
out to Perfection right the king as long
as it gets to these two squares
everybody C2 or C1 this King has to go
back and then the white king sits at the
corner this is a draw by stalemate that
means it is a still lead for the
archbishops one and a half in their
favor
yeah and I'm just wondering who is happy
about this result out of the two of them
because badia he really took his time to
go into this kingpawn ending but it
looked like he'd calculated all the way
through and Benjamin Bach escapes what
could have been a more difficult
position to save in seconds we've got
action on still that bottom left board
it looks like the Bulldogs are going to
score on that one let's bring that up uh
the Alexander injure game we haven't had
a look at it wow this is a complicated
end game what on Earth is happening it
looks like White's King might be getting
checkmated uh the white king is looking
like it's in trouble because how many
squares that it does have these light
squares so if the black king somehow
could jump forward and that's why taking
the Knight on H6 bringing into Kink
forward to help deliver that Checkmate
and Tanya I'm doing a quick material
count black is up one Pawn H3 is already
in this Rook size A4 looks like it's
some trouble do not take this Pawn you
will get checkmated after King to F3
very quick line King F3 your King has
nowhere to run if you go this way still
the Knight takes away the square yeah if
you run the other way you're still
getting made it
the only move is King to G1 and I think
you still get checks and then eventually
give a check on G2 and that also looks
like it should be winning some Knight G3
that you're pointing out why would white
get one night stuck on 86 and The Rook
stuck on A6 would be a bad idea he says
I'm not gonna let that happen
no and doesn't but unfortunately two
pawns down there's still some chances
what white needs to do is get rid of all
of these pawns even if it costs you your
night that will give you a shot in this
game and the moves The Rook slid over
here I actually think that white is
going to hold
it's so difficult while you do pick up
the G6 Pawn white has to try to give up
that night for the pawn but even rub it
if it goes into a rook at night versus
Rook black can still play on forever but
you're right this looks like it'll end
in a draw the last board remaining would
be the Alice Lee board let's take a
quick look at that the players are
playing on seconds and what oh my God
oh my goodness nothing I wish you won
and look at her the surprise on her face
she can't believe it but she has taken
down super Grand Master bowed on Daniel
dayas this might be the best game of her
life as she wins for her archbishops and
you can see it there is that smile from
Alice Lee look how happy she is right
now how does she do this she did it
against Michael bluebomb she almost did
it again and now when it matters the
more she takes down the top part of the
Croatian Bulldogs Alice Lee is a
superstar
Wow Let's go back in time to see how
this happened because we just watched a
humongous upset Alice Lee wins with the
white pieces over Bogue down Daniel dead
she is still smiling she's trying to
gather herself but she's also this is
amazing she's doing the chess player
thing she's looking over the game and at
this point in time Tanya if you just
look here it just seems like black is
much better up a pawn but she fought she
did not give up and she just tried to
activate her pieces oops sorry I'm
pressing back instead of forward we see
the Knight go into the center but black
is dominating right black is just up a
pawn making progress here so where did
it go wrong for both I think around here
telling you the Knight gets into D6 and
now it's a now both sides of chances and
Bug them just 10 seconds remaining
Robin it went wrong for a
Alice Lee what a player she's been for
her team an amazing result and actually
with that win she guarantees the point
to her team St Louis Archbishop and
takes them over to the finish line and
this is where we stand after round one I
am still getting over what we just
witnessed she is just 13 years old she's
a woman International Master with two
International masternams it's clear
she's made it clear with a breakout
performance here at the protest League
just the bright future that she has
ahead of her right now it looks like the
Saint Louis archbishops are the one with
the bright future ahead of them with the
3-1 lead over the Croatia Bulldogs what
around Robert
I can't believe it I mean we you know
I'm gonna have to go through that game
again but Alice Lee she is doing some
heavy lifting for her team coming into
this match we're talking about it she
has been punching up and there's no more
up to go than board one for the other
team so Alice Lee I mean she is a
superstar in the making we had 500
carwana on for an interview he says he
could see her becoming a Grandmaster for
sure but after a win like that hey maybe
GM would just be the start we don't want
to put pressure on her she seems to just
be having fun but Alice Lee with perhaps
the biggest win of the protest League
season thus far
and that you are the most critical
moment the most crucial match for her
team Robert where she's got three big
rounds also coming up so she has to keep
up that same energy it almost feels like
she's played her part but Champions
never get complacent and I am sure we've
got a lot more coming up with Alice Lee
ahead of us now we know that this is the
final week for the main season the main
event of the protest league but the
drama and the action on chess.com never
stops because the teams will be back for
the arena Royale on March 24th now it's
been difficult to watch so many great
teams being eliminated from the main
season these past few weeks even the
teams with a losing record have
exhibited incredible play Robert this
whole season so to celebrate all of the
talent that we've got here with us on
the PCL we are hosting an arena Royale
on the March 24th you don't want to miss
that it is going to feature all the 16
teams who will be playing with up to 10
players competing from each team it's
going to be an epic show on the 24th
March mark your calendars you don't want
to miss this use the command exclamation
mark Royale in the chat for all the
details
yeah it's gonna be fun right it's just
all the players even those who are
eliminated they get to come back and
take part so it's a nice kind of end or
All-Star game if you want to call it for
the pro chess League season
I love it can't wait for that what I
can't wait for right now is to see the
action that's coming up on the other
side of this break do not go anywhere
[Music]
foreign
I cover the entire 184 185 Spectrum so
all the openings that arises after our
one E4
I have had a lot of experience in this
I've played several games with
prominence out of game against Levon
aronium from the world team championship
I also hit a game from Gibraltar against
Marcus ragger which is the game that I'm
gonna show here
the key here when this happens when your
opponent finds a resource of playing F4
or you've reached this position in your
calculations don't panic
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
thank you
[Music]
honestly has been the headliner for the
Saint Louis archbishops as they take the
lead in their match against the Bulldogs
with a 3-1 score and truly the star of
the round the hero of the round is this
13 year old what a performance what a
game Robert there against the top Board
of the Bulldogs taking down poke down
Daniel diac it feels like every second
we have to update her biography because
in it we see she beat a Matthias blue
bound rate at 2650 we see Alice on
screen here she was just ecstatic she's
trying to remain composed now because
she has three more chess games to play
but I think we want to take everybody
through the Finishing Touch of her win
over a booked on Daniel dayas because
Tanya that was actually some great stuff
from the youngster she's playing in her
opponent's time travel and at this point
after Bogue down Dino takes the pawn on
A3 tunnel she plays B5 giving up another
Pawn but springing free a passer because
after Pawn takes Rook D5 look at this
the Knight is pinned in under attack the
bishop is loose and she just was able to
secure Victory from here
stuff and that also playing on seconds
against a grand master who's rated
around 400 points more than you just
Fearless play there she has truly been
the star of the Saint Louis archbishops
for so many matches and it continues
today Fabiano caruana might be leading
the team from the top but it is this
fourth board Alice Lee who really played
and you're playing out the end game
Robert from such a young player this
shows so much maturity to be able to
take this point not in some tactical
Skirmish in the middle game but to
outplay your opponent in an end game
I mean just instant replay one more time
down a pawn here gives up another just
to Spring free a pass Bond and as we're
highlighting here the minor pieces are
all loose black and only 5.9 seconds
left not enough time for bugs on Daniels
but the time of her life for Alice Lee
She's phenomenal but it's three to one
St Louis right now Tanya we can
celebrate her victories if you're the
archbishops but she needs to keep it up
and so does the rest of the squad
well there's definitely work to be done
still for the Saint Louis archbishops
and the Bulldogs are going to try to
make sure that they don't become
successful in doing just that let's take
a look at the round that's coming up and
we see it's going to be Fabi against
bardia now bardia has been quite the
surprise package there with the Bulldogs
scoring some heavy points of Sabi needs
to watch out there with the white pieces
and we see at the bottom of the board
Alice Lee takes on her second Grand
Master of the day Alexander Intech
doesn't get easier just because the
rating may get a little bit lower it's
hardly getting easier when you play a
Grand Master of the Grand Master and for
Alice and the archbishops they are in a
great spot right now they have a lead
Fabiano gets the job done on the top
board Alice Lee with the upset of the
entire protest season but Fabiano he's
back at it he gets the white pieces
against bardia dinesfar I tell you we've
seen our Dia throughout the season I
mean he may be sleeping on his move
right now but he has been fully
attentive to the chess throughout and
he's had some good performances
if he's played the system
or a strong fight there in the middle
game goes for the very combative opening
and we see their Fabiano taking some
sort of what is it some sort of a hybrid
alapin that might go into a friend setup
what is even going on here
well I think what Fabiano is trying to
do is he loves the center and we see
that white has Connect Four upon all the
way up to D to E5 and F6 is played he's
got a chip at that pawn Center so a big
question for Fabiano do you take on F6
now do you protect the pawn on E5 with
another piece because it is under attack
by three different black pieces here
while white only has two Defenders so
I've been us thinking Tanya I'm
wondering you know is he really super
familiar with the position the answer
seems to be yes they did take that pause
which makes me wonder if he left his
book
well it's hard to prepared with these
offbeat openings and I think that has
been bardia's Focus as well throughout
the protest League he's been playing
these lines which are not super
conventional and then taking his
opponents off a Mainline Theory and we
see that well there was no French so no
E6 was played instead strikes in the
center opens it up at night from F6 can
head to E5 at some point it can also
head to F4 wire H5 F4 meanwhile
whitesnite is heading to E5 white with
the Lost move Fabi has defended that
default Pawn so definitely eyeing a
knight jump over to the E5 Square yes
big decisions for both sides because
it's not a typical Pawn structure we see
the semi-openf file but a semi-open e
file so both players they're looking to
use their Rooks to their advantage and
black does go first with Knight H5
trying to go F4 a ton I think a lot of
people say can I just take a pawn isn't
that free I even have my Bishop
defending it but what's that pawn on D4
doing it's stopping E5 and I can see you
shaking your head you're like no no no
no no I'm not taking this Pawn just to
see what that looks like and you have
two Pawns in the center and black is
just spring forward
I was holding my breath when you went
for this line because I thought you'll
take on C5 You'll Play E5 and the bar
would be like white is completely
winning now but it does confirm that in
fact the center is much stronger than
getting greedy and going for that pawn
as you're mentioning E4 coming in this f
file open White's Queen is stuck to
defending that Knight on F3 always watch
out for Bishop H3 tactics in these
positions as well so there would be just
too much for white to be careful about I
like this move Knight H5 Robert had
mentioned it the Black Knight can find
itself over to F4 and really putting
pressure on fabi's King side I am liking
pardias position here
it's a really tough call right now for
Fabiano because I like ordia's position
no matter if it's even material or even
if Fabiano is up a pawn so I'm like
maybe I should just take the pawn right
let me take this pawn and I don't like
my position but you need to prove that
you have enough compensation and that's
very difficult in Rapid chess because E5
wouldn't be the end of the world the
bishop could slide back yes white is a
bit passive black is gaining space in
the center of the board but maybe there
will be some chances for Fabiano in that
line
he's never gonna take
it doesn't feel like a Fabby move to
give so much activity in the center and
you know when I say these kind of things
never it's never going to happen it
usually always does but I will be
surprised if Fabi decides to get greedy
with the pawn and give up the initiative
and Robert he wants to keep things under
control he continues with development
that's very Fabi style play allowing E5
just seemed way too dangerous now this
position will a hundred percent heat up
and we'll have to jump straight back
into it at some point but for now I see
the actions on on the other boards and
there's one Bird that's already hot hot
hot let's bring up our bird's eye view
because what on Earth is going on on
that top right screen rabbit we've got
White's Rook which has done a rook left
onto H3 black has already castled whites
King is in the center which Pawn is on
H5 that is that is intense action what
10 moves down
yeah the top right game is fascinating
and just you know it's one of those
openings where you throw your file the H
file The Rook file Pawn up the board and
you have the Rook lifting to H3 but the
question is what attack do you have is
this a love is he just hoping that an
attack against the king will come out of
nowhere and this isn't the levitov chest
Wizards right you can't just make magic
happen so Tony I'm asking you sincerely
is white doing the right thing is there
a legitimate attack in this position
you know it's definitely Brewing up I
would be really scared one of the plans
as black hair because one of the plans
that are very typical is to line up a
battery on the b187 diagonal at some
point the Bishop from a D3 can fall back
to C2 the queen can jump to D3 white
spawn will advance to E5 and you can
already start to see mating ideas along
this diagonal now meanwhile uh black
develops the Knight to C6 I'm slightly
surprised because I thought that black
needs to keep that Knight there so that
Bishop can come to A6 and you can start
trying to trade off pieces but
goodness is that if you fall back with
the bishop to C2 to defend that D4 Pawn
she'll have a jump on B4 so she's still
trying to play actively to counter
White's attacking idea of setting up the
battery
yes and this Pawn on D4 is actually
hanging sometimes when you see a queen
in line with another with a bishop in
between you look can I move this bishop
away with some check the answer is not
here so Knight takes D4 is a threat and
E5 shouldn't be counted out either with
the rook in The Bishop's line of fire
you could push that pawn up the board so
Tanya do you have to make a move like
Bishop B5 then just to protect the D4
Pawn well it does move the bishop to
protect the pawn on D4 but slides back
to E2 it's a mistake which means E5 we
have the help of the Eva bar off the
side that's a double attack in the
position
wow yeah and that Rook Cliff that we
were talking about so only The Rook on
H3 is vulnerable who would have thought
E5 coming in will pelina chevalova find
this move it's not an easy move to spot
uh wow and he said it might not be easy
for you guys but here I am plagues plays
it out in under a minute on her clock
hits that Rook on H3 hits the center
Pawn on D4 uh she does see that
Benjamin's King is still in the center
it's time to open it up and the eval Bar
says with that move it's Advantage
Paulina and I'm trying to understand
what does Benjamin have in mind and it
looks like you know we look at him like
he doesn't have too much I think he
missed this idea altogether
and at this point right whether or not
he missed it and I think you're right he
did you just have to get the most out of
your position and I would play the move
D5 so I have two options either I give
up my Rook for this bishop that's
seemingly a two-point swing by five
versus three but we don't just count in
points because if you move the Rook
you'll only be down quote unquote one
point but it's a very important Pawn in
the center and I think that that
position is actually more difficult for
white to play and he does go for it he
didn't want to give up the exchange but
I think I would have tried to lock the
center and given up The Rook but he's
just saying all right Knight takes D4
for example you can I guess their E5
Pawn is loose but I don't know about
this Tanya I feel like it has to be
really really good for Paulina no matter
how she takes this Pawn on D4
yeah I feel you because white skin on E1
suddenly looks extremely loose though
you know after Knight D4 that night on
D4 is so strong at some point the black
Bishop will come to B7 uh and it looks
like white is going to take a long time
to get to Black's King so things under
control here the other the other way
that she could recapture the default
Pawn is with her own E5 Pawn I think
what Benjamin has in mind for E takes D4
where Paulina does win upon is to Simply
get the bishop to B2 start piling up the
pressure on the D4 pawn and hope that
you can get to G7 even those positions
with blacks Bishop coming to F6 to
really challenge that long diagonal it
looks like everything's under control
here for black uh Paulina doing well out
of the opening here
yeah no this is a good position for her
and she's doing the right thing by
slowing down because there are two
different ways she can take this Pawn on
D4 if she wants it I'm also wondering if
at some point there's a bishop takes H6
type of tactic it might not work here
but sometimes just you know you give up
a bishop open up the uh opposing King
but I just feel like she can safely take
on D4
Robert that's a brilliant idea and I
just I just to demonstrate that let's
just make a non-move here for example A5
or Rook B8 I'm loving the concept that
you have you take on 86 and Bishop takes
it and I see that eval bar approves and
queen C1 Queen C1 was the point and it
seems to work because it's a double
attack you hit the Knight and you're
threatening mate in one with Queen at
six that is a massive tactics that
exists in this position wow you know
what's funny is I was thinking Queen D2
this little sideways queen move is
actually much more difficult than it
would appear Queen D2 is natural let's
get the quit up the board round to the
side but it is a double attack and Tanya
I think you've actually highlighted the
downside of playing politics D4 that
Bishop takes H6 after G takes H6 there's
still maybe this queen C1 idea hitting
the Knight and hitting the pawn because
if you play Queen E6 which seems to
defend both then look at this
think Rook G6 works I mean this is
incredible stuff there's a microwave
behind Benjamin Buck the action would
absolutely heat up here because after
you take the Rook Queen H6 check King
Jade Pawn takes G6 and uh excuse me that
looks like a Checkmate against this
black king you see the bars at plus it
looks like plus 13. it's just game over
it doesn't matter it could be a plus
hundred this is made in the next move
you're not surviving it you move the
Rook it's still Queen at seven and
followed by Queen AJ Checkmate this
would be game over so it's really
fascinating to see the kind of tactics
that exist in the position there's a
third move that's been played one that
we were not considering doesn't take on
D4 pushes the bishop so she's still
targeting that Rook on G3 Bishop H4 is
actually quite interesting Robert
because if white decides to trade that
Bishop for the Knight the queen suddenly
becomes super powerful on H4 it's Pawn
on e4 is threatening Queen H1 and don't
forget notice the D4 Pawn still hangs I
like this
I think Bishop H4 is a brilliant move I
see the Eva bark went from better for
black to in the middle but I think it's
a great choice by her because she takes
away these Bishop takes H6 options D4 is
still loose as you're mentioning and if
you take on H4 and the queen gets out
here I think you're in some pretty big
trouble so I think this one both players
will start using their time here but
Bishop H4 was a good choice by Alina
move on to the bird's eye view to finish
your point if white does go for the 86
sacrifice black can pick up the Rook on
G3 doesn't even have to bother picking
up that Bishop on 86 so everything
remains safe for black really nice
practical move as you're pointing out
let's take a look at the other boards
let's bring up our bird's eye viewers
action is heating up all around and
again my eyes are drawn to the bottom
right because it's Madness there one
more time Alice Lee Unstoppable on the
king side she's really going for it
she's playing against Grandmaster
Alexander inject but we see the position
there with the pawn March Fearless play
there by Alice and on the bottom left we
see that Bogdan Daniel diac who suffered
suffered a major upset in the first
round looks like he's back in control in
his game yeah it looks like the board
won the top left five in a carwana also
has a slight pull against bartier
dineshfar but those games on the
left-hand side they're kind of locked up
for the most part whereas the game's on
the right hand side just seems like much
more open space kind of hectic positions
so you get your two different options
whatever your flavor is you can choose
between them so Tanya speaking of
choosing I'm gonna make you do it sorry
partner which game do you want to dive
into
well I like being right so we're gonna
go for the right side and we're gonna
pick up the bottom right board there
with Alice Lee against Alexander inject
the position just looks super fun there
with Alice's Queen in the center so
let's do a deep dive on to that one it's
really heating up a pawn has been traded
on G3 opening up the f file and the F2
Pawn looked very tender Bishop F5 she
defends the pawn on E6 where our eval
Bar says hold on that's a mistake
yeah well it's as it takes a little bit
more time gains a little bit of depth
it's saying that was a mistake but it's
probably not one that's easy to
recognize if you don't have the engine
as your assistant so why would that be a
mistake well I would like to play G4 as
white but of course I can't get away
with that there's a queen and Bishop in
line with it so maybe Knight C2 first
let's kick this queen out of here and I
just want to get at this bishop that's
my big goal perhaps the Knight slides
into E3 so I don't even have to push my
Pawn but I feel like maybe now White's
pieces can join the party where this
Knight is sitting and doing nothing
because the D3 Pawn is already defended
enough times
that's really interesting that you want
to get your pieces out by actually big
tempos hitting that Queen on D4 that I
was just mentioning when we jumped into
this game looks like such a powerful
piece and after Knight C2 it's kind of
hard to see a very stable Square you've
got to fall back all the way with the
queen go back to D7 your idea of D4 well
it looks like inject needs to find that
because if not then black has got ideas
of her own Alice might be threatening
Bishop G4 next notice how the pawn on F2
is spin so you can't really go F3 so
it's really all about timing and inject
needs to be precise right now this is
his moment to push back on the pressure
yes and he both players uh they're about
the same of the clock now he has just
dropped a little bit below her uh in
terms of the time but if we look at the
material it is even five pounds per side
two minor pieces two Rooks and a queen
but the board is so open it's not just
about the material and it's a
complicated position I don't think that
they're easy choices here I mentioned
Knight C2 the queen slides back to D7
the question is and then what that's
hard to recognize for white because you
see one-off moves every here and there
but the actual plan is not that
straightforward so I actually think that
this is a very complicated game and the
result of it will be determined are down
the line not right now it's also super
impressive how Alice has created this
complicated Dynamics on the board but
also maintains the balance on the clock
which is so easy to lose out on when
you're playing against a strong player
to really play good quality chess but
also burn the clock we see an equal time
here and as our chart is pointing out in
fact Al is slightly ahead on the clock
in a very complex game so things look
like they're in control in this one
let's bring up our bird's eye view
because I see with our eval bars things
are getting out of control on some other
boards let's just zoom out for a moment
and quickly take a look at the bird's
eye view top left that we see Fabiano
caruana once again with a big Advantage
we see index board but we know that
one's a complicated game and Robert on
top right Benjamin Bach with wow still
on that position with the Rook still
hanging what just happened there the
knights got traded off it looks like
Benjamin is doing well there
yeah Benjamin Buck you know he has been
such a great player for the archbishops
all season long his position the top
right that's looking fascinating because
some other Bishop is still staring at
the Rook even though some moves have
been played and then in the bottom left
bogdon Dental deoxy looks like he's in
charge just like Fabiano and by the way
bardia didn't ask for under 40 seconds
right now against carwana
I think we've got to jump to that one
how will he handle the pressure against
one of the best players in the world
playing on seconds there bardaya Danish
were against Fabi in what looks like a
really difficult position Robert let's
see if we can do a deep dive into that
one Fabi in driver's seat in this one
and that's all because of that big
weakness on E6 he goes Rook C3 so
shifting that Rook to the open C file
and not easy to find a good Square
because the Rook will jump onto the
seventh rank
and by the way this queen like it's on
F4 but it's looking like it's running
out of squares I could see a future
where 95 happens and then a rook to F3
things of that nature and so Knight d8
Tanya protecting E6 you pointed out as
the big weakness in Black's position
there's no activity right you have a
rook and a queen staring into the
nothingness over here the bishop is
staring into the Rook the Knight is
retreating and of course Fabi jumps his
Knight forward to E5
well you called it he plays it and after
95 he keeps all the threats alive the
white
so instead bharathia slides with the
queen preempting that he goes Queen H4
the only thing that Fabi needs to be
careful about is it doubling up on the f
file that F2 Pawn can in certain
situations be extremely tender but I
think it should be easy enough to defend
that Robert but that's the counter play
that bardia is looking at will he be
able to put pressure on F2 that's what
he needs to do and this Knight by the
way can keep hopping Hit The Rook on F6
try to win this Pawn on B6 but I love
your move Rook C8 just pinned this
Knight back here I feel like black is
completely tied down with no major
threats the Knight on B5 defends this
Pawn on D4 so if you think about
stealing a pawn uh you're gonna Gambit
your queen and not in a good way so this
Knight on B5 is doing great work this
Rook can slam down on the C8 Tanya was
16.4 seconds left playing against
Fabiano caruana in this kind of form I
do not envy the task of bardia De
neshvar
fine I I mean that just shows the kind
of nerves and the control that he has
but that's exactly what you need in this
protest League format but things are
getting more difficult Fabi plays a
prophylactic move he defends that F2
Pawn with the move Rook F1 before taking
action on the C file and bardia plays
Bishop f8 now your move Rook to see it
with the last move bardia wanted to
activate his Bishop perhaps eyeing that
B4 square or trying to at least keep the
D6 Square under control so that White's
Knight cannot jump over with Knight D6
things are getting more difficult we see
the eval bar screaming and G3 in there
is that game over I I think it is I
think you just Fork the rook and the
queen because a queen trade will be an
immediate win four yeah rookie four I
think you can even just take this queen
over on H4 and then have Knight C7 ideas
at the end there's just too much going
on uh down on the back rank so maybe
Knight C7 to start with don't even push
the pawn is good enough uh but he plays
G3 and I guess P4 goodness for the f
file
Knight C7
The Rook is trapped The Rook on E8 is
just trapped yeah he can just go for
that yeah this is just looking this is
this game over for black now Knight C7
and Fabi do doing that thing that he did
against Paulina where he knows it's
winning but he slows down just a little
bit you mentioned this is such an
instructive strategy when you know
you're winning don't Blitz out your
moves he wants to be precise and he
wants to wrap it up he does it in style
the move that you mentioned it's and
that is it wrapping it up on the spot
with Knight C7 wins the material Fabi
once again taking that point for his
theme but of course we've got action on
on the other boards let's quickly bring
up bird's eye view this was a
devastating loss for bardia in Grand
Style by Fabi but look at the bottom
boards down there boges in the bottom
left with a huge advantage against
Nicholas theodoro and then in the bottom
right it looks like Alexander injured he
is trying to do what Bogue Don Daniel
could not and he has a sky-high
advantage against Alice Lee so
unfortunately for the archbishops they
have a big lead but those two boards are
going the Bulldogs way in the top right
Tanya that one looks like anyone's
contest as Rock once again in time
trouble
not only that I mean you look at the
eval bar it says it's even but the
position is crazy we've got to rush to
that one because it Benjamin Bach we're
just seconds on the clock the Queens
have been traded off what on Earth is
happening it looks like Paulina has
everything under control let's bring up
that board Robert
yeah I mean look at this position what's
going on this Pawn on B6 is loose this
King on E1 is almost checkmated like if
this Rook were to take the pawn the
bishop slides into C3 that King is
nowhere to go because the other Bishop
takes away the F1 Square so I feel like
if you are Paulina you want to make use
of the fact that uh Benjamin's in some
time trouble but it's not easy to figure
out a plan for black because these
Bishops got to give them credit they're
taking away key squares from the Rooks
doubling on the D file doesn't seem to
do all that much
this is blunder territory it's so easy
that in an even position you just get
checkmated in one you've got to make
sure that the King on E1 doesn't get
into any more trouble because that won't
be trouble that will be game over B5 has
been played so the B6 Pawn is now
defended but can't continue pursuing
that pawn with moves like Rook B7
targeting trying to trade off pieces as
much as possible it's on the board
yeah but this Rook is coming over to A8
to get this Pawn over here so it feels
like they might trade off the pawns and
if everything gets straight over here I
do think we are seeing liquidation and
what looks likely to be a split of the
point so Tanya I mean this one it's been
a hard-fought game both sides had their
chances but now I think we will likely
see peace though there is a possibility
for this bishop to get the G6 if this
bishop gets here that black king in the
corner could be in huge danger so I
don't know how you get there and well
the answer is not you're not a trade
which means that I think we can go on
over to a new game yeah the trade is
essentially a draw for for any chances
those pieces have to be kept alive but
black hat tricks of his of her
squares under control the Rooks will be
traded off this will be fizzled out H5
Pawn can be picked up but it won't be
enough the white king will be super
active King C2 will Target the E4 Pawn
uh Robert this is going to and I think
we can say that this is very close to
draw territory let's bring up our bird's
eye view yeah because Tanya all of a
sudden the boards are going wrong for
the Bulldogs in the bottom left it looks
like Nicholas Theodore has fought well
he's holding on but Alice Lee in the
bottom right I don't know how she does
it but she actually is the one with a
huge Advantage let's Dive Right into
that game because Alice Lee is able to
dive into the white king side and
deliver Checkmate on H1
and that's an extra piece that's an
extra piece for black Alice Lee is
completely winning she's up on the clock
as well
Street
this is game you could force a queen
trade if you want it and just go into an
end game up a full Rook d8
and look at ingitch you you look at him
he's just like how did this happen and
the answer is because you're playing
Alice Lee and she is on a mission right
now Tanya I can hardly believe it but if
she starts 2-0 against this Grand Master
lineup from the Bulldogs my goodness
Alexander inject is in this belief that
he doesn't know what to do he is smiling
even though his position is crumbling
there he doesn't know what to do here on
the inside he knows that this has all
Fallen apart what a moment but Alice
needs to finish this off Robert she
needs to finish this off and she needs
to do it quick
oh my gosh she's done under a minute so
that is the nerve-wracking part for her
she knows she's winning she's going for
a tactic Queen H3 if Queen F1 comes
there's Rook D1 distracting the queen
and that because there's a pin on the
first rank we don't see that because the
king slid up to H2 but I feel like it's
now time to bring that Queen over who
cares about a bishop you're going to
deliver checkmate you're going for the
king I love this idea you could go Queen
T4 or queen F5 you give up that Bishop
you give a check you drive the king back
and then the idea and she does it how is
she so good she is finding all the best
moves Robert this is incredible play and
Alexander engine cannot believe what is
happening to him it's over and you know
he's kind of looks like he's maybe
smiling a little bit just probably to
avoid some tears but I think there'll be
happy tears coming from Alice Lee I mean
she beat bugs on Daniel dick 2700 and
now she's on the verge of taking down
another super strong grand house so how
does she end this game she goes Queen H5
check you have to trade queens and we
talked about this before Tony it's a
full extra piece for black I think this
should be sufficient although injured
playing this smartly he's trying to grab
these Pawns
there's a little work to be done an F3
Pawn you can't I mean you could defend
it with the Rook but then you lose the
B5 Pawn it's still completely winning
but it needs to show a little bit of
good technique I'm a little worried
Robert about Alice's clock right now she
goes C4 I like this move it does create
a parcel but this means you trade off
one more Pawn white can go Rook C7 start
targeting that fast C4 pawn and it looks
like Alice has to give up one of the two
pawns not easy to decide which one
yeah and by the way it looks like did in
fact win the game and buck they drew as
we expected so that leaves just this
game in the round and Alice Lee trying
to get it done here E7 that pawn is one
square for promotion the king is trying
to help out so she gives away this is
unfortunately this H Pawn and the bishop
they do not match the H1 Square so this
means that in the long term if the Rooks
get traded there could be drawing
chances for white
I think Alexander senses that he has
chances here he isn't going for the
Pawns
the pawns believable as that sound he
now picks up the C2 Pawn he will go for
these for the F3 Pawn next Rook C3 as
you pointed out very important that the
H1 square is of the wrong color the king
will step back to H5 to G4 white will
pick up uh the G4 Pawn or the F3 Pawn in
the end and this looks like it's getting
close to White defending this one yeah
actually this looks much more likely to
be a draw to my eyes than for to be a
win for black Rook H5 or Rook F5 the
king cup of the G4 because of his H Pawn
it leads me to believe that it's not
going to be a winter but don't take
right away because each one check would
distract the king away from The Rook so
there is a trap set by Alice Lee
I believe it that is so tricky that is
so sneaky so easy to fall into this in
seconds if you pick up that pawn you
lose on the spot and now you can offer a
trade with Rook F4 it comes down to that
H1 Square being the wrong color it's the
wrong color to blacks bishop and this is
what will decide why it's fate Alice's
only chance is to keep the Rooks alive
she does it she's still playing for the
win yeah she's gonna try to pile up
pressure on this F2 pawn and she is
going to get it I just don't know how
you do anything from there like where's
the king going it's cut off along the f
file so maybe she'll walk her King
around but this looks like it's a
fortress or white second She's Gotta Be
entire round result depends on this game
currently it is one and a half to one
and a half so this is the decider board
yes but but it looks like the back and
forth should do the trick for Alexander
ingers but even if this game is the drug
you know St Louis will be thrilled they
want to keep the status quo they won the
first round by two points and Alice Lee
I mean she's been unbelievable she's not
going to convert this into a full point
it was trickier than I think we
initially gave Credit in the position
but still a draw that's a great result
for her and it looks like it's
unavoidable at this point
that's a huge result once she's once
this one ends if she's on one and a half
out of two playing the top two boards
that is incredible stuff by the fourth
Point honestly has every reason to be
proud but this particular result I think
is going to be slightly Bittersweet
regardless of who she's playing she knew
she knows that she had a completely
winning position what a game by her but
it just looks like Alexander inject has
set up a sort of a fortress where it's
impossible for black to make any further
progress especially now after F4 check
and she actually needs to be a bit
careful because this end game with the
King up to H3 now you have to calculate
these sort of things actually oh my gosh
oh my God this is getting dangerous you
might lose the game I I wow what a move
have you taken this Rook A6 checkmate
if you take the bishop you trade and
then you pick up the G3 Pawn after
rookie five rookie five you trade on E5
83 is H4 how do you I mean I am shocked
Robert this is stunning stuff yeah when
you trade on G3 she finds the forcing
draw line amazing oh my God oh my
goodness look at this by the way I'm
gonna turn on the actual moves here
H4 is the only move that makes a draw
every other move loses for black and the
reason why is that you brought your king
up to E4 once this trade happens in the
center of the board the white king just
grabs this Pawn on H5 and then we start
this end game learn your king and pawn
end games opposition the King goes to
the side and then the white king goes
forward this Pawn is going to be able to
get to the other side this you can do in
any sort of Chess lesson but H4 out of
nowhere Tanya the only move that allowed
her to survive this game
just in seconds she literally played
this in two seconds it's the only move
that survives forcing a trade on the
spot after H4 whitecon capture the H4
Pawn with the G Pawn because then the F4
Pawn Falls and as you're pointing out
king H4 would be a huge blunder omit in
one after H4 G4 is not a possibility
because F4 Pawn Falls you take on E5 we
saw how the game ended I mean H4 is a
stunning move to find in just seconds on
the clock that just shows the kind of
champion and how powerful a player she
really is just amazing stuff here I'm
I'm in shock yeah it's really good play
from her she didn't convert this
Advantage into a win at some point she
did have a decisive Edge uh time trouble
was not her friend in this game but
credit actually to Alexander fought very
hard and he's actually keeping the
Croatia Bulldogs in the match because if
he had lost then St Louis would have
taken the round two and a half to one
and a half but Fabiano caruana he gets
the job done for the archbishops and
bogdal Daniel to get the job done or the
Bulldogs the other two games were
hard-fought troughs
stuff I'm still
I'm still it was clear that she wasn't
super excited about how it ended she was
completely completely winning that one
but in the end it got tricky as well and
Robert one of the hardest things in
chess is Shifting your mind mind space
understanding that the wind has slipped
out of your hand and now you need to get
things under control and at 13 for
honestly to recognize that moment to be
super precise of all of that and to find
this move H4 I think for me this has
been truly uh inspirational to watch and
we see that with that result a 2-2 game
St Louis Archbishop manages to hold this
one and continue their lead in the match
with five three
yeah big lead two points is a lot in the
Pro chest league but comebacks of course
happen but as we look at the individual
scores the top two boards for Croatia
have one out of two but for the
archbishops it's two out of two for
carwana and then all the way down on
board four Alice Lee with one and a half
out of two you don't expect that from a
board four but you sure love it so Alice
Lee has more points than anyone on the
Bulldogs she has been taken down the top
two boards for Croatia
Robert the woman have been
protest league so far and Alice
Alice being at the front of all of that
but of course the action does continue
in women's chess the women's candidate
finally comes to a head on Tuesday that
is March 28th after taking down six of
the strongest women in the game latinje
and tanzongi now are wine for a seat
across from reigning women's world
championship
and we will be bringing you live camera
feeds and match commentary bye ETI and
Alexander Costner wow that's gonna be a
lot of fun to watch Robert a big moment
there in that match and it will all
happen right here at twitch.tv chess use
the command exclamation mark candidate
for all the details
can't wait because it's been a long time
coming super excited to see those
players uh challenge each other for the
right to take on June June I will
definitely be following all the action
Tanya it's just around the corner
it's gonna be a lot of fun there's so
much just happening we've got the
protest League we'll have the women's
candidate we'll have the championship
star back as well but for now it will be
round three as the Bulldogs will aim at
equalizing the score currently they are
behind by two games big big action
coming up don't go anywhere Robert and I
will be right back
from the World Chess Championship to the
candidates the speed chess championship
title Tuesday and so much more chess.com
events has all of the top chess
tournaments played both over the board
and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
and chess.com
hey officer
sir
I've talked to you about this many times
so now now it's okay you may not
advertising checks.com adjustable
together at the same time I told you
there's one sign sir you may not be
advertising chess.com accessible at the
same time please give me this side yeah
I don't want to give Tammy the sign of
mine okay no you can't do anything
it's all the world everybody your hands
behind your back you have the right to
move one square at a time
if it is your very first move you may
move two squares at a time I can't go
backwards you have the right when you
have reached the eighth rank to consult
with a promotional officer about your
future I want to be a queen please come
with me to the back of the question
okay go backwards I can't move backwards
[Music]
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh
you know anyone trying to develop their
chess game if you do find you know style
of play that you enjoy that's good but
you could also try to sharpen it by
implementing you know another form of
into your bag as we would call it right
[Music]
foreign
and we're back and we've had such
exciting action there's been a bloodbath
of a mat so far we're we're halfway
through we've got two more rounds coming
up now the St Louis Archbishop is being
headed by Fabiano caruana on the top
board and take a look at the Tiger 's
percentage the win percentage that we've
had throughout the protest League Fabi
with seven wins three dot draws and two
losses at 70 percent Robert I'm looking
at the top of uh of uh this graphic that
we've got in front of us with Hikaru
Magnus and Wei Yi with high percentages
and no draws what does that tell us
about them
I mean the key is you just don't lose
and that way you have the best win
percentage and five minute caruana he
entered this match with a great winning
percentage he's won two out of two games
so it's only going up and up for him but
the challenge is only increasing in
difficulty as well telling you so while
he's been a star throughout the season
in Seasons past and in this specific
match he now has to play the top two
boards so they'll make like look to make
a dent in that record
absolutely and talking about making a
dent in that record well Fabio will make
sure he wants to get that percentage
high up let's take a look at how the
match has gone so far and remind
everyone what the Croatia Bulldogs need
to do well first thing first they need
to win a round Robert right now they're
down five to three to the Saint Louis
Archbishop we're going into round three
some big big rounds there now we've been
talking about how the Croatia Bulldogs
need to handle Fabi at the top but I
think the big question right now is how
do they handle Alice Lee on board four
those two have been stars for the
archbishops and if you look at the
Bulldogs right they have at least all
four players have scored some points so
they're not going to be dejected they're
not going to think that I can't do this
it is a two-point separation but you
can't put all your hopes on this third
round right you just want to just cut
into it maybe score two and a half one
half in this round where does that come
from that's a great question because
everybody on the archbishops is playing
quite well uh but I think if you're the
Bulldogs for you if you're injured
you're thrilled to have not lost that
game and that means all right some luck
is on their side
they really survived that one Alexander
inject was completely busted against
Alice Lee but that one ended in a draw
let's take a look at our lineup that is
coming up with Fabiano caruana taking on
Alexander inject and I think he really
needed that before you're facing Fabi
the last thing you want is to come out
of the loss against the fourth board
against Alice because even
psychologically that is so difficult to
overcome
yeah I mean just the psychology of Chess
is always going to play a part and it's
preparation it's psychology it's just
being in the moment and right now in
this moment Tanya as I look at the
lineups here you get the top two boards
or the Bulldogs getting the white pieces
that's great news but the players from
the archbishops they're super solid with
black and then for the archbishops down
on the lower two boards theodoru
announced they get white we know what
they're capable of and they're having in
particular honestly having a great day
and Theodore would love to make use of
those white pieces
he's got to do just that with the white
pieces they have to try and strike but
meanwhile it is up to the Croatia
Bulldogs to try to create their chances
even on the bottom boards this is a very
important round for the Bulldogs Robert
you mentioned they shouldn't go all out
try to score too big try to go super
rash because that can backfire but the
one thing they need to make sure is that
they get this round in with whatever
margin whether it is two and a half you
want to try and cut into that lead a
little bit but it's super important to
not let things go to the last round
keeping this big Point difference of two
points because that is going to be super
difficult if that is the difference in
round four and we can see the players
are almost ready to go it is an
elimination match between the St Louis
Archbishop and the Croatia Bulldogs uh
Robert what do you think are you
expecting Alice Lee to bring out the
fireworks one more time
well I don't know what fireworks show
bring but I know that we have the
microwave in the background it is
Benjamin Buck taking on both
well I guess sort of the question that
is being asked is and what does a team
need to do in order to come back from a
two-point deficit and I think that there
is no rush that sounds kind of
counter-intuitive you only have two
rounds left you're down by two full
points you need to go but I think when
you go all in Tanya that's when you just
lose the match right away because you
can't play chess specifically for
results unless that is strictly required
it's not required until the fourth round
so I figure if you're both gone to no
doubts you just play a calm game like
he's doing you try to get an advantage
and Benjamin Bach has been playing quite
slowly try to use the clock against him
wow and we see Benjamin here
and he and Knight to D2 I'm slightly
surprised because it's very early days
in the opening and he finally does
develop the bishop to G4 and I think
part of it was him perhaps taking the
decision which side does he want to
Castle is Benjamin actually considering
going for Queen side castling in this
position
sometimes you do that right you just go
to the other direction and with the
bishop on H5 now I'm a little bit
worried that that Bishop gets caught on
G6 and is staring into pawns doesn't
have a great future but well done Daniel
day out just let me just bring the
Knight back to F1 I'm gonna do the same
thing with my knight coming to G3 and I
have not committed my Pawn to G4 I can
be overextended if I do that especially
Tanya as you point out the black king
likely to go Queen side
I think so I think we're gonna see an
opposite side castling most likely in
this game well it depends if bogdon
Daniel decides to go with the King side
Castle or keep things safe because he
also has the option to get the king to
safety over to the queen side but right
now black needs to watch out for threats
of Knight G3 and maybe even take a
decision do you want to trade that
Knight on F3 with the bishop or fall
back to G6 I'm loving what we're seeing
Robert it's a queen side Castle we know
that that means it's going to be well we
might have fireworks on Alice Lee's boat
but this one's going to be really feisty
as well
for sure because it's often that the
white king goes to the king side you
haven't castled yet so you still could
go Queen side as well but I like how
black is playing this you may have
double pawns but you have good control
over this D4 Square which means that
white cannot break open the center and I
think everything is under control for
now
all right well as Bogdan decides which
side he wants to Castle it gives us a
few minutes to take a look at the action
all around every board every game every
player matters here and we see that we
do have liftoff on our left side as we
can see on the top left fabi's game
against Alexander injik and I see that
there have been a few trades already it
looks like Fabi is quite pleased with
the position everything under control
there I see a bishop pair for engine but
better structure for black meanwhile on
the bottom left we see the Queens have
already been traded off and there's a
bit of shattering of the pawn structure
there and it was voluntary like Nicholas
theodoro just chose to put a piece on E3
Molina quickly took that piece on E3 and
that means White's Pawn structure will
be bad and in the bottom right Alice Lee
against bardia Dinesh for two very
talented teenagers they're going to be
squaring off and their teams are going
to be relying on them so Tanya which
game should we dive into more deeply as
all four boards are underway
well it's excitement all over but I want
to take a look at the Fabi board because
it just feels like there's been so much
progress in that game so many pieces
minor two minor pieces have been traded
off already and we see there's no more
the bishop air advantage it just looks
like both players would be quite happy
to have a peaceful ending to this one
well if you're Fabiano black pieces
against a strong Grandmaster you
definitely take a quick draw if it's
being offered and the issue for black is
this bishop is very strong the issue for
White is you have the separated Pawn
structure to isolated pawns here and
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn so if
I could just slide this Pawn over if you
let me cheat for a second then White's
position is quite great but if these
Queens get traded Tanya this Knight hops
around a bunch those pawns could be in
some danger so I think that you have to
restrict the Black Knight use the bishop
on the long but I am worried about
those Pawns in the long run
does favor the bishop advantage that
Alexander inject has the B2 Bishop can
never be challenged it is quite a strong
diagonal that it is breathing fire down
F3 slightly weakening there this E3 Pawn
once again a voluntary decision thereby
white which does give black this
additional Target do you really want to
ever go E4 with that pawn creating a D4
weakness in the position which feels
like black can at some point go within
like jump around a little 97 95 96 94
and all these ideas come into play so it
really looks like uh well fabi's got
things under control and even though
white has got the strong Bishop on B2
black has his own trumps in the position
yes that night maneuver that you
mentioned could be in the future and not
to mention that black can just bring the
Knight over to B6 because with the
bishop on this long diagonal it needs
full scope so just like white played F3
perhaps black will move the Knight and
put a Pawn on F6 and make that Bishop
stare into a blunted diagonal so I
actually really like the look of the
night maneuver over to B6 go right after
this loose Pawn on C4 that's the bad
thing about a bishop it can't go to the
other color complex which means you need
to go after the light squares
well and that means that white has to
try to create play on the dark squares
with that bishop and I don't see that
happen once there is this wall with the
F6 Pawn I love that idea I was only
thinking about bringing the Knight to E5
but there white would have the
opportunity to actually trade that
Knight for the bishop and of course uh
if Bobby has the choice to able to
create some chances in this by attacking
the C4 Pawn he's going to do just that
but it might be it might be inject's
opportunity here then to already trade
on F6 that essentially would be a draw
offer
yes because without the minor pieces
with some liquidation occurring that
does feel like it's likely to lead
towards the quality but with the weak
pawns over here I mean that's the
problem for Injustice he can't afford
just simply trade and Bobby he brought
the queen back to esem first now brings
the Knight over likely to B6 or as
you're indicating uh maybe over to C6
and into D4 but if the Knight goes to B6
how kind of want your queen back on E6
or maybe a slight inaccuracy from Fabi
but in a position where he definitely is
no worse
well 97 we were talking about this
maneuver it is on the board the knight
from D7 can hop over to B6 it can hop
over to E5 it can also go to B8 and then
to C6 and then hop over to D4 meanwhile
white still hasn't really created the
chances along this diagonal there's
always F6 to stop that and I also like
that the D4 square is on the blocks
control we see that after this move E4
it really is a gaping hole in the
position and black can maneuver the
Knight all the way up to D4 I'd like to
do that or talk things are looking good
for Fabi here yes now Fabi he's doing
well for the archbishops two out of two
scored thus far here in game three
really having no issues he goes home he
went to the other home right he said he
said the other night's home is my home
as well but this Rook on D5 it's more
menacing at first glance than it
actually is in practice because where's
it going the answer is nowhere and maybe
this Knight will just kick it out uh by
going to B4 so the Knight went from F6
now to C6 I think it's a huge
improvement from where the Knight can go
to
balance bonds structure if there's a
trade or the other option is to jump to
D4 but you've got to be careful you
don't end up losing upon there Fabi
choosing an interesting idea with the
night maneuver this one's going to
develop over the next couple of moves
let's bring up our bird's eye view let's
just zoom out from this because there is
action on on the other boards as well
and wow big action on because take a
look at that top right it's not just
Benjamin Bach who went Queen side
castling but Bogdan Daniel also decided
to keep his King on the queen side and
we see a nice little Knight there posted
on F5 and I see our eval bar but I think
white does seem to have a little more
space a little more activity in that one
meanwhile on the bottom right the Alice
Lee board a lot of trades in the center
there Robert the pawns are all off and
it's all about peace activity in that
one
yeah the bottom right and the bottom
left both look like interesting
positions we can go to the Alice Lee
game as you were calling for because
bardia dineshfar the super strong player
from Iran who's made his presence felt
here in the Pro chess League we see that
there's a pressure against Alice's
position down to this E2 Pawn here so
these positions with the fiancado bishop
in these Catalan structures uh they can
liquidate quite early but that doesn't
mean we're heading towards a draw Tanya
not at all there's always a lot of play
in the center and it's really all about
peace activities and a lot of
maneuvering and we see that happen with
Alice's last move she falls back with
the Knight to D2 defends that C4 a night
at some point what she needs to do
Robert is Kick That Knight out from D5
E4 is something that Alice really wants
to get in the position but she has to be
careful because that Bishop on A6
x-raying that Knight with the Rook on F1
so still requires a couple of moves here
to make everything work for white I
really I really think E4 Queen G4 ideas
are something that Alice is thinking
about
these moves are the ones you want to
play E4 right now may be critical but
you're highlighting it The Rook on F1 is
hanging behind that Knight on C4 you
could be walking into some uncomfortable
pins so what else can you do for Alice
whoa whoa she takes on D5 giving up her
fiancaro Bishop maybe she's looking at
this queen here on C7 saying The Rook
usually wins a showdown and if you take
with this Pawn here then you have
isolated Pawn the center and the Knight
just hops back here so I don't know
Tanya it was a big decision by Alice I
think she was feeling the pressure in
the position I mean that's a really good
metal decision we don't often see the
fan childhood Bishop on G2 being given
up for the night there that is like you
said really a massive decision on the
board and she played it in just about a
minute made it so quickly Rook D5 you
pointed out Knight E3 but lucky for
black that you still have the option to
come back with the Rook to C5 so you
covered the queen as well as get out of
the attack on The Rook on D5 so things
are still fine Robert I am very unsure
about the trade that Alice decided to go
for it just feels a black can set up a
battery along the A8 H1 H1 diagonal with
blacks light squared Bishop still alive
this could get dangerous for Alice
so what Tanya is suggesting if I'm
reading between the lines you need to
trade Queens if you're Alice you
desperately need to get those Queens off
the board because you may get checkmated
in the near future so I think you're 100
spot on here uh for Alice maybe move
like Knight B3 just get these Rooks off
the board start trading some pieces uh
but it's not going to be easy for her
she's certainly worth that's very clear
and she doesn't have a plan while she's
down a couple minutes so 94 Knight B3
were the same idea but Tanya she's down
a lot of time and her position is worse
I really like what you pointed out you
hit the Rook you try to trade Queens but
does Black is Black Force to trade
Queens black can actually sidestep with
the queen I was gonna say well A7 is
quite an ugly square and you don't want
to allow White's Queen to jump into C6
as well putting so much pressure so it
might be time to place the queen on B7
and try and hope that someday you can
again rearrange these pieces because
once the Queens are traded off like you
pointed out Queen C1 Rook C1 yes the E2
Pawn is hanging but Robert with the Rook
jumping on to the seventh rank lacks
nine on D7 that's Bishop on on E7 it
just feels like it's a lot of counter
play for white but bardia is going for
it is he gonna pick up the E2 Pawn
I think he is and he does and he has
Rook daithian his claim is I may be a
bit tied down for the moment but once I
defend my knight my Bishop will be free
to move so The Rook does land on C7 but
a simple Rook to d8 and black is up a
pawn black has the bishop pair black has
the safer King black has the lead on the
clock I think you know where I'm going
with this Tanya I think bardia dineshwar
are just showing off his class by just
saying a pawn is hanging I can now take
it I'm not afraid
it's on the board when I was looking at
this line pointing it out I completely
missed this defense that black has with
Rook to d8 because otherwise black just
ends up losing a piece on the seventh
rank with the Knight and Bishop lined up
but bardia seeing a move ahead there has
an extra pawn and it does look that
Alice has a lot of Peace activity but
she has got just a couple of moves to
try and make something out of that I
like that move Knight C4 what that does
is make sure that the D7 Knight is is
stuck to defending that B6 Pawn you're
also eyeing a knight jump on D6 but I
would still be a little afraid with the
Rook coming to D1 a bishop F3 a little
move by black taking control of that
long diagonal and really boxing up white
skin in a potential check mating pattern
I see what you're going for that looks
very very dangerous and so white has to
be careful the good news is that if the
bishop goes F3 you can kick that Bishop
out of there by even bringing your
knight back to D2 and the bishop will
have to leave the F3 Square so for now
it does seem like Alice is hanging in
and what she needs is a trade if she can
trade this bishop for a knight that
would be ideal but what she really wants
is to get these pawns off the board
because without the queen side pawns
with all the concentration in the center
and on the king side that actually helps
the knights and helps the defensive task
so she has her work cut out for her
bardia Dennis were up on time up a pawn
but it's not going to be easy from here
well he's not the only one who is not
going to be easy for because I have my
eye out let's bring a bird's eye view
because there has been a big turnaround
as I see with our eval bar on that top
left board rabbit look at that Fabiano
caruana is in trouble and wow what is
this position why does manage to plan to
Rook on D6 there's a Pawn on E5 sure
Fabi got his nice night to a nice little
spot on B4 but it's not really doing
anything there that's a night with all
Bach and no bite currently and it looks
like Fabi needs to be up for a huge
defensive task here
and he's also down two minutes on the
clock with a worse position limited
activity the night on B4 as you're
saying it's out great it's Advanced it's
not threading anything and it can't go
anywhere the Knight is not actually
helping as much as it would appear and
for uh White this Rook on D6 excellently
plays peace Pawn on E5 this queen can
maybe go back to B1 and use the light
squares or it could slide to D2 right
now so if you take if you take Pawn
takes that looks very scary as white has
a far Advanced pass pawn and a bishop an
open diagonal what's it's happening and
he's not gonna pick it up with the
that is not
is not big Pawn now that combined with
threats along the long diagonal and
fabi's queen stuck on D7 and we see that
little shift in Fabi he knows that this
is a tensed position for him yeah this
queen takes F4 but that was a mistake
apparently so Alexander injured he
rushed both because he had five minutes
on the clock and in the position let's
bring up an analysis board because
that's a very instructive moment uh for
players that just a couple turns ago
after Pawn takes D6 the queen is
blockading this queen cannot move so
let's say white it pushed this Pawn to
H4 right away instead of taking on F4
first this Pawn's not actually hanging
because the pawn goes up to D7 and now
it's going up to d8 I am getting a new
Queen the best you can do is give your
knight up for that piece but in the
ensuing position white is up a bishop
and delivering Checkmate I'm not even
sure if it matters which Square I go to
but let's go here Checkmate is next good
game so I think that ninja Tanya he
rushed it by taking on F4 because when
he did that that allowed the black queen
to take on A4 there is no D7 and there
are threats along the first rank wow
that's a super point that you make and
it just goes on to show that how it the
F4 Pawn was hanging you could have
picked it up at any point but you could
have improved your position further but
now we have a similar position but Abby
has an A on which gives him a lot of
counter play earlier in the in the
analysis that you showed if H4 was
played earlier before taking on F4
things would have been very different
now this a pawn is going to give Fabi
the counter play that he needs but it's
still very difficult the black king is
exposed goes to f8 where
Robert it looks like A4 A3 coming in
Fabi might be able to save this without
too much trouble
yeah that's an annoying Pawn to deal
with the good news for Injustice even if
it gets to A2 the bishop being the
long-range piece it is it covers the
promotion Square while putting pressure
towards the black king but this Knight
it's free to move it can go to d8 maybe
to F7 at some point to go after this
pawn and how does white actually make
progress if black is playing to do
nothing and answer the question was
answered there with G5 but I'll say
black was playing to do nothing what's
White's plan but you just said G6 G6
it's coming in you've got to watch out
it's Queen H5 possible you give up the
D6 Pawn but you win the G7 Pawn
but it could be another moment of you
need to do it right now let's bring up
that analysis board because Queen H5
that's the automatic move that's the I
simply must go for Queen H5 Queen h8 but
the eval Bar says not so fast the queen
takes D6 Queen check you take on G7 with
check you have a new pass Pawn but
somehow Tanya the king is escaping and
because there's that's the wrong Arrow
because there's so many checks against
the white king in various directions I
guess that's why black is staying in the
game so ingitch he rushed once he should
not rush again I don't know what the
best move is Tanya but apparently Queen
H5 up and he played it so the second
time he has rushed to queen move and we
see the Evo bar drop Queen 66 keeps
black in the game it was so natural to
go for Queen H5 you pointed it out
yourself it is the most human move in
the position and queen H5 we've got this
position it still looks very scary but
also for the white king Fabi having
enough counter play with that A3 pawn
and that Queen G3 check would be a bat
on the spot Queen G3 Queen F3 and the G6
Pawn just doesn't have enough time to
advance if you give a check on h8 the
king moves forward G7 and then black
follows that up with checks and that
would end in a draw on the spot Tanya I
actually think black could win this game
I know that seems ridiculous and the
reason why is Queen G3 is a threat and
this Nike is gonna go back to E7 at some
point so if white is not careful right
now you could find yourself in trouble
if you're so singularly focused if you
tunnel on pushing this Pawn so I'm
worried for injitch but Croatia I mean
they really need him to get at minimum a
half point in this game he cannot afford
to let it snow and he is slipping about
to be two minutes on the clock this is
where mistakes happen when you're in the
mindset of I should be winning where is
the win in and you don't play the board
that you currently have
while he can't burn the clock too much
he can take a few seconds because it's
an important moment that is a smart move
Robert there because it defends that F3
Pawn so sure you can jump in with a
check on G3 but that's the only check
that you're getting and if you go for
this bishop on C3 then white intends to
advance the G7 pawn and queen next you
have Knight E7 there so what's going on
after Queen C2 Queen C3
I'm telling you white needs to find a
forced drawn there might it might be
available I think we are going to see
Queen C2 takes Bishop the pawn goes up
and once the Knight Returns we will get
a promotion
think there are enough checks against
the black king but if there are not then
this Pawn is just about to promote black
will be a pawn ahead this is scary
territory if you're in just he's
dropping to a minute and a half and
suddenly things have gone wrong in every
single way and look at his face he's
shaking his head right now yeah he knows
it he knows that he's let the slip and
you're absolutely right for the Bulldogs
this is such an important body at least
needs to save half a point also once
again getting that mind shift that you
are completely winning and now you have
to find the precise way to hold this
game it's so easy to go wrong he doesn't
seem happy with any move that he's
making right now King H3 he shakes his
head Fabi quickly picks up that Knight
on C3 sorry the bishop on C3 the Knight
will jump to E7 to defend the pawn from
queening on G8 so you need a force to
draw if you're injured but this is bad
news for the Bulldogs but there's good
news so if we are able to get towards
the bird's eye view because this one it
looks like injuries can force a draw
that is the expectation but look at this
Tanya in the top right it's all folks on
Daniel Dash in the bottom left Paulina
shuvalva is delivering on the verge of
delivering a huge upset over Theodore
with the black pieces and then in the
bottom right our Dia de nesfar is
winning with the black pieces so it
looks like it might be a three and a
half half round for the Bulldogs and
they'll take the lead
why the Bulldogs are dominating on every
single board here Robert which one do
you want to jump to I see on the top
right Knight G6 that's not a Focus black
snide can recapture on G6 yeah I'll just
make a quick point then the bottom left
it looks like those pawns are too many
past pawns for black and that is why she
will be able to win this game so let's
go to that game in the top right between
Benjamin Bach and bog downtown dance
just because I think that's more up for
grabs and look at the eval bar it's in
White's favor but look at the clock both
sides in some time trouble wow
opposite color Bishops and these are
notorious positions if all the pieces
the heavy pieces get traded it ends in a
draw but it looks like White's the one
who's putting the pressure is bringing
in the attack in opposite color Bishop
it's not just about extra material but
the side that is more active and it
looks like Benjamin Bach is in trouble
he's got to defend not only against the
extra Pawn but White's attack as well
yeah no this is going to be an annoying
defense for Benjamin Bach but he's got
the perfect setup right the queen and
the Rook defend everything he goes back
and forth back and forth let's trade a
rook let's trade the Queens if you can
get the major pieces off the board
you're much more likely to draw that
doesn't mean you certainly will draw but
is much more likely and so Benjamin Buck
look at it he's going back and forth
let's trade and if you're you avoid that
trade at all costs for now
he's doing everything to try and trade
off the major pieces because that would
make life so much easier and as you're
pointing out white is targeting trying
to get to that C7 Pawn eventually with
the Rooks if they could be only doubled
up the rook and the Queen on the seventh
rank Benjamin Bach says no he's got
things under control I don't think this
is going to be easy to convert and bogd
and Daniel is down to six seconds on the
clock wow this one is still looking
pretty loud but we have to go to our
bird's eye view because there is a big
news happening in another game so while
this one's in time trouble it's going
back and forth I just want to catch our
the eye on look at the top left Fabiano
caruana suddenly has a winning position
against Alexander Anderson I mean all
games are frantic at this point as the
players are in time trouble
let's go to fabi's board we've gotta
have that and you call this that you
think Fabi is the one who's gonna take
this point and you call it at a moment
when Fabi was in huge trouble white has
played the move G7 it looks like a very
dangerous position and I'm still trying
to understand why is white busted with a
Pawn on G7 maybe it's because the black
king can sit in front of this Pawn
because as you approach it the queen
would need to be able to get to the f8
square that's very hard to get to so
King F7 might just be able to pick up
the pawn and what about A2 by the way
this queen is stopping the white Pawn
from promoting and I don't think there's
an endless series of checks so King B7
was in fact played uh so I can get some
excuse me I wonder if now at this point
you have to go after this A3 Pawn just
give up G7 win A3 I just think that it's
not going to be enough because black has
these two other past pawns to work with
this has been such a hard making
turnaround for the Bulldogs because
Alexander inject looked like he was
completely winning against Fabiano and
wow he just flags flags
he can't he's beside himself and karwana
just laughed a little bit because he
didn't like the game he played but he
moves to three out of three and we have
to move on because for injured it's
disappointment for the Bulldogs it could
mean elimination so let's go back to our
bird's eye view because well actually I
mean they're just two games remaining it
looks like Nicholas theodoro salvaged
the draw oh my goodness wow you don't
survive somehow but we've got to go to
that top right board with Alice Lee
against bar they are players playing on
second Alice has got six seconds on the
clock rabbit this is the Rooks are being
created off but it just looks like wait
white is down a piece you can't save
this yeah Alice Lee in the bottom right
she's in a losing position down a full
minor piece so we know the results of
vacuum a credit to Bar designers for
that one is over so we have one game
left between Benjamin Bach he's the
black pieces against bugged on Daniel
day out so let's Dive Right into that
one it is the last game of the round and
the Bulldogs they desperately need this
to inch closer in the scoreboard here
but how do you break this shell this
Pond right how do you get through
you've got to start pushing that E Pawn
you bring back your queen you go E5 and
the dream is to advance it as much as
you can but he's gone gone for Queen F6
so watch out now if the queen moves and
loses control of C6 white could have
jumped in with Queen C6 given a check
and then Advance the E Pawn well I do
see E5 is still in the air but Bogdan
not taking that decision at some point
Robert he's got to go for it he's got to
start pushing that a pawn you called it
Queen C6 check it was D6 that looks like
about it oh we just spawn second two
everything in a position
oh my goodness and you see every Pawn
has dropped for black
and he attacks the bishop but this is
over and we see Benjamin they're
absolutely frustrated he completely
missed Queen C6 Queen B6 and now Robert
this one has three extra pawns and it
looks like the Croatia Bulldogs will
take it with the margin that you've
mentioned at the start of the run two
and a half to one and a half it could
have been more they could have stolen
this round and the match lead but this
one is going their way it is a clear win
at this point the bishop is hanging
that's Checkmate back there you could
probably even trade Queens at this point
and win the game and that's what he does
is simple now
well if it was just two pawns then black
saves it but with three extra pawns that
is absolutely lost because a black
spaceship and King cannot control and
stop the advance for too long as you're
pointing out eventually the a pawn will
get forward right now the B5 Pawn is
hanging so you've just gotta be a little
careful on how you actually push these
Pawns
so bring the king back and then push the
a pods that's what he does he recognizes
his initial mistake now his a pawn can
go forward E5 Pawn is protected and that
is sufficient because you are just going
to push them all don't stop
don't stop because you're down to
seconds as well just make sure you don't
fly he hits the bishop
Bishop you play a move like B6 you give
black a lot of control on the lights
Quest so you want to also push the right
Pawn I like that move King D it's
stopping Black skiing from moving
anywhere it almost looks like a zugzong
here for a black now you can go a six
and you can potentially Queen oh but
watch out A6 King 8 and queen and that
was a stalemate that would have been oh
that would have been a disaster don't do
it now King why not King it you're not
tracking it
yeah no you're trying to go for a
stalemate that's uh funny but I think
it's gonna be a resonation I'm going to
show that what you were just saying as
well done Daniel dayas gets a huge win
for the Bulldogs he's keeping them in
the match but Tanya brought up a very
funny tactic that uh bogdon was able to
avoid because if A6 check was played and
the King went to A8 the move B6 is
winning for sure but let's say you want
a queen I'm gonna win your Bishop the
Evolve bar sinks because after Bishop
takes King takes like oh no no no that's
stalemate the bishop takes away the
Escape Square
yeah but what a Miss by Benjamin right I
mean in this position of course it was
still lost as he pointed out B6 was in
there but there are always these tricks
you have to be careful about Benjamin
that making a huge blunder at the very
last moment when it looked like
everything was under control he
plundered into Queen C6 losing a bunch
of Pawns in that position and with that
the Croatia Bulldogs take their first
win of the day against the Saint Louis
Archbishop so now Robert we've got the
smallest of margins between the team
this was a two and a half to one and a
half win with a bog down Daniel and a
bardia Danish were scoring big and very
important wins to keep the Bulldogs hope
alive
two and a half one half in the round for
the Bulldogs it could have been more it
could have been disaster for the
archbishops but Fabiano caruana I don't
know how it was a miracle he wins the
game and that is the reason that the
archbishops they maintain a lead but
Tanya it feels like a closer match the
Bulldogs have to believe in themselves
because each and every board for them
has shown potential and as we see the
overall scores uh the archbishops
they're led by board one Fabiana carwana
and then for the Bulldogs similarly
their board one is leading the way but
it feels balanced on the rest of the
boards
yeah absolutely and it's also very
impressive how the board 4 has actually
contributed so much to the team we also
see Polina with one point and Alice Lee
of course at one and a half with that
first round win and the second round
draw and she went down to a bardia
Danish where in that last round and now
with the smallest margins we go into
around four Roberts so that's a big one
coming up but uh what what do you make
of this do you think what are the
chances are we gonna see a tie break or
not in this one
I think everybody wants to see tie
breaks except for the St Louis
archbishops they've been leading since
the start but the Bulldogs they've had
their chances I mean even though it was
a two-point lead for the archbishops at
some points it was closer than that
there were mistakes from both sides
that's the nature of this event and
we've had a few draws but not many so
for those of you who predicted the over
on today's featured question I think
you're looking likely to win
oh that one of them was me by the way
just saying that Robert that I did
predict this was gonna be a bloodbath a
big fight and that's what we're getting
but it's far from over as the Bulldogs
are currently chasing the Archbishop but
just by one point we got a huge round
for coming up on the other side of this
break don't go anywhere
three puzzles here it's just him yes yes
that's Jazz now we're gonna go but
suddenly you know there's like some kind
of some kind of triangle so along the
place okay no okay we're not warning I'm
not the fastest so here is the first one
okay
okay so F2 check yeah Eric A6 F2 PNG 2
check Rook takes G3 Knight H3 King h100
I made anything on second
yeah I think I have sold this already
like F2 is the answer
um uh actually I didn't have time to
calculate King takes F2 which looks uh I
mean at the very least I can just take
on D3 and on F1 and I'm material effect
and the and that is also a gift to
Indian so it's just Checkmate but of
course the point is after look it
doesn't matter which hook takes an
episode then there is quinjeto check
followed by another three check and
replace F1 Checkmate one rupees okay
okay
currently blind all right your 10
seconds is up 100 yeah I just got it
while I was singing briefly yeah so it's
obviously F2 and then uh Queen G2 90
strain Rook F1
wow okay okay so you're I mean there's
also Rook up to hg2 the same thing yeah
yeah I mean workout takes off to Queen
you two or two tonight usually King H1
and then hurt you one or two ones babe
but yeah
okay you like to play and win or what
yes I like to play away
well I mean I got it right next thanks
I don't know I didn't find the meat I
saw them
oh you're good I'll Make a Move yeah
unfortunately the move is not 92.
F2
Rook take oh F2 I need that warm up can
we start again
yeah yeah I need the warmer
um
don't think it's a mate
yeah no I don't
all dead
um the correct move is actually F2
yeah
and then oh wow like this
somehow it's unusual better but it's
really cool no exactly
it's so easy
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chest.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
the defending Champions the three times
champion of the pro chess League the
Saint Louis archbishops had a
devastating start but now they are
leading this final match which is an
elimination match they need to win to
make it to the playoffs of this season
they won the 2020 season the 2019 and
2017. two of the seasons were headed by
Fabi Fabiano caruana is back for the 23
season as well but it hasn't gone well
at least not the way they would have
wanted Robert from the start but they've
had two back-to-back match wins and
currently leading against the Bulldogs
and Fabi has played a fabulous role oh
he certainly has he's three out of three
today it's surprising to many that they
would need to win just to get into the
playoffs that's been their season it
started on the downward swing 0-2 but
they've won two straight matches they
currently have a one point lead here
Tanya so now the answer is with their
season on the line down to the wire the
final round of action will they be able
to get the job done make it three wins
in a row and make the playoffs it's so
difficult Robert to get our head around
the fact that Saint Louis archbishops
have been staring at elimination the
last two weeks and this week as well
they needed to win every match they won
two back-to-back matches this is the
third one currently leading with just
the smallest of margins against the
Bulldogs anything can happen to force a
tie break to go into a playoff the
Bulldogs need a two and a half to one
and a half win but if they win with a
bigger margin than that then actually
with a 3-1 win the Bulldogs will
eliminate the Archbishop so you've got a
big big round four coming up and this is
the most equally matched round of the
protest League where board one plays
against Ward one and we look at this and
Robert Hill in this particular matchup
we see Fabi sure he's that heavy hitter
he is the big name at the top but
actually the Bulldogs in the in the
other three boards have a huge rating
advantage
well I'm looking at these lineups and
I'm thinking where do the points come
from because you need to score one extra
point if you are the Bulldogs I'm
looking down at boards three and four
you have the white pieces our Dia
dinesfar against Nicholas Theodore
Theodore is a very strong Grandmaster he
meddled he won an individual medal at
the Olympiad that says a lot about his
skill not to mention he's one of the top
rated Blitz and bullet players on site
but then on board four Polina shivala
she gets the white pieces against Alice
Lee Alice Lee is amazing there's nobody
in the world that's going to deny that
but what Paulina might deny her is that
last round Victory Paulina is fantastic
she's already at that GM level Alice
still has a little bit of work to get
there she's showing that she can punch
up she can win these big games but that
I think is a critical game for the
Bulldogs as we get sent as Fabiano
caruana gets the white pieces and needs
to make his first move here
person on that board for
cares about rating differences but as
you pointed out Paulina is almost 2500
for all practical reasons almost a grand
master and we see our players are ready
to go very important the last two boards
the both three and board four with the
white pieces for the Bulldogs they need
to try to get those points in and Fabi
starts with the English opening one C4
on the board
yeah he goes for the English not
something you see every day from Fabiano
but it makes it harder to prepare for
and we see E6 from uh broke down Dash
he's likely going to strike with D5 but
in those situations white will often
take and push the pawn to D4 and he goes
right away he could have created an
isolated Pawn instead he wants to strike
in the center and Tyler these are
confusing positions with all his paw
attention
oh 100 Persona he decides to trade off
so not keeping the tension alive for too
long then he takes off the bishop I was
quite surprised that Fabi took about 30
seconds to make that first move C4 it
almost seemed as if he's forgotten that
the clocks have started
yeah I think Bobby you know just was
relaxing a little bit too much but now
that he has recognized that he needs to
make moves he's doing them quickly uh
he's playing a very natural opening just
look at this tension he's waiting for
his opponent deox to move the bishop and
then he'll take on C5 you don't want to
allow the bishop out in one turn and
that's why for black you might think
about a move like Bishop E6 developing
the light Square Bishop first he goes
all about the G4 and wow look at how
quickly Fabiano played Bishop E2 Tanya I
think he knows what he's doing
100 that speed Bishop E2 is not a move
that you make too quickly but it was
also necessary because there was so much
pressure on D4 as you pointed out Fabi
doesn't want to take on C5 just yet
welcoming the dark Squad Bishop for
black to develop with an ice Square on
C5 with a Tempo by recapturing so he's
delaying that as much as possible we see
that Bogdan Daniel is also up to the
task of knowing what he's doing he keeps
delaying that development of that Bishop
on f8 it's really about who blinks first
with the D4 and the C5 pawns staring at
each other well I just watched Fabian
not blink a few times but I don't think
he's going to take on C5 I think he'll
play H3 make quiet move maybe have a B3
at some moment because the bishop does
want to go and develop a bishop D2
that's not really doing anything you're
staring at your own pieces so both sides
are trying to figure out this tension
and B3 is useful because later in the
game you might want to Fan Kettle
especially if you do eventually take on
C5 it opens up the long diagonal
I'll also think about and the way the
center gets fixed of black trades on D4
and then white what does he recapture
with where the bite ends up picking up
on C5 and the D5 we get an isolated
Queen spawn so really the Central Pawn
structure will determine the
characteristic of the middle game that
we've got where each side plays for the
attack and for the counter play so while
these players have a think on how they
want to sort out the central tension
that we're looking at we've got liftoff
on the other boards as well let's zoom
out and see the opening action on our
bird's eye view as the games are well
into the opening phase and I see our top
right board with we've been talking
about Pawn structures and centers that
is quite a fixed Pawn structure with
white advancing the pawn to D5 currently
the Knight is hit he's moved to B4
meanwhile on the bottom left again a lot
of flexibility in the center with a
Face-Off and wow 94 what is that move
Robert what just happened I was about to
talk about the other games I think we
have to go right into the board three
matchup between ordeal dinesha and
Nicholas Theodore because that's a night
sacrifice in the center this early in
the game so theodoru says here take my
knight and well the answer hasn't taken
it yet
we've got to do a deep dive on the
Nicholas teodoro bardia position 94 was
the last move played let's let's have
that up and we see the Knight on e4 is
hanging raw but you're doing a replay of
the action and just in this position he
calmly snaps off the pawn on e4
but the Knight is under attack and can
be captured so let's bring up an
analysis board because it seems like
it's not an easy decision but what other
moves do you have you've given up a pawn
and the point is that the pawn takes D4
the queen hits this Knight so the pawn
hits this bishop and you could take on
D4 but after Queen takes E4 this is the
big question Tanya black is up a pawn
but this queen is in the center it's
actually in some loose territory but
whoa I just noticed that bardia did not
go for this line he was worried that in
a position like this that black would be
up a pawn and he wasn't finding the
clear compensation but instead he goes
like this Knight D5 after Queen d8 I
think it's even less compensation
I'm trying to understand this whole
thing Knight D5 was also tempting you
hit the Queen but the queen falls back
and that Knight on D5 is not stable at
all that can actually Kick That Knight
out at any moment with a move like C6
and you were talking about finding
compensation I am with you Robert it's
harder to see the compensation in this
line rather than the trading one that
you were showing with capturing the
Knight on e4 and opening up the center
yeah the center is closed and black has
an extra Pawn so taking on E5 I like
your point about C6 I might throw that
in right now because where does that
Knight actually go if it goes back to C3
thank you very much I'll take it and
Shadow your Pawn structure if you go
forward to F6 well I'll take you there
too and then I will open up my Bishop on
G7 but okay Nicholas says I don't need
to get fancy I'm up a pawn I can move my
knight now that's under attack it's a
clear extra Pawn for black so theodoro
has won the opening battle and Tanya
that's really bad news for the Bulldogs
100 on that also this is one the boards
where the Bulldogs start with the white
pieces and so this was where they really
had to try to strike or at least get the
maximum chances they could out of the
opening but it looks like instead it's
going to be one where bhardia will be on
the defense he needs to save a position
where he's down upon create his chances
not seeing where all the Robert that
said there are still a lot of pieces
whitestruct can't jump to D1 create play
along the center with Rook on D1 The
Rook on E1 the E5 Pawn constantly on the
Target and black still not fully develop
a little bit of initiative does exist
still a healthy Pawn while this one
develops we will see whether bardia can
create something out of it or not let's
zoom out for a moment because I have my
eye out on the bird's eye view and on a
certain certain board I do see our
valbar has jumped all the way well not
all the way but quite a bit of the way
for the Saint Louis Archbishop take a
look at that top right board Benjamin
Bach it looks like he's got a good
position
uh he's got more space with that D5 Pawn
there's a lot of stuff happening in the
on the queen side B5 is hanging A4 has
been played Robert some Pawn sacrifices
going on here first question what
happens after C takes B5 well let's
analyze that position in the 4-2 matchup
between Benjamin Bach and Alexander
injet so if we can we see the pawn was
captured on B5 so quick instant replay
this was the position things were
getting wild and then black says I don't
care that my Pawn's under attack let me
push to A4 and after Pawn takes Knight
C7 now B5 and D5 are under attack from
Black's Knights and he goes I'll take
you there too thank you very much and
after Knight takes D5 Tanya right now
white is up a pawn but black actually is
the one with an extra Pawn towards the
center actually an extra two pawns so
these are White's three pawns compared
to two that's how I like to analyze
position that's not just quickly
counting okay white has seven black has
six it's not that simple in chess you
want to look where the pawns are so
essentially like black is up two pawns
and the C D files white is up three
pawns on the queen side flank over here
but who does this benefit are these
pawns going to get rolling up the board
later of course the queen is under
attack right now or blacks pawns
actually more powerful and restricting
the white pieces
I think it's gonna be all about quality
over quantity coming to your point of
which bonds get rolling first if white
is able to advance on the queen side
those pawns will be unstoppable
meanwhile black also has to figure out
because it's not easy to get the d-pawn
rolling with the D file open let's say
white falls back with the queen queen C2
looks like a natural move that comes to
mind you're just trying to um you're
trying to just line up the battery as
well as you can go Bishop A2 next you
defend your A4 pawn and develop your
Rook to D1 you were asking who does this
benefit I do like White's position it
looks like white can build up pressure
on the D file why it's got this bishop
pair it's an open game it just looks
like more targets here for Benjamin Bach
to attack I actually the move that you
said throughout all that that I really
liked the most was Bishop A2 because at
first glitch I'm going for checkmate I'm
gonna be stubborn there's a knight on F6
you're not getting Checkmate come on SO
Bishop A2 redirecting to a new diagonal
I think that's a very powerful idea you
mentioned Rook D1 I like that as a
starting move because you're already
throwing to win a Pawn on E5 as the
d-pawn will be pinned to the queen
behind it but there are also ideas of
just getting the pawns going and this is
not an easy move so and Rook D1 played
first but I actually want to bring up
the analysis board because I actually
think this is a really key learning
moment for people so if we can analyze a
variation here that white can sacrifice
a pawn right now with the move A5 and
the reason I'm gonna give up this Pawn
is that the Rook takes A5 I'm going to
play A4 and then I'm going to bring my
Bishop to C3 and keep pushing my pawns
up the side of the board I'm trying to
get a queen I know there are many pieces
on the board but that's what I want and
if you don't play A5 and it looks like
he hasn't he said when Knight to C3
which is perfectly good move but look at
black all of a sudden it's black who's
going forward B5 oh okay blunder that's
eight seven Robert you just mentioned
it's not about the attack and it wasn't
until the F6 Knight is just overloaded
voluntarily with that move D5 blunder
alert Knight E5 you saw injured his face
he he's just beside himself right he
just cannot believe what's happened in
these last few rounds right it gets
Alice Lee he had a huge advantage and
then she took control he did Salvage
that point it's Fabiano he had a huge
Advantage was on the verge of winning he
left that slip and gave Fabian a win and
now D let's just go back I mean at this
point in time you're gonna see the eval
bar saying black is you know right in
this thing maybe bishop E6 first to
protect the square but Tanya he rushed
it he went D5 and that was a critical
blunder
and you know what you're normally going
to lose a D5 Pawn but I think you also
lose the E5 Pawn because there's just no
good way to defend it that Knight on F6
can't fall back eight seven always
hanging white can simply gobble up this
third Free Pawn pick up E5 pick up C5
everything's falling apart and and we
see it on Alexander he knows that that
was a big Miss and there's this is the
kind of blunder that there's no coming
back from no there isn't and the one
thing that Benjamin needs to do is avoid
getting back ranked checkmated uh he
trades Rooks don't play Move like Queen
takes E5 there will be a mate down here
so even the move Bishop A2 just to get
your rook in contact on the first rank
that makes sense H3 at any moment
perfectly reasonable uh so yeah this one
is now
over I mean we typically don't like to
call games before they finish but now
white is up a bunch of Pawns plus
remaining pawns are weak and yeah the
bishop pair is also an advantage for
white
everything looks like it is working for
white in this one but let's zoom out
while Benjamin Bach tries to convert
this into the full point things are
going the Saint Louis archbishop's way
in that one but what about the other
board it looks like on that bottom left
Nicholas theodoru also has everything
under control with the black pieces what
is White's Queen doing on A7 the end of
the board sure it's gobbled up a pawn
there but it looks like it's getting
trapped at some point with Knight B5
rookate all these ideas this could be
very dangerous for bardia and if
Theodore wins and Bach wins that's the
bottom left and bottom right if those
two results go the way the match is over
remember St Louis enter the round up a
full point six not five and a half you
need eight and a half points to win so
those two victories if St Lucie get them
will lead them to the playoffs and
meanwhile in the bottom right Alice Lee
it looks like she's down a pawn but has
the bishop pair gives her chances in the
top left five minute carwana well done
Dental damage that looks like a super
Grand Master slugfest just equal for now
but I think we should go to the bottom
left game between bardia Dennis far and
Nicholas Theodora because as you said
the queen is almost trapped over here
and B4 was just played by white so Tanya
the question okay can you play Rook 8
and win the queen yes I mean I don't
know if it's good or bad but rookie it
is being screaming to be played here
that Queen on A7 you've got no squares
you've got to sacrifice it for the rook
and the Knight but is that gonna be
enough Robert I don't think so wow it's
such a big question and by the way
there's a g Pawn missing like if there's
power on G2 I think white could
sacrifice the queen so we'll bring up an
analysis board to show you very quickly
what we're talking about Rook A8 no
their Knights cover the square you can't
go to B6 the queen covers it you just
can't go to any of these squares so the
queen is trapped and if the queen takes
Queen takes Pawn takes C5 okay we see a
position where white has a rook a minor
piece and this past Pawn on D5 after
Bishop takes C5 but if this Pawn were on
G2 and white king were safe we'd be
saying wow the Laster compensation feels
legit Alaska compensation is a rook
minor piece and a pawn for a queen that
equals nine points it's a fair trade but
the king is open this pawns a Target I
feel like that is what leaves black
ahead it's really about the placement of
this Pawn if it were on G2 the king
would be safe white would actually maybe
decide for choice
I have to admit I didn't even realize
that white was missing a Pawn on G2 it's
so easy to just feel that that partner's
got to be there where would the G2 Pawn
even disappear is that even a
possibility and then when you mention it
that just changes everything on the
board before you're talking about the
compensation of picking up the material
and the reason that it falls apart is
because White's King is super unsafe we
can imagine a position where Black's
Knight can jump to H4 the queen will
come back into play and that will be
game over on the king side B4 currently
played and Nicholas goes for it he goes
for the move Rook to a it was also a
necessity in that position and now we're
gonna see this play out Robert you
called it Bishop C5 you can come back
with the queen you can go Bishop E5 I
like this move you defend that Knight
you're eyeing that H2 pawn move the Rook
next Rook comes to E8 free up that night
and well are the asses not gonna allow
you to do that and at best now white has
chances to make a draw there is this
past d Pawn that's really what's keeping
white in the game you could take on A2
but then a pawn starts rolling like
let's get that pawn going maybe it's a
little bit too soon of course the bishop
is hanging but you just need to get it
going and it's getting there in the near
future
so there's still a lot of work to be
done here well The Rook on d8 at least
fights against the Deep Pawn if you go
D6 black can fall back with the queen to
E6 but pressure on the D6 pawn and also
find itself at a good Square to put
pressure on a black on White's King side
as well so that's what Nicolas is
relying on with his last move well Rook
D5 is not a threat watch out do not pick
that pawn up on D5 because Knight F6 is
Devious yes and I I just want to point
out for people who try to Envision what
defensive configuration you want what
white wants is to trade these pieces
that I'm going to highlight just you can
lose your d-pawn but as long as all
these pieces come off the queen will not
beat the rook and Bishop as the bishop
will just slide back and forth The Rook
can go up and down there's just really
no way to win so that is something that
RDA is looking for but while this one is
looking relatively balanced and both
sides have some Dynamic play to them
maybe we should zoom out for a second
because I see Benjamin Bach once again
in Big Time trouble he has a big
Advantage but he does not have much time
to work and then the bottom right it
looks like Paulina is much better
against Alice Lee so the Bulldogs need
every point right now because their back
is against the wall
wow Benjamin block is up an extra piece
but he's playing on seconds but it does
look like that one is completely winning
for white so I think we should head over
to another game let's take a look at the
pulley let's pick up the Benjamin block
and then we'll move over to the Polina
game well here it looks like it's
everything's over everything's defunded
for white an extra piece a lot of extra
pawns I don't really see how black can
create anything here yeah you're just
trying to flag your opponent but
Benjamin Buck is one of the best bullet
players on the site he plays with a
minute to start the game he is not
afraid he has two second increment in
this one and as you point out an extra
Bishop for White Queen G1 save this
bishop back here and after Queen H4
going after this H3 Pawn
sure you can even bring your king up to
G2 just to defend everything so I think
you're right we can zoom out of here but
it was good just to check in to see uh
what the position was because Benjamin
Buck you know he is winning this game
absolutely and he goes for Bishop 86 on
the top right threatening a mate in one
that's an interesting choice because
Queen F3 can be picked up with a check
but once white skin moves forward
everything is under control let's say
that is Benjamin box game meanwhile we
see on the bottom right Paulina
shavalova is the one who is in driver's
seat for the Bulldogs and we've got to
try and pull that one up because that's
a very important game that Paulina has
to take she plays with White against
Alice Lee there and we can see that
there's a lot of pressure the D5 Pawn
has advanced that is that is an extra
Pawn for white and a really nice one the
H Pawn can start advancing down the
board yeah this Knight on F5 a knife on
F5 can't really kick it out you need
your Bishop somewhere to do that and
this is the nature of having double and
isolated pawns you would love just push
that pawn to the side and I think black
has great compensation but for now this
Rook on D2 is under attack so Pauline on
the clock she needs to move a rook
somewhere don't go there that would
blunder The Rook to this bishop so
that's where the compensation comes from
is these Bishops are causing some
problems the the white Rooks or this
Pawn on D5 can be targeted in the near
future but I just I love White's
position this Knight and F5 the H Pawn
going and once this Rook moves out the
way I feel like even if you drop D5 you
should still have a sizable advantage
oh paulina's taking a bit of a think and
I don't see so many squares for the Rook
as you pointed out don't go E2 don't go
these three Rook C2 looks like a natural
response here you sidestep and then you
want to start pushing on the king side
the D5 Pawn is still under control and
we see that Paulina does move her Rook
now there are ideas of going G3 of
starting with H4 already and it looks
like the Bulldogs are going to take the
point on this one let's zoom out and get
a look because this means if we just get
our bird's eye view Benjamin Bach let's
say he takes the point for the Saint
Louis Archbishop Paulina equalizes it on
that bottom right board it comes down to
the left side of our bird's eye view yes
because St Louis needs two full points
Benjamin bark in the top right he's
getting that full point done I think
we're very confident in his chances and
that means on the left side if they get
two draws there that the match will be
over in their favorite actually look
what Benjamin did he gave up a piece
that's his past pawns we just stay in
this scene here look at the top right
those pawns that cannot be stopped so
Benjamin Bach decides let me actually
trade pieces make it easier for myself
and he knows he is winning with those
pawns running so quickly up the queen
side and yeah that's going to be a win
for the archbishops and Fabiano caruana
by the way on his final seconds over
there what is going on with his time
management
it's been terrible from the start of the
day let's jump straight into that with a
bog down Daniel the Arts taking on
Fabiano caruana playing on seconds there
and wow that looks like an extra
exchange for Bogdan but the two Bishops
and this G7 weakness gave white a lot of
compensation and not to mention that's
an extra Pawn I think this position if
anyone's trying despite being done in
exchange it's white look at that pawn
structure and the Bishops controlling
all key squares the Bishops are great
that's a past Pawn uh where's your Rook
going exactly you can't go anywhere down
here The Bishop's cover and H5 you hit
the bishop when you create a new
weakness and look at this bishop I think
it should go back around to B3 because
there is no rookie one check just
highlighted that and here it comes I
think Fabiano he's making small progress
and maybe he'll switch to attacking mode
oh nice that's a nice idea because the
queen from D3 not
es once the pawns start rolling down on
the queen side it will be all over right
now bogged on aiming to get that Queen
to E1 trying to trade up the Queens but
Queen D3 will just be in time to escape
that I think the white tabi can keep the
Queens on the board Queen D3 I love this
idea attacking eight seven and then
pushing the pawns further down and Tanya
benjenbach won his game so Fabiano wins
here with his past pawns the match is
over Queen trade about to happen how can
black stop these pawns especially with
eight seconds of the clock yeah that's
that's the big problem here even if
there is a defense it's so hard to find
and notice how that Bishop on C2
controls the B1 Square Rook C1 trying to
Target that bishop and stopping that C6
pawn bishop B3 will hit the D5 pawn and
that's what uh White can go for at this
moment I like to move Bishop B3 here
and I like Fabiano spending some time
how are you gonna protect this pawn it
doesn't but take on uh D5 here and this
Pawn is going you have B6 and B7 because
look at this bishop the bishop covers B6
so even if black decides to take this
opponent C6 I'm gonna shut very very
quickly the King goes away B6 oh thank
you for a pawn no thank you you can't
stop my other Pawn you can't get this
Rook behind the pass beep on and that
should be a win for white so as we see
Fabiano he does take the pawn on D5 the
king comes C7 it is time to play B6
E6 is coming in as you're pointing out
it doesn't matter with the tactics that
black takes on
some stoppable and once again Bobby he
just first attacks that Rook on C1 and
now again the move B6 is in the air if
Fabi wins this it's not just game over
it is match over Robert because with
Benjamin Bach already taking the win
home the archbishops just need another
point and we're getting another update
that Nicholas theodoro actually drew his
game and that's it
we have the Saint Louis archbishops
returning to the pro chess League
playoffs Fabiano caruana goes four out
of four Tanya it wasn't always easy he
had some losing positions but he fought
tooth and nail to bring this team back
from an 0-2 start in the PCL season to
win three matches in a row and head to
the playoffs this has been the golden
squad for the Saint Louis Archbishop
after a devastating first two matches
where they lost and they've been staring
at elimination every week they've won
three matches in a row with exactly this
lineup Fabiana Benjamin Nicholas and
Alice Lee taking the teams on doing what
needs to be done to make their way into
the playoffs and that means while we
celebrate for the Saint Louis Archbishop
Robert it's the end of the road for the
Bulldogs and I just want to point
something out in this game because this
was a cheeky Try by bogdon Daniels we
were talking in this position Bishop C6
Bishop takes Rook takes B7 you can't
stop the pawn from queening because the
Rook can't get behind the pond but he
was anticipating or hoping for me
praying for a pre-move because after
Rook takes C6 if you have pre-moved
Bishop takes C6 now the black Bishop
gets here and stops the pawn so it was a
last dish effort from a losing position
but I like that move Rook takes c66 and
I like seeing Fabiano not pre-moving he
had plenty of time and that secured
match Victory and the playoffs here the
archbishops come
that's so
that's so true a recapture on C6 but of
course Fabi is is in another league and
he does preempt it he found the right
way we've got one more game going on now
it doesn't matter for the match result
but still it's a fun fight between Alice
Lee and Paulina chevalova and we see
Paulina still in the driver's seat a
little heartbreaking for her that even a
win will not help her team it's too
little too late
and it might be too little too late even
in this game right now because we see
the eval bar it's hovering closer and
closer to the center uh black is down a
pawn but maybe there's Bishop takes E3
winning that pawn back if the Knight
moves you lose sight of the D5 Pawn that
will be targeted so Alice Lee I think
her best characteristic that I've seen
as a chess player is her willingness to
fight to the very end she is not
somebody who just takes a position for
granted she continues to hit these Rooks
right these bishops come to life and
will she play Bishop D4 back to go off
this Knight I'm not sure but I like the
her fighting Spirit and the way she's
hanging in these games even with top
positions
well and look at that Polina as well
just bringing her Rook to H1 the
starting spot of The Rook where actually
yes you've defended it there but it's
going to assist the H Pawn March down
the board and that was a really nice
little dance maneuver by the white truck
all the way to H1 where in fact it
looked like it was a passive square but
it's going to be the piece that's going
to assist white spawn to promoting to
that h8 square I love that little
maneuver there
and she's just maneuvering back and
forth between E5 and D4 with this bishop
A6 and see it with that one but I mean
this Pawn is going up the board fast so
I think it's time to bring the king up
closer to it and she says let me block
with the bishop instead this bishop is
active while also blocking this past
spawn
and now a white needs to find a way to
actually get past this bishop Bishop G4
Bishop F5 would be the dream but then it
does allow a black to step back with
that Bishop to D4 yeah I'll get that E39
also always watch out for Bishop E4
ideas as well but not so easy to
dislodge this Bishop from eight seven so
Alice Lee not only a Wizkid when it
comes to tactics but also really
defending hard in this one
she is I mean look at this her Bishop
just took away the F5 Square so the
knight's gonna go it might go to C4 but
then what's your next move maybe D6 but
then the Knight gets kicked out there
she I think did that a little bit too
early she welcomed the Knight into C6 I
was just mentioning that pawn push she
shouldn't have rushed it
Rook D6 but it's interesting to see how
the Bishops have been putting Prussia on
a white species but I think it's all
done for now now with the Knight coming
to C6 the bishop on D4 is not stable
anymore you can't afford to give up that
Bishop she says I'm fine giving up that
A7 Pawn but will not get out off that
that these two Bishops are basically the
soul of Black's position after Knight A6
as you're pointing out black has got the
counter player Rook A6 Rook a two
winning back the pawn not only winning
back the pawn but creating play as well
yeah this is crazy if you take this Pawn
she wants to open the AFL get an attack
of her own but she's going back and
forth yo-yo string between these scores
if you play H7 the king helps to stop
this Pawn over here so it's very close
and that's why the Rook came behind the
pawn she blocks it once more Tanya I
feel like this is anyone's game because
the time trouble
E4 ice is Unstoppable Jesus creating
chances and creating pressure and it
doesn't matter if it is right or wrong
practically creating big questions for
white to answer with seconds on the
clock Rook check we see the players just
blitzing out the moves now you can you
still can't pick up the 86 Pawn but the
king defends it from queening but this
looks like it's it's getting out of hand
Knight G6 that you're pointing out it's
seven coming in this is game over
no this is really well done for pulling
I don't know about F5 actually yes I do
know you're gonna play Knight G6 leading
to check G7 great game there like down
the stretch by Paulina she it's not
going to be enough for a team but it was
starting to get more and more towards
Alice's side but she says no not so fast
there's a reason my rating that's across
2500 she wins the game but unfortunately
for her not enough for a team
wow what a match what a game by Paulina
but as you're mentioning Robert it just
wasn't enough and speaking of a
dogfighter bloodbot this last run did
see three decisive games and the
Nicholas one ending in a draw and with
that it is the Saint Louis archbishops
who move on to the playoffs it is the
end of the road for the Croatia Bulldogs
what a close match we had but it always
felt like it was a St Louis Archbishop
who deserved this one Robert they had
been leading the match from the start of
the day from wrong one and a lot of
credit for that goes to Alice Lee
Alice Lee with one and a half out of
four I know at the end it's the score
she had after two rounds but to get
those early victories against the
opponing opposing top two boards that's
why Alexander ingish had a bad day he's
one out of four he couldn't get a
victory against her well done Daniel day
out he lost against her so she took
points from the top two boards and then
Fabiano Carona how much more can we say
about that guy four out of four score
against this Croatia Squad in an
elimination match Tanya is just one of
the top players in the world he's played
a world championship match he's a beast
Fabi no amount of cops are enough for
his chest he is the leading player of
the Saint Louis Archbishop and he's led
the team into the playoff after a
difficult difficult start for the team
what a performance by him and Robert not
only by him by everyone who predicted an
under 11 score including herself I know
you're celebrating on the inside there
with even though we had so much action
so much drama on the board it looks like
the decisive games we're under 11 so
congratulations to everyone who made
that predictions and uh let's take a
look at our standings as one more team
has made their way into the playoff and
that is the defending the reigning champ
in St Louis archbishops the three times
Champions which was staring at
elimination just after week two finally
win the third match in the row and in a
row and find themselves in to the
playoffs Robert I think it's it's
surprising the trajectory the road that
they had to the playoffs but it's also
not surprising to see them there this
team belongs in the playoffs I think
everybody was shocked that they started
oh and two including the players in the
roster but they found the lineup that
works for them Fabiano caruana he leads
the way he scores the majority of their
points and then when they can trust
board four to just pick up points by
beating not just 2600 gems but 2700
rated boged on Daniel dayaj Alice Lee
has become a star before her eyes she
has two IM Norms she's just 13 years old
her feet of rating is nearly 2 400 after
picking up those Norms so I feel like
you know the GM's in the middle Benjamin
Buck Nicholas Theodore we kind of
overlooked them a little bit but it's
because of what's happening in this
season Fabiano masterful performance
he's showing off his might and Alice Lee
is saying hey I'm not just the future of
Chess maybe I'm already here and I can
land those upsets
well the stars are made at the protest
league and definitely Alice Lee is is
one of them who's had
some of her biggest performance of her
career so far in this very event and of
course she's got a big road ahead of her
as the Saint Louis archbishops to make
it to play off but it's not the end of
the day for us Robert because we've got
one more huge big elimination match
coming up again between two teams that
at least I I'm super shocked to see here
I mean these two teams should have
already qualified into the playoffs it
is the chess bras taking on the blitz
and this time the chest bras do not have
the world champion Magnus Carlsen he's
not feeling well it was a last minute
replacement but we do have Anish giri
replacing Magnus Carlson making his
debut in the next match that's coming up
with chess Bros taking on the blitz
thank you
foreign
League action continues as we've got
another big matchup coming right up with
the chess Bros taking on blades and for
this one we've got joining us
Grandmaster Daniel naraditski Danny how
are you doing today
Tanya I'm doing great I was just on the
edge of my seat as a spectator watching
your excellent commentary with Robert
now I'm still on the edge of my seat but
this time it's as a commentator glad to
be here to cover the second match with
you
I'm so excited to have you here with us
because you got big chess action with
two extremely strong teams and and
Daniel I don't know if you heard about
this but the big breaking news of today
was that the Canada chess bras are in
fact without Magnus Carlsen he's got
some health issues a last minute
replacement take a look at the roster of
the Canada chess bras now looking at
this at this lineup that we've got it's
hard to imagine that they're even here
right now Daniel these guys should have
made it to the playoffs a long time back
they've got the world champion on top
they've got Anish giri who by the way
today will be replacing uh Magnus
yeah I mean listen they had to scrape
the bottom of the barrel for a
replacement and I think they found a
pretty decent one in Anish giri the
trash brows really made no introduction
Tanya I mean Geary uh Jordan met forest
and Sean rodrigue lamo is somebody I'll
talk about in Greater length when the
games begin he's an incredibly
impressive young man he went nine out of
nine in a Charlotte Norm tournament so
this guy is not to be messed with
um
well if you're impressed by the chess
bras roster take a look at the blitz
roster these are the players that
they're fighting against another team
that many of us are surprised that
they're even playing an elimination
match in fifth week Alexander grishek is
the three times world let's Champion
Maxine martial is the 2021 Blitz
Champion I mean these guys are super
jams they've got above 2700 and we've
got Katrina Lano who at 2563 just such a
strong player this roster I mean what
are these teams doing here today Daniel
how did this even happen no
crazy the fact that these teams lost two
matches is a great indication of how
monstrously strong the PCL is this
season but the blitz such an easy team
to root for I believe the only husband
wife team in the PCL Katarina and
Alexander and of course grishook up top
you see all you have to know
[Music]
try to win yes foreign
I love that Daniel as you said a family
of further with gristook and Katarina
both playing let's take a look at the
board assignments the big reveal of the
lineup of these two teams that we're
going to be seeing in action today and
we see the Canada chaspras Anish giri
making his debut at the top Port along
with Jordan along with another debutant
Sean who hasn't played yet for the
Canada chess bras he comes into play
today he is the world under 18 Champion
so do not underestimate that vote and
Jennifer you taking that fourth part
Robert I think the reason that Blitz
hasn't made it through yet already is
because Chris Chuck and Maxim I mean
these two players they play like God but
it just feels as if they haven't
performed to the ex to their
expectations and their level so far at
the protest League you're absolutely
right I mean in terms of mvl's
performance thus far those two losses
against Alexander indich at the end of
the blitz's matchup against the Croatia
which unfortunately did just get
eliminated is a memory that he is going
to have to wipe out I think mvl and
grishok are both going to have to score
over two out of four two and a half
three out of four that would really
propel them to Victory and on the chest
breath side Tanya again Sean rodrigue
limo if he can score I think one and a
half or more and if Jennifer you can
pull out an upset I think they're in
pretty good shape to make the playoffs
speaking of upsets we know the round
that it matters the most and is the
biggest possibility it is around one
let's take a look at our lineups for
kickoff because this is the most tilted
the most lopsided round of the match
where board one plays against Ward four
we got Anish now Daniel it's going to be
also a lot about how quickly he can find
his farm and Rhythm he hasn't played in
the protest league so far Magnus has
been the anchor of the ship for the
Canada chess bras with a heavy heavy
scar but now it's anisha's turn to
really show up he needs to do what needs
to be done for this team to take it to
playoffs the other player Jennifer you
she's at half out of eight for the team
and she has also underperformed now we
know just how strong a player she is
this is her chance of redemption this is
the match that it matters the most can
she deliver today and that's going to be
a deciding board as well it absolutely
will Tanya that is the big question and
Anish Gary as you're saying with huge
shoes to fill literally and figuratively
he didn't know he was playing until a
couple of hours before this match begins
so can he calm himself down uh can he
drink his coffee or tea or whatever he
drinks before a PCL match like this and
can he perform at the level that Magnus
Carlson has performed thus far it's an
incredibly tall order but I think we're
all very excited to see Anish giri in
the PCL
super thrilled it's always exciting to
have him in the roster and of course
he's had quite quite a good year so far
so let's see what Anish brings on the
board while it is going to be all about
bringing up your play to the point so
that you can get that golden spot of
eight and a half points to win the match
because take a look at the match format
now we know that the time control is 10
minutes with a two second increment the
team that scores eight and a half goes
through one will be eliminated one will
make it to the playoffs and Rob it
somewhere in my heart I feel as if I
want I'm sorry I called you Robert it's
just been a long day and sometimes I
compliment Tanya you're good
Daniel I have to say that I'm slightly
heartbroken because I would have loved
to see both these teams in to the pro
chess League playoff because they belong
there they are
as Michael Tall famously said you have
to take your opponent in this case your
opposing team into a deep dark force or
two plus two equals five and there is
only a pass back for one so which one is
that going to be there we see Mr Geary
cupping his head in his hands he needs
to start off with a bank he needs to try
to defeat by hell Boyer with the black
thesis in game one and of course you can
see that one minute penalty Tanya that
he starts with because of the late
replacement you can thank Magnus Carlson
for that but in all seriousness we wish
him the best of health in a quick
recovery
that's a really important point so every
game a niche will be starting with a one
minute deficit being a late replacement
for Magnus but you got to do what you
got to do and Robert as you pointed out
he Robert I need to stop saying that
Daniel
Daniel it's so important for him to get
on the game as quickly and we see a
sicilian on the board is he going to go
for the night off we know he's got a
course on that so in the in the cgc uh
Final in Toronto Tanya I called Levy
Wesley like six or seven times across
multiple days so you've got a long way
to go until that's filled but again I
take it as a compliment uh so you're
totally good Daniel we'll get there
we'll get there at some point during
today's commentary where I will indeed
keep calling you Daniel but for now just
bear with me and it looks like Anish had
a bit of a think there before deciding
to potentially we could have a night off
now D6 you trade Knight F6 and then A6
on the board I'm predicting it it's
gonna happened Daniel does Anish realize
that he started with one minute less and
not one minute more though he's yeah
that's a great question why is he taking
so long to make these opening moves he
appears I said yeah
I don't know what's up but he's he's
already spent a minute Tanya I mean
that's a little concerning on move three
yeah and we can see on camera that there
is a little bit of switching of screens
going on there it looks like he's
figuring something out but this could
prove to be very costly he's down two
and a half minutes on the clock trades
quickly Knight F6 night of coming up
Daniel or not coming up Daniel Knight C6
on the board
yeah I mean expecting a night off Gary
has done courses on the night or and on
the dragon but here he plays a third
Sicilian this is called the Rouser or
the classical Sicilian depending on who
you ask and Boyer responds with a
relatively rare continuation an early
King side fianchetto the main move of
course is Bishop C1 to G5 that leads to
a very theoretically heavy battle Boyer
kind of sidestepping uh the most topical
theory of course G3 is also pretty well
known
wow so G3 played and quickly answered by
Anish making his intentions clear that
he wants a fan shout out of the bishop
as well on G7 and now it is boil taking
a little bit of a thing here creates on
C6 before developing that Bishop to G2
because he wants to go E5 and that looks
like a pawn sacrifice really early on
can't black just snap that up on E5 yeah
I've sort of 10 vaguely aware of this
continuation it's a positional Pawn
sacrifice so black is not black is not
going to give that pawn up easy or is he
I thought a niche was going to put his
King on C7 instead he gives back the
pawn which white can take Bishop takes
C6 Rook C8 and the bishop could dip back
to A4 simultaneously guarding the C2
pawn and Tanya white will have a three
on on majority on the queen side so a
bit of a questionable choice in the
early going by Anish but in any matters
related to the opening I trust him
completely so I'm halfway sure that
Bishop F5 is still his preparation
I mean Anish and his openings right
Daniel you can't fault them he's one of
the strongest most well prepared Elite
Grand masters of the world and it's hard
to imagine that he doesn't know what
he's doing but it looks like he's taken
huge huge risk out of the opening not
even to talk about the clock deficit
with the bond deficit that he's going to
be facing trying to prove his
compensation there where he will show us
the way and while that develops let's
zoom out and take a look at the other
boards Anish giri today heading board
one for the Canada chess bras but of
course this is the protest League every
game matters every board matters and I
see action is on let's bring up a bird's
eye view because we also have the world
Blitz Champion Max Air lagrav who by the
way has been quite a Mainstay in the
pro-chass league Maxi Maxime and
grischuk have both been playing every
week for their team and we see he goes
up against Sean another debit for the
chess bras this this week
yeah and Sean as I mentioned he is an
international Master but not for very
much longer Tanya there's certain young
players you look at their chests and you
just know that it's not a matter of if
it's a matter of when uh they achieve
their grand master title and the
responsibility on the shoulders of Sean
and Jennifer you and Boards three and
four isn't to go four out of four that
uh responsibility belongs to anishagiri
they have to score a well-timed upset or
two and that can really give their team
the need so what do we make of this
opening where 11 moves in this started
out as a Moscow variation that's early
Bishop B5 Check In the Sicilian so
Rodriguez sidestepping mvl's Knight or
Preparation he's just captured the
bishop on E7 what catches my eye Tanya
as MBL recaptures with the king I love
it what a move by MBL he decides that
his little ponchell in the center
guarantees King safety I love it too I
think MBL has a pretty decent position
here and most importantly it's
unbalanced so it gives them some chances
to win
this is going to be a lot of fun and one
of the other subtleties of capturing
with the king is that if he would have
taken with the Knight a thematic idea
for white is to open up the B file with
the move B4 that's why the Rook on B1
will get Super Active so with this
recapture MBL has made sure that Sean
doesn't have the breaker B4 at least for
the time being and as you mentioned a
very unique way to finish development
there and we see the Rook comes out and
we're probably going to see an
artificial castling with the King
marching to f8 and to G8
very likely we will Rookie 8 signals
that MBL wants to bring his King back
and after he does he will have the
possibility of reopening the center with
uh E5 E4 although positionally that
could favor white because if you look at
this D6 Pawn once white captures on e4
Sean can put a rook on D1 and start
harassing that backward Pawn on D6 so I
don't think Maxime is going to rush with
a movie four I think he's gonna drop his
King back to G8 and Tanya two can play
at that game you pointed out A3 before
well black it expand on the queen side
as well with the equivalent idea A6 D5
so the eval bar it assigns a slight Edge
to the Frenchman with three names
although there are two frenchmen's with
three names in this game I guess John is
a Canadian with three names but we'll
see uh who is able to strike on the
queen side first
wow that is the big question and as we
see a Maxime getting the king to safety
as you mentioned a match between well a
three-name game here going on between
Maxim and Sean and it looks like instead
of going for a6b5 another different Pawn
structure controlling that B4 advance
that we've been talking about Maxine
takes control off that square with the
Knight and the pawn on C5 and the pawn
on A5 controlling all of that also white
doesn't have a D4 break I'm really
liking Black's position here with no
breaks for white it looks like Black's
the one with the peace activity Daniel
while this one develops and I'm so glad
I didn't call you Robert by the way
almost did that let's get up our bird's
eye view and check out the action that's
on because there is a board that caught
my attention take a look at that top
right with Katrina Lana against Jordan
man Forest there's a lot going on on
that one Katarina is an incredibly
dangerous one E4 player and we have a
very complex Karo Khan It's very obvious
when you look at that structure as we go
to that game that this emerged from an
advanced Caro where Jordan at some point
played the move c65 in order to break up
White's Pawn chain uh Katarina said
thank you very much I'm grabbing that
pawn I'm defending it with my knight and
I'm defending the other Pawn with my
other Knight and Tanya the problem in
these types of positions is that black
can win the pawn back on E5
um and if we bring up an analysis board
you might wonder why Jordan is
procrastinating why he's not taking on
F3 but if you extend this line white
gets the bishop pair white hits the
Knight on E5 if you fall asleep you
blunder a piece and if you move the
Knight back Tanya with the black king
stuck in the center I've seen a lot of
games decided quickly by the march of
the F1 which could shatter Black's Pawn
chain and open up the king so Jordan
isn't touching that with a 10-foot pole
instead he's focusing on his King side
development but right now that comes at
the cost of the pawn if he doesn't take
on F3 for a couple moves longer Katarina
could secure that extra Pawn by putting
a bishop on D4 and maybe a rook on E1
I love the points that you're
demonstrating especially that idea of
going F4 and breaking open the center if
E5 was picked up you called it Bishop D4
not so easy now for Jordan to pick up to
recapture that pawn on E5 white can of
course even think about trading on C6 to
keep the pawns alive but why give up
that Bishop it's such a beautiful piece
instead Rook to E1 so that whenever your
button does capture that Knight on F3
the E5 Pawn suddenly becomes gets
defended by that Rook honey one that is
a nice way to keep the bishop pair and
keep the pawn Advantage great play by
Katarina wagono and if I'm your then I'm
thinking about leaning in to the pawn
deficit you might not be able to win the
pawn back on E5 and that's okay and the
Karo Khan is standard uh to play long
periods of time down upon and the move
F6 is standard fare in the French and in
the Caro but Jordan decides on a
different path I think he is stubbornly
aiming at the D5 pawn and he is thinking
about taking on F3 in fact Tony he might
even get away okay with the immediate
Knight takes E5 without having to give
up his Bishop there but then of course
he's gonna have to be very very careful
not to get skewered on the e-file right
95 you could get a mass trade and then
white could play a well-timed F3 and pin
the bishop Katarina she drops her Knight
back to D2 forcing this bishop back and
I think she is aiming for F4 but then
you have to be especially careful about
black playing F6 this is going to get
really complicated
it's gonna get really complicated really
quick and I love that this night
retreating move to D2 just keeps
everything under control and she does
what you're saying Daniel she goes for
the idea of f4 and it looks like F6 is
the only break in the position because
black has to find his activity here
after F6 also notice how the F4 Pawn
becomes a little tender but instead
first Jordan asks Katrina to make a
decision with a bishop does she want to
trade the bishop for the Knight on C6 or
fall back all the way to F1 if she falls
back I have little doubt that Jordan
will strike in the center with the move
F6 there's F6 but the more I look at the
queen side the more it occurs to me that
this knight from CA can also move back
to be it or perhaps even to d8 and black
will suddenly have four attackers on the
C5 Pawn so maybe it's that pawn which
Jordan is trying to win back I haven't
even been paying attention to this Pawn
but Jordan could win it back he could
delay the move F6 save it for a rainy
day but right now he's tossing the ball
back into Katarina scored forcing her to
invest valuable seconds decide where to
put the bishop whether to take on C6 I
like Jordan's position
Bush of the F Pawn was a significantly
weakening move by katsurina so we'll
watch this middle game closely as it
unfolds but we've got a couple of other
fascinating games unfolding before our
eyes Tanya let's go back to the bird's
eye view This Is A Feast for the eyes
absolutely and you're totally right
while Katrina invests her time let's
invest our time into these positions
especially that bottom right board with
Alexander gristook taking on Jennifer
you Alexander's got the black pieces but
we see the Kings have been castled on
the queen side there's so much happening
here that D5 square is weak the Bishops
are eyeing each other on the long
diagonal and that is the board that I
would like to do a deep dive on but also
really quickly just on that bottom left
Maxim with a slightly bit better end
game there and it all comes down to that
pawn structure we were talking about on
the queen side where he's fixed white
spawns the Rooks in the center there's a
pin on E3 the Knight can jump to B3 the
pawns eventually can go forward to B5
looks like it's black with all the
player there I'm loving Maxim's position
but let's do a deep dive first in the
gristook Jennifer board as that's
heating up great observations Tanya we
will keep an eye on the mvo game and
should more clarity be reached in that
end game uh we'll try to catch the end
of that game but yes I really like this
Jennifer you Grisha position there's a
lot to unpack here first thing that
jumps out at me is that both sides have
castled Queen side and I think both
sides kings are relatively safe for the
time being the center is sort of
semi-open but both sides a very solid
Pawn structures on the queen side white
has a bishop pair Bishop on E3 Bishop on
G2 grishook has only one Bishop on B7
and he could try it with a pair of
Bishops by moving his knight from C6
let's say to E5 he could also strike in
the center with E5 Tanya but that seems
to be very ill-advised because you do
not want to give white a major outpost
on D5 where only 14 Moves In what a
surprise that Alexander grishek has
already used up half of his time I know
nobody has ever said that never happened
before never ever we just don't see that
happen but what always amazes me is how
Sasha gets down on second and then just
starts playing like a god so you really
cannot ever play on his clock but we see
both players here down to about five
minutes in a very complicated middle
game already where only a set of minor
pieces has been traded off this is
everything to play for and once again
this is Jennifer Yu's chance to redeem
herself in the protest league so far
such a critical match for the chess bras
if she's able to save just half a point
a point for her team that will go a long
way in chess Bros path to that playoff
ticket but it's not gonna be easy
because I think Alexander has got
everything that you want when you try to
make something out of the black pieces
there are ideas like H5 H4 opening the
king side trying to create a weakness
that you mentioned the move you
mentioned the D5 Square you can play E6
not only controlling D5 but actually
someday hinting at getting a D5 break in
yourself
absolutely there's a lot of potential
for both sides and in the center but you
could say that black controls the pawn
breaks in the center white as no Pawn
breaks to speak of and I called this
move illa device but then Sasha grishock
played it so in your face Mr commentator
says grishook but I don't think he's
playing E5 because he's in love with his
position I think he wants to reach a
little bit more clarity get some pieces
off the board I think Jennifer's
slamming that Knight into D5 grishock
might capture it and the thing is Tanya
whites piece on D5 isn't very stable if
we pull up an analysis well we don't
even need to do that right now because
they're making the moves for us after
Bishop takes D5 the Knight can drop back
to E7 and if you get a trade on B7 yes
congratulations you have an outpost on
D5 but what piece are you going to put
there if the Bishops are traded that I
think is what grishok is kind of saying
and I'm expecting him to play 97 here
uh so Bishop D5 on the board I like your
idea if a black plays Knight E7 and
there is trade of the Bishops it is the
Knight on E7 which controls D5 more than
anything else very difficult to imagine
white getting any hold of that also
notice how the Knight on E7 safeguards
the F5 Pawn if needed so black can
actually recapture the bishop with his
own Queen he's going into a bit of a
thing because I think psychologically
Sasha wants to try and keep as much of
chances as possible he wants to keep as
many pieces on the board which is why he
makes the move Rook Cafe just delaying
the trade there and I see that you don't
seem very happy with this move Daniel
I'm a little bit puzzled about Rook f8 I
think he's trying to lend another
supporter to uh the F5 Pawn but
obviously this Rook is going to be
pretty passive I would even consider
playing F4 if I'm Jennifer you
in order to to freeze the F5 Pawn in
place and white has a very simple plan
consisting of doubling Rooks on the D
file and piling up the pressure on the
backward Pawn on D6 tiny it's not only
the D5 square that Sasha weakened when
he played E5 it's also this D6 Pawn
itself but most important thing for
Jennifer is to avoid this getting into a
Time scramble you do not want any sort
of time scramble against Alexander
grishek and I really like the way that
Jennifer you was managing her time thus
far she jumps her Bishop out to H6 and
says get off me forcing The Rook off of
the file Rook F6 Bishop G5 versus
Alexander grishek's Rook to move back to
the e-file but this bishop doesn't
really have all that many prospects
either
yeah well luckily for black the G7
square is under control because Bishop
C7 would actually win The Rook on h8 but
because the queen is on D7 that's not a
possibility so far and now white needs
to watch out because if at some moment
black can get a successful F4 that
Bishop on H6 could potentially be
trapped there so there are a lot of
ideas that exist in this position with
that Bishop on 86 which could tactically
work out for black I like this little
dance of real Cafe rookie 8 that you're
pointing out and rookie one played so
Jennifer continues to play Fast very
important against Sasha brings the
pieces into the game I would be a little
worried about that Bishop 86 a night
trade a bishop trade is offered also
notice how that Knight can potentially
land onto F7 or E6 and get that final F4
break in
98 Knight F7 Knight takes B7 also
possible to reinforce the D6 Pawn I
think it's impossible to speak of an
advantage for Grisha this is going to be
a fascinating climax in this game but a
couple of other games have reached a
climax so let's dive back into the
bird's eye view I'll point out lower
left Tanya it looks like MBL continues
to make progress in that end game his
Knight on C4 threatens a fork on B2 a
fork on E5 and the pawn on A3 which I
think he's about to capture so MBL I
think is pretty much has this in the bag
but let me tell you about someone who
doesn't have it in the bag and each
Geary over on the top left is locked in
a Time scramble in this end game against
my hell Boyer so Tanya shall we take a
closer look at that end game time
scramble as Boyer tries to score a big
upset against the newcomer anishikiri
we shall Daniel and it's funny that you
say Anish Guri a newcomer in the same
sentence never thought we'd hear that
one but as you're pointing eye well the
only impressive thing for Anish has been
that he's managed to equalize the time
and it looks like in fact more than
equalized because my hell is the one
who's under uh under 30 seconds he needs
to be fast in a position which seems
very much in control that Knight on C5
hitting that pawn on A6 but he decides
not to capture it I'm slightly surprised
96 was a possibility this is too passive
against any other player he would have
taken that pawn and started playing B5
but you're facing anishkira you're
double triple checking everything you're
second guessing yourself and his idea is
to prevent blackstroke from infiltrating
the secondary so I get it I get what
he's doing the problem is that Black's
one Pawn is stopping White's Pawn Armada
and white might be unable to create a
passbonna niche on the other hand is
going to start setting his Pawns in
motion he starts with G5 he's going to
play E4 and I think black's position
Tanya is easier to play for a practical
standpoint you could also go after the H
Pawn if White's King won 10 seconds he
needs to make a center he does five
seconds now for Boyer oh my God play two
score
Tanya I think he's slipping
this is panic this is panic mode on by
Mahal I am shocked that he didn't take
the pawn on A6 Knight B3 was a passive
decision now Anish can even fall back
with the bishop and he does it to
advance the F Pawn further F5 coming in
E4 F4 ideas who's going to stop it not
in my head nobody and he goes back to C5
he's stumbling on his no I mean this has
been just a meltdown in the in the time
scramble but you can't really blame him
you're facing an issue he came very
close to drawing or even winning this
game out of the opening and look at gear
response bang E4 bang E3 bang and the
pawns are totally and utterly
unstoppable my hell is trying he stopped
E3
he could have picked up the A6 Pawn like
20 moves ago but instead wasting so much
time and now Anish responds and marched
on the boat so much faster Daniel you're
pointing out white still goes B6
B7 he's threatening to promote oh but
Gary's gonna deliberate attack on H3 and
that's gonna deflect whites King here
he's gonna promote and he will Queen
from Bishop F5 was an evil evil move by
Gary and he follows it up with Checkmate
what a finale
and Mahal there we saw the frustration
on him he knew that he had this so close
that retreating move with the Knight
instead of capturing that pawn on Asic
something that he did far too late in
the game and Anish giri starts with what
he needed to a win to get himself set up
for a very very big match that's coming
up we've got action on the other board
let's take a look and wow the Jennifer
you Alex and the Christian game has
heated up with that H Pawn advancing
down the boat but it is the bottom left
where Maxim vashir Le grab looks like
he's set to level the score which Anish
giri won against Mahal
won his game so we could go also to the
Katarina Wagner game in the top right so
the score is currently 1-1 mvl delivers
for the blitz that was an incredibly
smooth game against uh Sean rodrigue uh
whose Praises I sung but at losing to
mvl uh absolutely not a shame at all but
Katarina lagno is very close to securing
an important half point for the blitz
she's locked in a double Rook end game
against Dan Force material is equal I
see the pawn on D6 Tanya who do you
think is playing for a win here
yeah it's tough to see I see our eval
Bar says it's absolutely level but let
me tell you that jaw is a is one of the
least is probably the least likely
result in this one with blacks B for
pawn and White's D6 pawn it is a game
for all three results after Rook A4
black is threatening a B3 check which
now after Rook B5 wouldn't make so much
sense because the king falls back and
then suddenly the B3 Pawn will be left
hanging instead you're with a rook trade
if you take then we'll see a trade of
the a pawn for the d-pawn and this will
fizzle out into a draw I think it will
Jordan has the token Advantage here he's
won the pawn but these two on one end
games are always
basically a dead draw Jordan can try to
play for when I would try to go King E7
and then Rook D7 and pretend like you're
playing but as long as Katarina doesn't
allow The Rook trade as long as she
doesn't blunder the H1 and both things
are exceedingly unlikely she should be
able to hold half a point here but hey
Jordan can play this for 50 moves and
I've seen crazier things happen
100 especially at the pro chess League
we've seen all kinds of turnarounds so
this is not a result that we can decide
on but it does look like it's heading
towards a draw meanwhile the other game
let's bring up our bird's eye view
quickly and go into the Sasha versus
Jennifer you because that ain't no
ending Daniel that is madness on the
board let's do a deep dive let's bring
that up as the Rooks are playing on the
king side while Jennifer you trying to
create counter play at the center of the
board but I think things are going from
bad to worse for white hair
yeah they are F4 it's a very powerful
move grishek is gonna double Rooks on
the H file look at this Knight on F7
Tanya it's guarding the D6 Pawn that is
Black's only Target and if that Target
is safely protected white Brooks are
unemployed they have nothing to do Rook
H2 was threatened Jennifer you is in
full defensive mode she's also down 40
seconds on the clock so Alexander
grishok his time management in time
scrambles is exquisite he always leaves
himself with enough time to figure out
the complexities of the position I think
he might even try to push this Pawn down
to E4 which will create even more
complications and Jennifer might just
not have enough time to deal with them
as she drops her Queen back she is
certainly giving it the old College try
well the D6 spawn is attacked and you're
mentioning the old College try well
there's all college defense try here as
well with the King stepping up to C7 and
he does it because why not you defend
the D6 Pawn with your king there's
pressure on a F3 white builds up a
further attack meanwhile Sasha trading
off this Rook F3 Pawn will fall the
other Rook comes on to H3 it just looks
like White's weaknesses are going to be
far more dangerous you're pointing out
E4 and this is going to be very
difficult for Jennifer you on seconds to
defend yeah sure Sasha's got seconds as
well but we know Christian seconds don't
matter that's like being a classical
game for him we do but you just never
know and Jennifer has defended this so
valiantly she's still trying to
orchestrate counter play in the center
but she's given up the F3 Pawn Sasha
with five seconds he takes on F3 with
the Knight Jennifer pushes G5 I think
she's trying to sack maybe a rook on E5
and open up Black's King two seconds for
Grisha because he stops the pawn from
behind he allows the move Rook T3 wait a
second one second
oh my gosh Grisha might have to give up
his Knight
oh my God
that's D2 at the end
E2 is threatened but white king can stop
the pawn Jennifer has great drawing
chances
and this is a deciding game because
Katrina alhano has drawn her game
against Jordan the match is absolutely
level and it all comes down to this
board oh my gosh this Pawn end game
might be a drop but it might also be
winning for black Jennifer she doesn't
take the Knight and grishek's gonna win
he's gonna go King E4 or is he Jennifer
goes back tries to take D6 don't blunder
the bishop oh
our eval bar is going absolutely crazy
up and down it looks like every move is
either a great move or a mistake King D7
following that up Bishop F6 it looks
like a King Pawn ending is lost for
white and Jennifer is unsure of going
for the trade on E5 she repeats but
Alexander says no repetition right now
trades upon on D5 Bishop C7 I think
that's a draw now Jennifer can take the
Knight on E5 and this should be a draw
grishook is going to lose his Pawn now
Bishop takes E5 BC oh and it's
apparently lost
oh because Jennifer's gonna end up in
zuk's vong B5 and she's lost she good
she's lost not have taken on C4
oh my God that and that's it it's game
over but we've got to show why she could
not have pick up she could not have
picked up that pawn on C4 and it looked
like it was so close to holding that
position the players are playing so fast
and that is it Alexander Grisha gets the
job done for the blitz oh my God
this position right both kinks are
staring at the D3 Pawn so the side that
exhausts its waiting moves last is gonna
Force its opponent into this song and
that side is black white plays A3 black
does not play A5 then Sasha is in zuk's
Wong and he actually loses instead he
pushes A6 A4 A5 white has to step back
with her King black steps into the
opposition pushes the pawn forward and
forces white to give up all of her Queen
side pawns this isn't stalemate because
white has C5 and black I think no not B5
but B takes C5 black wins the game what
a heartbreaker for Jennifer and her
mistake was to take the Knight if she
had taken the pawn here a draw offer
would have happened that's it Knight
takes C4 King takes D3 would have been a
draw what a heartbreaker but what a
valiant resistance for Jennifer you
wow that end game and all these
subtleties that you just pointed out so
instructive there Daniel that how in a
King Pawn ending every Temple matters
every pawn move counts it's a difference
between a draw and a loss and a draw and
a win you can save half a point and that
big Miss Jennifer was always eyeing that
trade on E5 but went for it at the wrong
time when in that moment simply picking
up the C4 Pawn would have sealed the
deal and level the match but instead it
is Blitz who get the job done in round
one winning with the smallest Martin
with Maxine busher lagrav and Alexander
gristook the two super Grand masters of
the blitz team winning their games and
meanwhile it is Anish giri who kept the
sail going for the Canada chess bras
with a win on the top board uh Daniel
there's zero doubt that this is going to
be a nail-bitingly close match
the chess for us aren't going to cry
over this result they're they only have
a one point deficit I mean we've seen
three or even four point deficits erased
in a single round in the PCL so nothing
has been decided at all ladies and
gentlemen this second PCR match of the
day is gearing up to have an incredible
finale so stay pegged to your seats we
will certainly stay pegged at two hours
and we will have more coverage Tanya but
I need a little bit more tea and I think
you might as well
absolutely that much action coming up
you guys don't want to go anywhere as
the chest bras take on Blitz it is round
to action on the other side of this
brick
I have three puzzles here yeah I don't
think I'll be much easier than this okay
I have the warm up yep 10 seconds all
right and let's see this one but um
yeah that's pretty straightforward I
think
yeah that's I mean it's obviously uh
Bishop D2 King A5 or K3 Bishop A4 Queen
takes B7
it is not it's not I'll give you a
second try
really and also five seconds if you want
to look at 40. no I I don't need to I
didn't ah because there's there's a rook
G3 truck that I missed this is true um
okay just give me one side let me think
about this
yeah I'm not gonna get it without
actually thinking so you can just tell
me what it is okay it is uh Queen to
every first
okay okay yeah I was I would have had a
thing for like a couple of minutes to
get that that's that's that's actually
pretty tricky
yeah I think I found it
it is not Bishop D2
okay let me try again I know the
position is
okay
this one is going to be more
of course
um
so I'm thinking about Queen F3 right now
I'm not sure Bishop takes and it's and
only them in something too so that there
is no Rook G3
yeah okay I would stay with queen of
free in the first one and after Bishop
takes the previous
one yeah yeah yeah you're you're nailing
this one
ah okay okay I think um I think I this
one I I have I think it's probably Queen
GT first and then we should do so
because the bishop D2 there is two G3
so I think with G3
maybe better because then I just deflect
the bishop as well
perfect yeah we know
yeah I guess Bishop D2
King A5 rookie three check
unfortunately Bishop D2 doesn't work
because of virtue G3 RG3 so Queen F3
first yes okay Queen of the reverse yeah
perfect
nope
it's not meat not quite it is a queen ah
oh it's a queen move
oh Queen F3 yeah it's Queen F3 all right
we should take 50 Bishop D2
uh yeah yes exactly
it matter that you have these serious
brothers and
and they were about Excellence they were
about winning and they understood
Checkmate was like that's what it's
about it's about winning this damn game
like we you're not trying to pretend or
or learn just learn you're not here uh
like just to be a spectator you're here
to win and if you're going to win you're
going to have to do the work you're
going to have to do not just the
external world but the internal work
because your pride and your feelings and
all that that thanks no thanks that's
just gonna go by the wayside
a matter that you
are or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
it's over Alice Lee secures victory for
the archbishops what an incredible
performance welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and nights spraws and
Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives unbelievable and you see
Arjun he shakes his head but pranav with
a second huge huge in a row entering its
Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot the
PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion he's blundered
he blocked my friends
it's the 2023 Pro chess League which
team can Rise Above the Rest they won't
be able to do it alone
hybrid
the blitz take their lead in round one
against the Canada chess bras and one of
the big players in that who managed to
get that done is the Frenchman with
three names Maxine washer lagrove the
2021 World Blitz Champion he is just
such a beast in all formats whether it's
classical Rapid or Blitz he's been in
the world Elite for over a decade now
and we see that Maxine he's ready to go
for round two he knows exactly how
important his role is today in this
elimination match it is go big or go
home Daniel he needs to get the job done
and I look at Maxi he looks like a guy
on a mission right now listen Tanya we
know all is right in the world and mvl
is snacking during a chess match I don't
think I've seen a single SEC or RCC or
cgc or anything C PCL match where mvl is
not snacking so we know everything's
good well we know everything's good
because he won his first game in
excellent style against a Canadian with
three names and now he faces Jennifer Yu
a tough matchup given the form that
Jennifer you is in came oh so close to
tying Alexander grishok but now
Jennifer's reward is to face the 2021
World Blitz Champion Tanya man oh man
life in the PCL is hard
it is hard and the last game of Jennifer
that you were pointing out that was a
wild end game and just all the
turnarounds that we witnessed now we
were talking about Maxim scoring where
he wasn't the only one it was Alexander
grish took as well who scored a big win
taking his team uh over to the Finish
Line in that wild end game against
Jennifer you Anish Gary winning a point
for the Canada chess bras we're going
into round two now uh Daniel but what
impressed you the most in that round one
well MBL I think played the smoothest
game on the blitz side Alexander grishok
he stuck with it he kept his foot on the
gas pedal and Kaiser the chess got us
rewarded him in the end I was also
impressed with Katarina Wagner's Play
She Drew Jordan manforest from a
position of strength now she has an even
more difficult trial she faces Jordan's
compatriot with the black pieces no less
but I'm expecting Katarina to score at
least one upset she already did did in
the first round now if she can hold a
draw or even score a win against Anish
giri that would give the blitz a massive
push and of course Tanya MBL and
Alexander grishok both of them have the
white pieces they have to do their job
that is I would agree with everything
that you just said except that if
Katrina's cause I don't even think it's
an upset I mean Katrina is just such a
beast she is such a strong player she's
over 2500 and she is up against Anish
giri and she's looking at saving
whatever points that she can for her
team she's definitely capable of it
we've seen her performance in the
protest League we've seen the blitz they
have all they've gone alternative
between Cornett and Katrina Lano Katrina
has performed so far for the team she
plays the top board against Anish Anish
with that first round win is ready to go
once again and then we've got liftoff he
starts with the King spawn opening and
we see his clock it went down to nine
minutes because just to remind everyone
he is a last minute replacement to
Magnus Carlsen and the penalty for that
has been that he starts the game with a
one minute deficit and Katarina essing
an early age six Italian this is all the
rage now black preparing an early King
side expansion with G5 you can also play
this more modestly with G6 but either
way black generally pushes the Jeep on
early in this line but I had a fun piece
of trivia time did you know that
Katarina started an internet company uh
in her spare time it has the lowest
latency of any internet company it's
called lagno
um
what is that I don't even know if you're
joking anymore actually yeah I mean I
was very convinced
coffee but I think that's a great
business
it
I love it but it looks like she's not
gonna need it because the chess carrier
is going absolutely perfect here for
Llano and she does go for the idea that
you mentioned with G5 it's not only an
attacking move but it aims at developing
and in fact very often Daniel in these
positions black in fact goes for King
side castling uh the other plan that
black has is to develop the queen to E7
bring that Bishop to E6 and the third
one is to transfer that knight from E7
to G6 eyeing that F4 Square that's the
one that Llano has chosen for her fight
against the niche but I don't like the
move Knight E7 and it's precisely
because Anish strikes in the center
that's one of the most annoying most
tilting things about facing the Italian
you never know when your opponent is
going to strike in the center with D4
and Anish chooses the perfect time to do
it why is this the perfect time to play
D4 well black has temporarily
relinquished her control over the E5
pawn and you might say oh well black
just goes Knight G6 if we could bring up
an analysis board what happens if black
plays Knight G6 the evil bar shoots up
white takes on E5 and black lands in a
pawn down end game no matter which way
black takes White's going to capture
capture the Queen Don't take on F7 first
because then The Rook guards the queen
first you take the queen then you take
F7 and not only is black a pawn down but
this bishop uh Tanya is biting on grenin
and Black's King is caught in the
crossfire all sorts of shenanigans
coming right up so Katarina can't play
Knight G6 but if she has to play he
takes D4 well we know that that is a
huge concession and after Knight takes
D4 white could strike at the king side
with F4 I think Anish has a big
Advantage after his last move
play an opening as committal as 86 G5
against the Italian and then you make
the move 97 you have to know what you're
doing and after D4 we see that she's
gone into a bit of a think tank you're
pointing out that she needs to trade on
D4 allowing White's pieces a lot of
activity that would be great for a niche
but instead
Lano goes for a peace sacrifice herself
she goes 94. it's hanging but after 94
she wants to go D5 what's going on here
let's keep the analysis board up we're
gonna need it well first impressions is
that D5 wins back the piece yes but I'm
a little bit worried about this weird
move Knight to G3 trying to get this
Knight right over this weak spot on H5
and uh I don't really want to talk about
what happens if black tries to preserve
the bishop here Tanya maybe you can
maybe the Eva the the analysis board can
talk about it this is all we need to
know apparently Knight G3 though isn't
the best that white can do maybe a
simpler approach just D take C5 gives
white a huge Advantage according to the
eval bar because no matter which piece
black takes it opens up the D file white
has a check on F6 so I really think it's
pretty evident that things are not going
Katarina's way but let's see if Anish
can punish uh her play properly and I
think he is he takes C5 is already on
the board Tanya bad news for Katarina
here in the early going of this game
wow this is exploding super quick now
you can't really take on e4 I think
because after the queen trade white wait
can you take on F7 because I just
realized first I thought Knight D2 but
let's just take a look at that if you
get the analysis board because this is
getting absolutely crazy get that board
back let's see you take get that board
back up Queen d8 you trade on the air
King d8 and I'm just wondering is Bishop
F7 an option or am I going absolutely
crazy here because I see you know you
pointed out Knight F6 but hello The Rook
from F1 coming on to D1 this is bad news
for black
sir sorry not Rook B1 Rook D1 Shaq black
has the block and bang E6 crushes lacks
resistance because the Rook is going to
come to the seventh Rank and that game
is over Tanya great tactical eye by you
and you saw that in three seconds he
takes D5 or D takes C5 instantly and I
think he might be flat out winning out
of the opening this is why the Italian
is all the rage it's a ridiculously
dangerous opening got it when played by
the right people Anish
anisha's gone dangerously red right now
on our screen he's calculating he's on
meditation mode I don't know what's
going on there but he's looking at all
these lines while she picks up it's
already for oh my God that is oh he
missed it he missed it he missed Bishop
F7 that would have ended the game right
then and there that was resigns after
Bishop takes Epson he's still he's still
basically winning but that's shocking to
me he plays Knight D2 instantly Bishop
F7 ended the game
oh and you know when when we were
looking at this line Knight D2 was the
first move that came to my mind as well
because it hits on e4 it hits on F7 but
the moment you spot that the King on d8
the center of the board right after a
queen trade is actually in a kill box
there with Rook D1 coming in Bishop F7 a
huge Miss but perhaps not one that's
gonna haunt The Niche because he does
still keep a big Advantage now black
can't pick up the E5 Pawn but eventually
the E4 and the F7 both these pawns are
hanging I think after Bishop E5 Bishop
F7 was a niche's idea in any case
instead Knight C6 Lana wants to get that
Knight to E5 uh but that might not be
enough white can simply grab the pawn on
e4 Knight E5 material balance is still
on
yeah I think doing things in the other
order Tanya maybe is is even stronger
Bishop takes F7 Knight takes C5 and then
drop the bishop back to D5 you're
attacking the E4 upon twice and you're
gonna win the pawn but the bigger
problem is that Black's King has no Safe
Haven with the D and E files both open
and well the e-file is going to open up
after these pawns are eliminated white
has easier access to those files with
his Rook so Rook D1 rookie one is going
to come so you know let's not overstate
the case Anish is definitely still
winning in this end game I'm a little
bit surprised but he missed Bishop takes
F7 but you're absolutely right he still
thinks ha still has things under
complete control
I'm very nicely pointed out by you there
Daniel that despite the material balance
it's actually King's safety that's a
problem for black hair and no Queens on
the board but it's like a queenless
middle game with these open e and D line
it's going to be forever until Lana
can't connect her Rooks can complete her
development and Anish will make sure
that doesn't happen he did have a huge
winning opportunity which would have
wrapped things up earlier but instead
Knight D2 is still a big Advantage we'll
see a niche what technique he shows here
but it looks like this is going to be
anisha's game let's get our bird's eye
view up so while the chess bras have an
advantage on that top board I also see
on the top right there Jordan looks like
he's created something I see an isolated
Queen's Pawn for black on D5 white has
got a bishop pair in an open position so
it feels like a long-term Advantage for
the chess bras on that top right board
as well it most certainly does early
signs are in encouraging for the chess
Bros let's take a closer look at that
iqp structure iqp stands for isolated
Queen Pawn who's got it black is the one
of the iqp white is the one with the
bishop here and most importantly Tanya
white is the one with control of the
square in front of the pawn when you
immobilize the pawn it becomes weaker
black can't play D4 so my hell is
saddled with this weak one on D5 and the
uh Jordan rather good confusing my
strong GM's here uh pretty typical it's
also staring down the barrel of the B1
H7 diagonal later on he has the idea of
Queen D3 with Bishop takes F6 and queen
H7 to follow so no question that white
is clearly better the question is as to
the extent of White's advantage
do you think my hell is in serious
trouble or do you think he might be able
to wiggle out of this
I just want to say one thing first
you're not the only one who's confusing
your a super strong Grand Masters Kelly
I'm also doing it with the Robert and
the Daniel thing going on today but
coming back to the action that we do
have uh I agree with everything that you
just said white looking good how will
black wiggle out of this hard to say now
usually the side with the isolated
Queen's Pawn tries to create an attack
tries to create activity against White's
King the more pieces that get traded off
it will benefit the side playing against
the iqb because it becomes a bigger
weakness and just simply put I don't see
how Mahal will actually make progress in
creating attacking chances sure that
Bishop on B6 eyes that F2 Pawn with that
Bishop on H4 everything is guarded
Knight E4 is not possible because watch
out that D5 Pawn is underpin so white
actually ends up winning material by
trading on e4 you can't recapture it so
it just feels as if black the usual
counter play that you get for a nice
lady Queen's Pawn for that weakness it's
a bit of a struggle Rook d8 taking
control of that D5 Pawn I won't be
surprised if my hell also falls back
with the bishop on C7 and tries to
create some play along H2 but there's
always Bishop G3 as well once again more
pieces that get traded it is better for
the side playing against the iqp and
much like uh the GM that I confuse them
with mvl Jordan Forest manages his time
excellently I always say that that is
not talked about enough players with
good time management uh aren't
recognized enough we only look at the
grishooks of the world and it's harder
to perceive when someone actually
manages their time well but I've noticed
in classical chess as well Jordan is
rarely in time pressure and here he
stands with two extra minutes on his
clock that affords him plenty of time to
figure out ways to tighten the screws I
think the screws can be tightened with
Queen D3 I thought that white would play
this move later down the line but with
the bishop exerting the pin against the
F6 Knight that raises the appeal of
Queen D3 but maybe black and play 94
anyway and hit the F2 Pawn that those
are tactics that will have to be
carefully assessed by both players but
Queen D3 uh that looks tempting maybe
dropping the bishop back to G3 and
tickling the queen maybe even trading uh
a bunch of Rooks Tanya you very
correctly pointed out that with every
piece that disappears The Pawn becomes
weaker and weaker Jordan just steps out
of the pin he says I'm tired of this
bishop pressuring my F2 Pawn what an
interesting move okay F1
I mean interesting is an understatement
for that we don't see that move very
often in chess the king's sidestepping
there is no check but just King F1
nothing happening on F2
by the way I'm just looking at some
tactical ideas here that might be a
possibility
and the more I look at it the more I'm
wondering if that's something that white
could have actually played Daniel
okay I might be crazy but is Bishop F6
and queen D5 a trick on the board that
white has and potentially was that a
trick on the board that whoa
on the previous move
no but it doesn't work right because no
it does it does oh you could Rook
Queen D5 he could have done this on the
previous move
someone's done their Puzzle Battle today
because rookie won rookie one and of
course after Rook D5 rookie it is still
made
oh my God and black has to play a move
like G6 White's Queen calmly drops back
white is up a full clean healthy Pawn
wow this can't work this can't work this
doesn't feel right because if this works
that means king F1 it was a big missed
opportunity but our evalubar seems to
say that black was doing fine so we're
missing something that was a fantastic
catch by You Queen takes D5 comes I
didn't even think about it because I
forgot that the bishop the white Bishop
is controlling the Luft Square on H7 so
it's as though it's as though Black's
Pawn is still on H7 that was indeed a
missed opportunity what a beautiful
tactic by white to eliminate crazy
Black's isolated Queen pun but the good
news Tanya I think for Jordan there's
two pieces of good news the first is
that the time situation is getting worse
and worse for Boyer the second is that
he might have another chance he's still
threatening Bishop F6 yeah Queen D5 I
mean that's still a threat and I'm just
wondering if if Jordan didn't like
something or did he miss it completely
and will Mahal see that this is
happening because it's still a threat on
the board like you're saying Bishop F6
Queen if I I'm still I'm still in a lot
of disbelief that it actually works
because Queen D5 is just insane but it
looks like the background is a huge
weakness and Mahal needs to watch out
for that by the way he's also down to
two and a half minutes on the clock oh
he just doesn't know what to do I mean
black black is so tied up here you can't
move the Knight you can't move the Jeep
on the bishop on B6 has nowhere to go
Queen C5 that doesn't do anything
because F2 is protected right wherever
you look black is tied down in the
center and on the king side and mahel
knows that he has to move he just does
not know what to do he's now done four
minutes plus on the clock Jordan should
be able to win this game
I mean you've just burnt three minutes
on the clock you're down to less than
two minutes now all pieces on the board
nothing's been traded off so there's no
ease of any pressure and Jordan that
King Efron was a smart move actually
because it just throws the ball on in
Black's court and ended up using a lot
of time now rookie won a trade so no
Bishop F6 stuff anymore so after Rook
takes E1 although after Rook takes E1
Bishop F6 is still a threat you're
pointing out D4 a very thematic way for
black to get rid of the iqp
I I think the hell has to try to squeeze
this Pawn through he has to reach some
clarity in this position or he's going
to lose on time get some pieces off the
board so whether it works or not I think
he just has to throw that pawn down to
D4 and Trust in the activity of his
pieces Also let's not forget that the H2
Pawn could be hanging in certain lines
right if White's Knight leaves the F3
Square that's a very easy thing to
blunder uh but with six minutes on the
clock again I think that block situation
is very likely to decide this game even
more uh than the evaluation which is I
think still in White's favor
and now I'm completely obsessed with
this idea of the sacrifice on D5 so just
a reminder it still exists Bishop F6
Queen F6 and then you go Rook D5 with
the queen jumping on to eat it yes
Daniel I can't get my head around it or
enough of it so D4 also does take care
of that and so easy to miss that little
move King F1 actually left the H2 Pawn
just a little bit tender
yeah Queenie Queen takes E1 that was a
very smart recapture 48 seconds
six seconds now what is he doing we're
my hell Boyer he just he's Frozen I mean
his position is bad and and he's just
trying to be a perfect he's trying to
find the perfect movement now oh my God
the queen moves back to D2 and again
your favorite idea this time without the
sacrifice Bishop F6 and queen T5 is
still very much a threat
but now you could just go rook d8 and
defend it because there's he goes
Knight G5 Queen takes H2 is what he's
relying on but Jordan's gonna calmly
drop his Bishop back and Knight takes G5
is going to become a permanent threat
I will take my hat off
I don't do 30 seconds are very nicely
pointed out by you that if the King was
on G1 Knight G5 would be crushing the
queen jumps onto G5 pick up picks up
that Knight on F6 but now with the King
on F1 that wasn't possible the bishop
falls back the queen doubles up on the E
file now rookie one is a possibility but
what Mahal wants is to jump with his
Knight to E4
yeah Knight E4 can be very dangerous
though you have to reckon with Queen
takes D5 so maybe Rook E8 to d8 first uh
followed by 94 maybe in some situations
even G4 so you can see the eval bar is
actually showing equality uh so you know
it's it blacks pieces are active my hell
has kept his D5 Fawn alive he's doing
okay on the board but I'm a broken
record Tanya but again the clock
situation is going to do him in
eventually
Bishop B3 Daniel I was talking about if
white actually played rookie one then 94
was an opportunity but which is why he
decided not to and you're pointing out
that D5 weakness that's what stops black
from jumping in with the Knight so white
they're piling on and mile doesn't care
he goes 95 anyway what is happening in
this game or can you you couldn't have
taken it because black would have taken
the bishop and dropped the queen into E2
so King F1 actually turned out to be a
very problematic room for Jordan but six
seconds and we're still in the middle
game three seconds three he needs to
make a move play something he takes the
bishop that was the mistake and he's
going to lose Tanya he's going to lose
the D5 pawn and the game is going to
follow
and that's it he's playing on a second
here literally and my hell there you can
see the frustration in him 95 he's
played he does lose the D5 Pawn but
there is these opposite color Bishops
but it doesn't matter because Black's
King is the one under Fire so white can
even go for Knight E5 and then just
simply pick up the bishop D5 upon and
then go Queen G6 ideas it looks like
Black's position is falling apart here
we'll keep a close eye on this game but
things kind of have stabilized from
Jordan's perspective he'll be up upon I
think my hell will try to hold on as
long as he can but uh looks like a full
point in the bag for Mr van forest in
the meantime Tanya couple of
developments in the other games Anish is
still winning uh some technique is still
required on his board but he's now up a
pawn he should be able to convert mvl
looks to have a much better end game
against Jennifer you
is locked in a fascinating battle
against Rodrigo and by the way Jordan
has officially won his game
wow amazing stuff that great play but it
was all on the clock Jordan takes the
first point for the Canada chess bras
and it will come down to Chris jerk and
Maxine bashiella Graf can they save
round two for the blitz team where do
you want to jump to let's get a quick
update on the Chris checkboard I think
we've got to do a deep dive into that
one Daniel he is chasing Black's queen
queen played to the center of the board
I have a spot he can win on the spot
with Knight G4 and Knight F6 that wins
The Rook on E8 if Grisha plays Knight G4
he's taking his time here which is a
little bit concerning because never mind
concerning grishook get out of here says
Sasha E3 just F takes E3 Tanya and that
doesn't change anything Knight F6 is
going to end it that is a big win for
the blitz Grisha doing his job he'll
have two out of two in the first two
rounds
Sean realizes it it is game over that is
it this is game over dietary Knight F6
you pick up that Rook on it you can also
pick up that night on C6 give a check on
D4 win a couple of Pawns Queen D4 coming
in you can't fall back with the King win
the queen and if King 87 anywhere Rook
did and you win the king with Queen a
chain that is game over on the spot
Chris Chuck takes the point and levels
the score for Blitz
amazing that was phenomenal I looked
over that game earlier Grisha played
incredibly from start to finish a lot
smoother than his last game with
Jennifer you speaking of Jennifer you
she is trying to hold on against MPL but
again the clock situation is doing her
in with 10 seconds she's down upon I
think we should go to the Anish game
because that has reached a Time scramble
the bad news for Katarina she's down 8
566 Pawns
yeah that's that's close enough I mean
look at that King side it is absolutely
busted there these wonderful
it doesn't even exist for black you're
absolutely right 94 check given and
you're pointing out well first breaks
with C4 uh Bishop F5 and you can attack
you take on B5 you're pointing at after
King B5 you've got to check on B7 you
can also go Rook G7 and hit that Knight
on uh G4 simply defends instead the
Knight on e4 with Rook to E7 instead
about 9 000 bonds up that's a mate
threat yeah now nine thousand and one
Pawn Knight C3 was a very clinical move
by any issue there was it's 300 rookie
five it's three and rookie five and you
win the bishop as well exactly and take
the bishop
that's it that's it Knight A4 I mean
Katarina has a pass Pawn but that's all
she has literally it has nieces I think
and you should just go Knight A4 check
and Rook E7 to E4 oh Rook E3 is clinical
and white wins the pawn race
wow and we also uh and this means that
Anish takes this one so it comes down to
the maxim vashir lagrav game which I
think just got over as well with Maxim
winning that game let's bring up our
bird's eye view for Just a moment
because this one Anish takes it home
what a start it's been for a niche in
his debut two out of two so far so he's
uh playing absolutely inform and we see
that bottom right board it all comes
down to that one for Maxine washer
what's going on there and he's won
already the game is one and Jennifer
flagging in the final position but it
doesn't matter because the two Rooks
doubled on the seventh rank are going to
Massacre the black skiing and the pot on
G7 is going to be captured so mvl we
didn't look at that game too closely
tiny but it was a pretty smooth effort
from start to finish the Queens got
traded early Jennifer was struggling in
an end game an mvl converted to the full
point that means that means that there
are no upsets in round two the score is
two to two that means the Canada chess
us are clinging clinging to that one
point lead Tanya
the blitz that's really good that's
yes and I think that makes a lot of
sense by the chess bras do not do
anything super drastic they took the
chances on the boards that they could
unfortunately for them Blitz with that
top two super GMS of uh Maxine Basha
lagrav and Alexander grishek they were
able to level the damage that Anish and
Jordan created on the top two boats for
the chess bras and with that a one point
lead so still very much in Striking
Distance there for the Canada chest
press they just need that one turnaround
match what what a fight this is turning
out to be uh Daniel incredible fight and
we are set for two epic final rounds
remember that elimination is on the line
you win or go home we know that from
Alexander grishock we know that because
both of these teams have lost two games
so we will have round three for you
after a break but first we wanted to
remind you to join the official
chess.com Discord now over 50k members
strong the server has tons of exciting
features including weekly Arenas with
the chance to win Diamond memberships
and ask me any things with streamers and
Masters do not miss out connect your
chess.com account to your Discord
account to gain access to it all we're
having fun over there so join us at
go.chess.com Discord that's go.chess.com
Discord or use x Glam Discord in chat
for more information well we will have
more information Tanya in this match
won't me I can't wait for the final two
rounds
absolutely Daniel definitely definitely
us on discard but
so definitely not as far
on three action coming up between these
two big heavyweight favorites of the
protest League unfortunately it will be
the end of the road for one of them as
we enter round three between the Canada
chess bras and the blitz right after
this break
foreign
[Music]
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need
a.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess
how to play duck chess the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck okay kind of
square to place the dog
to prevent moves of opponent not
yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemates but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dark chest
there's some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chess That's so exciting
oh no no no no no no no slip no no no no
no no
a duck chess champion give me those
points baby
foreign
so far in his debut at the protest
League he starts with a two out of two
performance despite having a one minute
deficit on the clock as he was the last
minute replacement for the Canada chess
bras for Magnus Carlson and that was the
penalty but it is not showing in his
form or his chest as he has a hundred
percent score so far but he's up for a
big match his toughest challenge so far
today in this matchup against the blitz
as Anish giri takes on Maxime vashir
lagrav this is The Clash of the Titans
uh Daniel Maxime as well with the two
bar two score wow what do you expect out
of this one
well but look at the rapid head-to-head
mvl he holds a very small lead it's as
tight as it gets Tanya these two are so
evenly matched and they have similar
Styles they both Bank on their
incredible opening preparation they're
Universal Players but maybe that one
both love the night or both love you
know knowing 35 moves of Fury but that
one minute deficit Tanya I think it
might make its presence felt in this
matchup because MBL is fast already you
do not want to fall behind before move
one is made
yeah I agree with you I think the clock
is going to be a super important factor
in this one and that one minute deficit
might finally tell Maxime is just so
quick and so fast so it's going to be
important for a niche to Blitz out those
opening moves now we've been talking
about these two players who've been
leading from the front with a full score
let's take a look at the overall scores
for these two teams in this elimination
match only one of them will go through
to the playoffs the other will be
eliminated and we see that Alexander
grishook also having a great start today
he's on 100 score he's been a bit shaky
in the protest league so far but that is
not today and a Katrina Alano with a
draw let's also take a look at the third
round matchups wow Daniel look at that
the top board fight Anish versus
a super GM tournament it really is this
is probably the most evenly matched
round that we have had so far Tanya it's
impossible to say how this is going to
go yes the blitz currently hold a one
point lead and they could even decide
this match and make the playoffs in this
round all they'd have to do is score
four out of four so we're likely to get
to have a fourth round let's see if the
chess bras will be able to erase that
one point deficit and turn this around
this is going to be an incredibly
exciting round I feel like we're gonna
struggle Tanya we're gonna have a good
problem we're not gonna know which game
to turn to because all of them are
likely to be so fascinating here's Mr
Geary
there's Mr Gary and there is Mr Maxine
Bossier both these players ready to go
what a fight this is going to be I'm
pretty I was gonna say one E4 he beat me
to it no Sicilian there Anish going for
a solid E5 what what do you think oh my
God it's gonna be a Berlin it is going
to be a Berlin
I'm I know I know that I know that face
exactly what you're feeling right now
but of course let's be real I think it's
a meme at this point Tanya but in all
seriousness the rookie won Berlin is a
serious winning attempt and bl isn't
just trying to make uh a draw all of
these top players have analyzed this
rookie one Berlin to exhaustion and
rookie two that is all the rage I'm not
gonna pretend that I understand Tanya
what this move is all about and why uh
players don't seem to go rookie one
anymore I feel like it might have I feel
like The Rook actually drops down to E1
on the next move I've seen B6 rookie one
played a couple of times I mean these
are crazy computer sub uh subtleties and
black immediately tries to exploit the
fact that the bishop is no longer making
contact with the C4 Square Niche wants
to push D5 through and create symmetry
in the center
absolutely and as you I'm just happy
that we don't have that Queen D4 Queen
E4 draws anymore in this and at least we
get a game on this one but it's gonna be
it's gonna be a slow development and
it's gonna be a positional fight none of
that night off fireworks that deep in my
heart I was hoping and expecting but
it's still going to be a battle we see
B3 the Knight has been pushed at and
expecting white to develop fan chatter
the bishop on B2 and also defend uh that
D4 Pawn eventually white can March up
the board with that c Pawn indeed and
Tanya just a quick note on Match
strategy I think some people might be
looking at this and saying well why is
Anish not playing for when uh you know
why is he playing as though he's happy
with the draw and that's because he is
happy with the draw you're only one team
one point behind that's not a reason for
everybody to take wild amounts of risks
and Anisha is playing realistic chess
yes he is uh hoping he's pinning his
hopes on the teammates that have the
white pieces but that that's exactly
what you and I feel like that element of
match strategy is really interesting so
Anisha is going to play solid chess but
he's going to pounce on his
opportunities if he can get them and
guess what the clock has already
equalized so a very encouraging sign in
the early going for a niche
yeah I think that makes a lot of sense
and Anisha is playing with the black
piece is really the pressure is on
Maxime here to create chances to try to
get that win in if not Anisha is happy
we're just getting an equal position and
maybe even a peaceful result but Maxim
needs to show how he wants to keep the
game going speaking of keeping the game
going take a look at what is happening
on the other boards we've got to pull up
our bird's eye view I know that
expression you notice that the moment I
did we got an H5 on the board in that
top right it is Jordan taking on
Alexander grishek another Super GM
matchup and Daniel we've got her head
straight into that one
this might actually be a novelty now
it's not as outlandish Tanya as this
move would have been considered five or
six years ago and there's a reason for
that the reason is that with colors
reversed this move H4 is now standard
fair if we could go back to the very
start I don't know if I can even modify
the first move yes I can after D4 Knight
F6 C4 G6 a lot of top Grand Masters are
now playing the move H4 I'm a king's
Indian player Tanya I can tell you that
H4 is one of the best ways for white to
fight for the advantage and if black fan
Catos then and only then this white
start developing their pieces with the
idea of course of pushing H5 so Jordan
is doing the same thing he's just doing
it with colors reversed which is rather
bizarre because he's lacking that one
tempo and you kind of need that tempo
for developing your pieces but why do
you need to develop your pieces tiny
apparently I'm out of touch with what
the cool kids do these days
I mean this is
just install you were talking about
reverse Theory now we are into some sort
of a Banco territory there where white
is the one who sacrificed the pawn is
looking for player on the open files
going to go Castle but that H5 Pawn what
is that even doing there uh it does want
to March forward to H4 if white rushes
with castling this position is an
absolute mess and look at gristook's
time he's already taken about three
minutes so he's not super familiar he's
trying to understand the reverse color
ideas how can he make it work with the
white pieces but this is a dangerous
dangerous territory for white it
absolutely is and you called it a very
committal decision by Sasha to sacrifice
the pawn I think right now there's a
couple of decisions that he has to make
the first is on the king side do you
play H4 do you maybe play H3 in order to
meet H4 which or do you ignore the
situation on the king side and focus
instead on the queen side that's what
Sasha has decided to do he's recaptured
the pawn on A3 in the benko you often
see the queen coming out to B3 he'll
probably develop his Knight to D2 I mean
there are no other squares and he will
try to operate on the queen side put
pressure on the B7 Pawn we are in for a
slugfest in this game
but a really fun one now we know about
Jordan he is all for the creative
opening ideas he was part of magnus's
world championship team and in fact
Magnus mentioned it that it's Jordan who
comes up with the most fun entertaining
creative opening ideas so that's what
we're seeing him play out here with that
move H5 this is going to develop why it
has sacrificed on upon on the queen side
to open up the lines the A-line and the
B-Line where eventually you will find
counter play right now it's about
development we'll see how this develops
but the other games are already hot on
action let's bring up our bird's eye
view Daniel so much has happened
including on our top left board with
Anish we see upon Advance on the
kingside H3 G4 black has managed to
plant the queen on e4 everything looks
pretty balanced in that one the Rooks
have been traded off but still an
interesting position on the king side
meanwhile on the bottom right we see
that and not a symmetrical Pawn
structure white sky a majority on the
king side Black's got it on the queen
side with Katrina Lano eyeing that C4
Square for the night it looks like black
should be happy with that position
because White's Bishop on C1 The Rook on
A1 feels like it's still a little
lacking in Harmony and development
yeah this is a very interesting
unbalanced grunefeld structure so let's
take a bit of a closer look and watch as
this game heads toward what whiz what
will be a very interesting middle game
Katarina lagno is a very combative
player with both colors the grunfeld is
one of the best openings to guarantee
winning chances and I think that's
exactly what she has here the kind of
position that you want if you're the
side that tries to play for a win with
black so what does the imbalance consist
of it's not a peace and balance because
both sides have the same minor pieces on
the board it's a structural imbalance
Tanya where black has the three on two
on the queen side and white has the sort
of four on three on the king side I
think Robert Hess would have been proud
of me for that comment he likes to cut
the board in half I would say that black
is the one with a definite superiority
on the queen side there's A4 and A3 on
the docket black could also play the
move C7 C6 in order to blunt and
diminish uh the control of white slide
Squad Bishop but Jennifer it was her
move and she takes a fundamentally
different approach from what I expected
she pushes E4 opening up her dark squid
bishop and maybe preparing a little
expansion of her own with F2 F4
wow Bishop E6 and that takes control of
the C4 Square now with the bishop
jumping onto C4 Knight jumping onto C4
A4 ideas I think it's time for white to
either go for F4 or I was gonna say
trade off some pieces ease off the
pressure with Knight to D5 I see our
eval bar doesn't like it but it just
feels like such a human approach in this
position to neutralize uh Black's
activity with the pieces now after
Knight D5 you definitely don't want to
give up your light squared Bishop I'm
guessing because why give up the bishop
pair Advantage so Knight D5 is the move
that comes to mind and you trade on D5
and plant that Bishop on F5 and it just
looks like if you compare the activity
of the pieces the development that just
has that nagging Edge in the position
yeah I definitely think that after
Knight takes and Bishop F5 black I mean
simply Black's Bishops are much more
active than their counterparts White's
Bishop is still going to be biting on uh
her own Pawn on D5 the bishop on C1 is
still on its initial square and it's
saddled uh with the protection of the B2
Pawn so I think Knight D5 I understand
why Jennifer played if she wanted to
relieve some of the pressure on her
position but I think this move has had
the opposite effect Katarina correctly
takes on D5 with the Knight she's going
to play Bishop F5 I think she's gonna
have a clear Advantage out of the
opening and things could get even worse
for Jennifer if wax Queen dives into B4
White's Queen could get caught in the
crossfire this is getting really nasty
Tanya
and the first move that came to my mind
with white was to develop with Bishop E3
and then I suddenly realized Daniel
white needs to be super careful there
are tactics as well apart from these
strategic advantages that you're talking
about Bishop G3 and suddenly that Bishop
on E3 is hanging you end up losing a
pawn here so that's definitely not a
developing move that you want to make
watch out for these ideas
that's a great catch Bishop E3 is
exactly the move you want to play it's
the only way to plug the e-file if you
can't play it well what the heck do you
do then do you play a move like Bishop
to H6 well that walks right into the
move that I pointed out which is even
stronger now B2 is hanging Bishop takes
G3 is still a threat I don't want to
overstate the case here but it feels
like if Jennifer doesn't play with
filigree Precision she might end up
being lost in just a couple of moves
it's been a frustrating run thus far for
Jennifer you she's got to take some
inspiration with how close she came in
round one but things seem to be going in
the wrong direction or the Harvard
student
Lana just made this one look at least so
far quite effortless you know making
natural developing moves and ending up
with a slightly better position with the
black pieces putting the pressure on the
white usually it's supposed to be the
other way around but this is going to be
a tough defensive task ahead of Jennifer
like we've been talking there is no
material imbalance she reaches out for
her mouth she's about to make a move she
also has to make sure she doesn't burn
the clock too much because the pressure
is just starting the critical moves are
just coming right now and it's hard to
develop pieces while Jennifer takes
these decisions let's zoom out for a
moment because I see certain other
decisions have to be made on the board
let's bring up our bird's eye view and
Daniel what on Earth is happening on
that bottom left board there's a knight
on C6 that's hanging there's a knight on
B3 that's hanging I see a trade has
happened and black is going to recapture
oh my God that looks absolutely
that looks like a mess right now it
looks chaotic and that means what's
stressful for the players is perfect for
the commentators that's the rule so
let's take a deeper dive and try to
figure out which Knight black is going
to take because you can absolutely take
either one of them the position might
stabilize in a couple of moves but it
could also devolve into complete and
utter chaos I think Boyer has decided on
the first approach and I think he has a
stable Advantage now he's recaptured the
night on C6 and you might say well this
looks like a lifeless position it most
certainly isn't Tanya black is the more
Mobile on mass he can play C5 he can put
a rook on E8 and white is also uh has
the responsibility of protecting the B2
Pawn so the queen is relatively tied
down and its Mobility is greatly limited
by that
and we see that happen you were talking
about a mobile Central Center Pond there
and we see C5 hitting that night the
Knight jumps to F5 you gotta watch a
little bit uh for these tricks that
exist with the Knight coming to E7 with
a check attacking D5 white is only
hoping that that Rook from A1 was more
centralized but he's one move behind the
queen was attacked steps onto C2 hits
that pawn on A4 why does watch out do
not defend that pawn with Queen B5
tactics everywhere Queen B5 could end up
with Knight D6 coming in and that would
be bad news by the way some breaking
news meanwhile the top board Anish giri
Maxim as we had predicted in the Berlin
has indeed ended peacefully big surprise
Tanya there I know we've never seen this
before hey Berlin absolute shocker ends
in a try that game never really got off
the ground the final position there uh
is somewhat unbalanced but at the end of
the day there was no Advantage for
either side so I think a good result for
Anish who does what he set out to do he
holds the position with the black pieces
but that means his teammates who have
white including genre they have to
deliver and as we go back to the limo
Boyer game it doesn't feel like white is
really contending for victory here
yeah I mean it looks like Black's the
one who's got so much space H4 coming in
where is your knight you have to just
move further back with the Knight I like
that move H5 after Queen A4 the B2 Pawn
is hanging as well so no time to capture
that Rook D1 played instead uh H4 is an
option here as well as
well now you could also
improve the position of your queen queen
B5 Rook B8 so many ideas meanwhile white
just struggling to find Targets to put
pressure on if anyone's trying for a win
here it's got to be my hell but Boyers
shouldn't overpress right he should see
the bigger picture listen the blitz have
a one point lead so I think you should
maintain an abundance of caution but
Sean he really needs a turnaround in
this game
well we have a very special guest to
offer his opinion on the way that the
match is going Grandmaster Eric Hansen
the OG chess bra joins us in the studio
Eric welcome to the show hey Daniel hey
Tanya thanks for having me well we
appreciate it this is uh this is like
this is round three which is
traditionally usually one of our worst
rounds so I'm I'm pretty nervous at this
very moment I think I think Tanya was
commentating maybe both of you guys were
when India swept us or zero
um
always always a bit nervous here
it felt like they belong in the playoffs
and here they are fighting an
elimination match and fighting an
elimination match in the final week the
last team you want to face is the one
against Christchurch against Maxime what
are the nerves like what are you feeling
right now about the match
yeah so I mean they're really strong
team and then the other tough part is
grishook played for us for a couple of
seasons and I was hoping to get him back
but him and his wife are
are playing for the uh for the French
team now so
um helps them and does doesn't help us
so much he was really good for us
um but this league is super strong so
it's it sucks to have such a tough
pairing but almost every team that we've
played has had a chance uh to beat us
and part of that is just the way our
roster has been constructed we've just
had very uh inconsistent play Boards
three and four partly because of me the
entire season
and we just haven't really had the
situations where everybody had a good
day
um you know you just need that day where
the board three and four over perform a
little bit or even play at their level
at their expected and we've just had a
bit of a collapse on our bottom boards
the whole whole season
um and I mean
so it's it's a bit of an uphill battle
it's been tough scheduling
um it's been a bit chaotic and even
finding players but
um you know it's clear it's clear one of
the um
uh he's the success is
uh
uh the woman's board or sometimes there
might be more than one woman playing but
the rating allowance
that allows you to feel the higher rated
women and have encounters 23.50 we have
strong Grand Masters like last notice
this week who is you know would be a
just a good board three anyways but she
counts as 23.50 which gives so much
flexibility to the roster
um so it's uh bit of an uphill battle I
feel like
you know Jennifer has been playing well
this year but in time trouble and why
not she just hasn't gotten the results
the position the play has been fine but
hasn't been able to close out games and
and that's been the story for a few of
our players a few of our boards the
entire year and if you're if you're
struggling on two out of four boards
which we have been
it's It's just tough to expect
um
to to be some of these really really
balanced strong teams that's probably
spoke for too long there but those would
be my thoughts for a while sorry not at
all
it makes I mean everything that you've
just said we've been discussing that but
Christian has just taken a Pawn on age
seven what is that about let's just back
up Eric what happened there
oh my God
yeah your boy is struggling here
shook has two minutes on the clock and
he has a thicker beard than usual so a
bit more intimidating I don't like what
I'm seeing right now I
yeah
yeah Jordan he has to keep things as
confusing as possible here that's what
he's trying to do Rook a to B8 Grisha
gives up the queen for two pieces but
he's I think he's completely winning
after a move like there might be further
tactics here but even if he drops his
Bishop back he's threatening Knight G5
this is looking really really Grim for
you and Eric just really quickly as we
watch this game unfold you've been
facing adversity even before the match
began of course Magnus Carlson uh was
unable to join today could you talk a
little bit about how you handled that
situation uh as as the manager
yeah so I mean Magnus played a lot more
than I expected this year so I mean when
he mentioned like it was under the
weather
you know he's already played Four
matches for us and done a great job so I
I was I mean one one thing that people
keep asking online and writing is like
oh why isn't a niche playing or why
aren't certain players playing and it's
usually because of availability it's not
that oh I'm trying to avoid you know
putting in top 10 players and and Anish
has been playing tournaments and and
busy with things so he kind of came in
as an emergency he wasn't originally
able to play
um but um because he was I mean at least
we you know Anish is a really good
replacement but it's just been tough
scheduling uh things around and there's
different time zones and factors but uh
yeah
um
maintenance just wasn't feeling uh so
well and he really played you know
playing every week was was amazing for
us and so uh I was just like don't Don't
Force It you're not feeling well you
know let's see what we can do and then
Anish was fortunately able to to play
this week and make his debut
um and he's doing well so far I mean it
really comes down to yeah the bottom two
boards because Jordan he played well
last week today
I mean he's gonna give the top two guys
mvl and green shook a fight but uh I'm
not expecting him to like beat both of
them or something it's just being
competitive in the top two boards and
and getting some points from boards
three and four so
um yeah
that last move might have been a serious
and accurate specific so still chances
here for Jordan But Eric we really
appreciate all of that Insight we'll let
you watch the games in peace there's
still plenty of Chess left to be played
so I think we're gonna see a close match
and uh we wish the best of luck to your
chest press you've done as good of a job
as uh anybody could uh possibly ask for
so let's see what happens I hope so but
lots of lots of things to fix but thanks
for having me
of course good luck thank you so much
Eric for joining us and good luck uh and
I think the chess bras are going to need
a bit of luck here today Daniel as we
see but it does feel as if grishek has
made has made life a little easier for
Jordan from a completely winning
position now there's work to be done
yeah I think he oversimplified a little
bit Tanya he's given that black queen a
ton of activity now obviously only black
only black is playing for the win here
oh sorry only white is playing for the
win here White's got two actually you
know that might have been sort of a a
slip there but Jordan is advancing his
pawns if he goes F4 Tanya how easy is it
to blunder a rook to a fork in a
position like this 10 seconds now for
Alexander grishook he needs to try to
play with an abundance of caution the
last thing you want uh is to lose an
entire point in this game he fixes his
Rook on a defended Square that's an
excellent move now I still think that
Sasha has great winning chances here
and you know what that's why I smile
because even though you had that black
might be the only one I don't even think
it was a slip I think there are a lot of
tricks that exist especially given
gracechuk's time situation that Bonn on
F5 could advance to F3 the Rooks are not
coordinated enough just yet to put
attack on that G6 weakness he is
targeting the E5 pawn and uh Daniel look
at that the eval bar dips lower and
lower for question in this position he
brings the king into the attack but he
gives up the E5 Pawn there might have I
think Grisha should have taken one of
the Rook though I think Grisha took with
the wrong Rook he's let Jordan capture
on D3 and now the pawn on C4 has lost
its key supporter he advances it to C5
but Jordan should have enough counter
play a king to make the dragon and again
another another
he's trying to get his Queen to F3 I
think and maybe push F4 Tanya but this
is going to be cool oh King H3 is
amazing queen of three King H3 I mean do
not forget that king after Queen F3
you've got to start hitting that Queen
on E3 uh but then if you move the Rook
from the first Frank there's a check on
D1 if you move the Rook from the fifth
rank the queen can return to D5 this is
not going to be easy Jordan there with
40 seconds taking his time he needs to
find the right Square for the queen
queen F3 F4 ideas Queen F3 King H3 ideas
and now 30 seconds Tanya and two of the
other games have gone absolutely Haywire
as well we have to go to the bird's eye
view as Queen F3 has been played look at
the bottom left with the hell Boyer
conducting we might be seeing a
repetition by the way Daniel I'm sorry I
didn't drop but I think but he says no
Sasha says no repetition there yeah
Sasha's playing as long as he avoids
King H3 I don't think he's really
risking as long as his internet holds up
he just played King H2 but also look at
Jennifer you Katarina lagno she
sacrificed a piece why does an extra
Bishop on C1 and Katarina doesn't have
the kind of attack that she was hoping
to get Jennifer you has stabilized and
that is a three result game as well
Tanya
that is an incredible position White's
King looks a little shaky there but
black has only a pawn for a bishop with
the problem in rights position on that
bottom right is and it's been a big
blunder what happened H5 not the
accurate move players playing on seconds
this is what happens
Rook G1 is a huge threat oh and
Katarina's gonna win Jennifer just
doesn't have any time she had a winning
move there two moves to go let's go to
that game because Katarina Wagner is
about to deliver a crucial Victory you
can't take because Queenie foreign
and that's it that is game over Daniel
she picks up the Rook loses the pawn but
it's not enough and you can't even just
simply take the pawn on H5 wow and she
does it what a heartbreaking sequence of
events for Jennifer You Who Came Back in
this game and she's still playing she's
still fighting the problem is she's
dropping all of her pawns now black has
two extra pawns on top of her Queen
Katarina has plenty of space on the king
side there are no tactics she could even
give up the H5 pawn and play a move like
Queen B3 as long as she doesn't let
white set up a fortress this is game
over I would go Queen takes B2 and run
that c Pawn down the board
she can pick up the pawn and beat her
she can defend that pawn on H5 she
decides to go for your idea because the
king is absolutely safe you can even go
King G6 Rook G5 and King F6 because
Bishop E5 runs into a lost King Pawn end
game oh my God if Jennifer you had
completed the Swindle and won this game
conceivably the chess Bros could have
even won the round because grishook has
run his game he was unable to convert
that position an amazing save from a
dead lost position for Jordan benforest
and guess what Jennifer you is still
trying she's got her Rook on a defended
Square Katarina logo still has some work
to do but she threatens Checkmate on H1
Jennifer's still fighting but here comes
the C Pawn the pawn is coming up the
board now with C3 C2 and with mating
threats on H1 this is going to be tough
to save and she flags and this is what
Eric mentioned that with last time on
the clock Jennifer has been having a
hard time and we see that narrative
being played at Katrina Alano takes a
big point for Blitz while while
Christian did not manage to win his game
we've still got action on we do and that
was an accident I flipped on that last
game Mahal Boyer has pulled out a crazy
win I think he's completely winning oh
my goodness Sean rodrigue lamo Tanya he
came oh so close to drawing this Rook
end game but with his last seconds he
was unable to find a critical drawing
move now he sets two pawns down and I
think he has no chances here you can see
the consternation the frustration as
Sean rodrigue limo will pass the chest
for us a crucial point
wow and and you're absolutely right this
is a
book on end game because White's King is
stuck to defend the C3 Pawn there's no
King D2 and black simply marches slowly
but steadily with his own King to assist
the F Pawn now rookie one check is a big
threat you can keep giving checks but
now when you come to F7 the pawn Queen's
Rook F3 on the board and that is it Sean
goes down Mahal wins a big point and a
big match win a 3-1 win to the Blitz
Daniel the chest bras are staring at
elimination right now they are indeed
Eric Hansen you could hear it in his
voice he cannot be happy with the way
that this match is going the one bit of
Silver Lining is that they're still in
the match they barely have any cushion
though one single point is what stands
between the blitz Alexander grishock's
team and playoffs all they need is one
win all they need is two draws they
could even lose the final round three to
one and still overall match so the
Canada chess bras need a complete sweep
they need three and a half Tanya and
that only makes the tie bricks
wow so you're saying that the child the
kind of Chess bras need to win three and
a half half to score it to get into a
tie break and they're playing against
gristook they're playing against Maxima
Sherlock Katrina Lano I mean where are
they gonna get those points Daniel this
is a heartbreaking situation for the
chess bras and it just goes on to show
that the format of the protest League
really focuses on a balanced team you
could have the world champion at the top
you could have Anish giri scoring
heavily on first board but you need a
balance team you need to pick up points
on each and every board and those are
the teams that go over the Finish Line
in the long race yeah I mean the chess
bras they have Magnus Carl so that makes
them a fair default he was unable to
play today his shoes have been filled
very ably by Anish Gary but his
teammates just haven't come along for
the ride the chess Bros are staring down
the barrel of elimination they will need
a complete and utter miracle in the
final round but how many miracles have
we already seen in the PCL Tanya so
don't count them out just yet
totally possible we've seen three and a
half house we've seen 4-0 turnarounds
and that's exactly what the chess bras
need they need a win and a massive win
going into round four or otherwise it is
goodbye to the Canada chess Bros
do not go anywhere as we are about to
kick off our final round of the chess
Pro versus Blitz matchup Daniel and I
will be right back
my name is Ethan Curry
you know we all have nicknames
um Chicago is naturally where I'm born
and raised so that's how I got the name
I guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently they
don't make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
we're trying to do is to let them know
hey we playing down here in Houston
Texas
if you come down here help step in trust
me we're going to beat you
you better bring your game
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
because it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
a dominating performance today so far by
the Alexander grishek Maxime washer
lagrove LED Blitz team here at the
protest league elimination match and
we're going into round four now the
chess bras what they need to do is they
need to have a clean sweep winning a 3-1
margin will not be enough Daniel they
need to score at least three and a half
points which will force a tie break 4-0
means it goes over to the chest bras but
it's hard to imagine that happening with
the day we've had but here's a little
fun fact for all of us we're slightly
superstitious I might give a little hope
to the chess Bros the blitz team I don't
know how they came up with this but the
name that they chose in fact in the
protest league so far all the decisive
results the wins have been in tie breaks
they are yet to close a match in the
rapid play and we see that against mgd1
as well as the Capybaras they took it
through the playoffs to the tie breaks
and won the blitz potion So Daniel quite
an interesting uh thing that they
actually named their team Blitz and took
it to the blitz to close the matches
that's great that's a fascinating step
that's a pretty ominous that's a pretty
ominous set for the blitz as you said
both of their wins they came in the
blitz playoffs their only loss uh in the
blitz playoffs came against the Croatia
Bulldogs imagine which mvl really really
struggled but from that perspective this
match could not be more different
because both top boards for the blitz
MBL and Alexander grishok are over
fulfilling expectations as we look at
the individual scores Tanya they both
pulled an incredible score of Two and a
Half out of three they haven't even come
close to losing a single one of their
games and don't discount Katarina and my
Hellboy who have done what they needed
to do 50 very respectable for like oh my
hell Boyer striking with a very clutch
win against Rodrigo in the previous
round
indeed each and every player has shown
up for the team in the Blitz and that's
what's been the deciding factor for them
this is something that we've seen the
chess brought struggle week after week
while being top-heavy while having big
hitters on board one it's been a
lukewarm performance by the other three
boards extremely shaky today with Anish
they're scoring a big two and a half but
we see down at the bottom there hasn't
been much contribution but we're going
in to the most evenly matched round of
the protest League this is the final
round where the top board plays against
the top board so we've got another hot
match up here Daniel Anish taking on
Alexander gristook I don't know how this
will land but I will tell you how this
will start no berlins here
are the points going to come from for
the Canada chess bras I mean the blitz
have no weaknesses on any of the boards
boards three and four are in Superior
form to their opposition so rodrigue
Limon Jennifer you are gonna have to
figure out some way Tanya some way to
put the previous three games behind them
Jennifer you she came very close to
scoring a first round upset against
Alexander grishok so that's what we
always keep learning in the PCL is that
these matches really could go either way
and they're often decided by concrete
details and by the form that the players
are in rather than their relative
strengths which is usually pretty equal
here we go
absolutely I think you've hit the nail
on the head that it is about the form on
that particular day and not about the
numbers and the ratings that we see we
see that over and over again being
played out in the protest League
definitely not a Berlin in this one
starts with the Queen spawn opening and
a queen's camper declined so far what
are we gonna see are we gonna see a
ragus in or are we going to see a
Catalan on the board a Catalan with
Chinese giri has played Aiden I think he
avoids one because he wants to avoid
forcing lines he wants to get some sort
of middle game that is going to
guarantee a long game of course he's
currently a minute down because of the
penalty that he has incurred uh due to
the last second replacement for those
just joining Magnus Carlson was slated
to play for the chest press but was
unable to make it he is under the
weather so we wish the world champion a
quick recovery but ironically Tanya it
hasn't been Anish giri who's been the
reason for the big deficit the chess
Bros find themselves facing it's been
his teammates Geary has done his job
that might as well say Magnus Carlson
he's done great and I think he's chosen
very wisely in uh this game as well
absolutely big shoes to fill replacing
magnets but Anish giri so far has been
vinish giri in this match but it's not
been enough as you're pointing out now
this position that we've got it's again
fireworks already where white has
sacrificed the pawn but it's often for
peace play and activity we see that
white with with control over the dark
squares actually controls the queen side
pawns from advancing further Knight E5
ideas with the bishop making sure black
doesn't get a C5 break-in A4 coming in
at the right moment black will put a
Pawn on A6 to keep that B5 Pawn solid at
the right time white can look at
expanding in the center with E4 so
definitely a massive a messy middle game
is going to ansu and that's exactly what
Anish giri is looking for as the chess
bras need to score three and a half to
keep the match going yeah this is really
all that you can ask for uh when you're
in a niche Gary's position I still see a
bunch of games in the database but it
looks like Alexander grishok is out of
theory he's already spent a minute in
this position he's trying to decide uh
where to develop the dark squared Bishop
you can go Bishop E7 you can go Bishop
D6 the problem then is that E4 is going
to come with tempo right it's going to
be threatening uh a fork with E5 and in
a position this sharp every Tempo is
important you could also start by
developing your queen side playing
Knight B8 to D7 but then maybe you're
walking into 95 because the C6 Pawn has
been weakened also don't fall asleep on
the idea of a well-timed A2 A4 which
softens up Black's Queen side uh even
further of course uh at the moment black
could simply meet that with A6 but the
tension already reaching a peak and
we're only nine moves into this game
Tanya grishook he's now at home because
he's down on the clock that's
it's happened later than I thought it
would
down on the clock in there he looked a
little distracted but I think he was
just trying to understand what he wants
to play he is he was looking away from
the screen but definitely it was the
board and the position that was in his
mind and as you're pointing at Knight D7
Bishop E7 or play the move A6 so many
ideas but each of them has its own
drawbacks White's plan is clear to go
Knight E5 but he goes Knight D7 now 95
feels very strong because black can't
trade after Knight takes E5 D takes E5
and The Rook will be hitting that Queen
yes you can block that attack with
Knight D5 but there will be a pin on e4
instead Anish continues with development
in these kind of positions white is not
really looking at regaining the pawn
back you just want to play for peace
activity here you want to develop your
pieces the bishop will come to F4 Knight
will jump to E5 no one cares about that
extra Pawn absolutely this is wildly
complicated and initially preparing E4
as you pointed out earlier but I think
this is a good time as Alexander grishek
Ponders how to complete his development
whether to solidify his Queen side maybe
with A6 and C5 let's go to the bird's
eye view because all four games are
underway and Tanya it's very important
as we look at these positions looks like
a pretty peaceful game on the top right
mvl doing what he has to do playing a
Petrov with black is obviously fine with
a drop but the point I wanted to make is
that if you're the blitz what you want
to avoid is essentially abdicating your
responsibility and saying ah my
teammates have got it it doesn't really
matter how I do it's like that joke
about the drowning man uh you know the
the helicopter comes to rescue him he
says no no I don't need a helicopter God
will save me then uh the Lifeguard swims
uh into the ocean and tries to save him
he says nah it's okay God will save me a
boat comes he's already almost drowning
he says Nah God Will Save Me So he dies
and he asks God thank you where were you
and God says who do you think said the
helicopter and the Lifeguard and the
boat so you're going to have to finish
off the match if you're the blitz rather
than looking to your teammates to do
that okay that was long-winded Tanya
that wasn't even a joke I think that was
some great life advice there Daniel now
you really have to make the most of the
opportunity and you're absolutely right
with that uh that Maxim Khan just pass
it on but he is playing with the black
pieces and it looks like he's doing
everything right to neutralize the
advantage
whoa what happened there was a little
glitch on this it said for a second that
my hell Boyer won his game and it's like
wait what no he's in fact still in his
opening sorry Tanya I interrupted you
that's fine but of course that would be
a shocker but Mahal Boyer's board is
very important that Jennifer you it is
her final chance here she needs to make
sure that she can keep that under
control but right now this position is
the kind that will be out of control now
we see that black with the last move
Bishop with Queen C8 has defended the C6
Pawn but it also invites white to
develop the bishop and put the Rook on
C1 targeting it further what black wants
to do next is actually to grab the
Knight on E5 and jump with his own
Knight to D5 now that he's moved away
from the D file with that move Queen CA
yeah this is getting more and more
complex of course there's c65 you cannot
fall asleep on this idea because if it
comes at the right moment it can
entirely relinquish uh White could end
up relinquishing the pressure that he
has on the center everything is due to
the presence of this Pawn on D4 that's
clamping down on key squares in the
center that is partially why Alexander
Grisha put a queen on C8 rather than a
rook on C8 because now C5 is very much a
possibility the queen defends the bishop
on B7 so a lot to think about here for
Anish giri I agree Tanya I think he's
going to bring his Bishop out try to
quickly put a rook on C1 and punish
Alexander grishek for putting the queen
on a potentially awkward square but both
clocks are dipping down grishok already
down to six minutes I think we're gonna
get a crazy middle game time scramble in
this game
yeah we're gonna love that one and we've
got a couple of minutes before that
happens so let's take a look at our
bird's eye view on the other birds on
you were talking about uh Maxime washer
lagrav there on that top right board has
he let go of the boat of the helicopter
what's going on there he's given up that
pawn on D5 so white is currently
white has an extra Pawn currently but I
see our valbar says that it's pretty
even he takes with the Knight on E5 I'm
expecting white to recapture the Knight
with d takes E5 Queen D6 just seems to
allow too many night jumps on the board
D take C5 what does Maxime have in mind
does he want to go Bishop C5 and start
pressuring the F2 Pawn bring the Rook to
die attack that Queen and just claim
initiate it yeah let's take a closer
look at this game that White Queen it
flew in on a helicopter moved to B3 he
snags the pawn on C5 but the way this
game is going I think the blitz could
helicopter their way into the playoffs
on the strength of this game alone
Jordan has just taken the bishop rather
than the Knight but apparently mvl just
rushed it he played Knight C4 that
allows White's Queen second what is mvl
done if we could pull up an analysis
board this was very strange the speed
with which he played Knight C4 Tanya
there was another night jump available I
don't know why he didn't play the move
Knight D3 this forces White's Rook to go
up now blackstroke dives into E8 and
look at the initiative that black has in
this position obviously this is
impossible because white gets mated
instead
would have had to play Bishop B3 black
could lift The Rook up to G6 Knight C4
by mvl was an incredibly sloppy move
Jordan I think now stands better black
might not have sufficient compensation
for the pawn any longer your thoughts
I'm really surprised by that because
Maxim his middle name is initiative
that's what he loves to play for we've
seen his game he's not the Frenchman
with three names he's the Frenchman with
four names when it comes to these kind
of positions and Bishop 86 now it just
looks like white has the extra pawn and
is the one who's playing for the attack
here there's a mate in one threatened
with Queen G7 I don't believe G6 is a
move that anyone wants to consider
creating so many dark Squad weaknesses
so I'm expecting a queen Retreat Queen
G6 a queen trade down upon wow I was
gonna say that might not be ideal but
Maxim says if it's an exchange he'll do
it and hold this end game because that
Knight on C4 is a great piece blocking
the two Central pawns it's a monster
there's no doubt about it but this is
the best that Jordan went Forest could
have asked for given how this game
started white is up a pawn he's got the
passer the protected passer on D4 and I
think white has to decide first and
foremost
has to decide this as well who benefits
in the event of a mass Rook trade if you
have if you take the Rooks off the board
right Rook takes C1 rookie one Rook d8
who benefits in the bishop versus knight
end game I think we have mbl's answer he
does not want to remove even a single
pair of Rooks off the board but the
drawback of this move is that Jordan now
has a direct path into the center with
his King and he can follow up Tanya
speaking of initiative being someone's
middle name if white can double up on
the e-file white gets a major initiative
in the end game on top of his extra Pawn
I think Jordan has excellent winning
chances here
I agree with you he really does and this
is a dream position against Maxim with
the white pieces but is it gonna be
enough and to find that out we've got to
get a bird's eye view because sure this
is one board but there's action on and
hot action on on the other boards as
well because take a look at that bottom
left board what a crazy Pawn structure
we've got there with a Sean's King still
in the center he's broken in the center
with F6 or a valbar seems to say that
the chess bras are the one with the
upper hand on the driving seat on that
board against Katrina
Katrina King on G2 Pawn on G4 crazy
position as well as the Alexander
grishter against the niche we've been
saying that that's going to be a hot
mess and that's what's happening D5 a
central big Daniel that's the one that I
want to go to uh let's take a look at
this first and then jump over to the
grace checkpoint let's quickly do an
overview like no game time just because
I think Sean has a huge chance in the
early going of this game to strike and
then we will go right to the Anish giri
game because that is total pandemonium
Katarina is facing the Karo Khan for the
second time in this match she Drew
Jordan van Forest she set a very good
tone for the blitz but now she has a
significantly inferior position D4 is
coming to a theater near you White's
Queen is gonna get caught in the
crossfire White's King is likely to get
caught in the crossfire so maybe it's
time for Katarina uh to try to generate
counter play on the other side of the
board but Tanya if you play F5 then
you're saddled with the additional
weakness of the E5 Pawn I don't like
this for Katarina at all
wow I mean F5 is so brave you're saying
that she should look for count and she
does it I mean speaking of Brave bravest
Katrina lano's middle name F5 on the
board falls back with the bishop to F7
this the reason I called it Brave was
that you it's your own King on the king
side and yet here you are trying to open
it up further because you want to have
that pawn Avalanche going down the
center of the board before black strikes
in with D4 Bishop F7 I like that move
after this if you take on E6 E5 will be
a huge weakness and I don't really see
how F5 has solved White's problems
because black still wants to go D4 I
still want to get that Central uh
Central break in it's not gonna be a
movie it's not going to be a D4 near
your in your in your theaters it's going
to be a blockbuster once that moves move
comes in
Black's play has been smooth as uh we're
be kidding that pawn on E5 is now Under
Fire black will absolutely capture it
given the opportunity so cut her in as
she does what she has to do A4 I think
is the only remaining chance for white
to whip up some semblance of counter
play obviously white is trying to open
to the EA file which is a direct line to
Black's King Sean could keep the queen
side closed down with B4 but will he
press on the gas pedal instead with D4
no question all of the cards he does
play B4 though
I like it I like it because I was
thinking can you actually grab the pawn
on E5 but it leads to Absolute chaos
with the a file opening up you mentioned
the idea of B4 just keeping everything
on the queen side intact and solid you
know with the King that makes a lot of
sense still the d-pawn will go down the
board with D4 E5 is still hanging that's
a nice way to solve problems on the
queen side keep it blocked where your
king is safety first I love the way
Katarina is playing though she's making
only moves at this point B3 continuing
to Chip Away nibble away at Black's Pawn
chain now the bishop on E2 it wants its
moment in the Sun the A6 Pawn is hanging
with check white is threatening to open
up the center and if your kite Arena you
know you're worse you might even be
objectively lost and that's actually
liberating in a certain way because
ironically when you're losing you really
have nothing to lose if you lose the
game okay I got out played so you might
as well create crazy play on the board
she's taken on A6 with check Sean is
pinning all of his hopes on the
connected passers in the center but
Tanya they are currently blockaded if
white drops the bishop three it's going
to be difficult to serve out that light
Square blockade
wow and Sean is feeling the pressure the
shift in Dynamics with those last couple
of moves F5 A4 B3 everything trying to
break open the position very impressive
attacking play aggressive player here by
Katrina and you were mentioning uh this
position is trouble maybe not even
anymore as our reval bar seems to say
that white has managed to create chances
here with that Bishop taking that pawn
on A6 but it's all about how do you get
your Rook into the game you want to
start advancing with the a pawn A5 Rook
A4 ideas come into mind once black
advances with D4 you can block that pawn
on D3 with the move Bishop to D3 or
queen D3 this is a crazy position
Katrina Lano down to two and a half
minutes on the clock uh anything can
happen on this board and that might be
the biggest per clock situation is now
her biggest enemy wax Queen is a pretty
sizable enemy as well well she's trying
to head to B5 with her Queen limit the
mobility of Black's Queen but uh
speaking of limited Mobility Alexander
grishook he doesn't have a lot of
Mobility on his board either and nor
does he have a lot of time on his clock
that would be a great understatement
eight seconds for Alexander grishok and
we're barely in the middle game we have
to go to that game Alexander grishek has
completely lost control of this game he
is in free fall and anishikeri is all
over him in the center Anisha is winning
a piece oh my God Anish is winning a
piece
this is disaster hits The Rook Bishop C5
coming in you can't move the Rook Bishop
C5 loses the B7 Bishop Alexander there
shaking his head he's down to seconds in
a dead lost position f8 Anish is an
exchanger what a performance by our
niche in this uh in this match and I
think incredible place it was such a
good opening Choice the cash sharp
Catalan is exactly what you want if you
need to guarantee victory for your team
with a win Anish would come up with a
Magnus carlson-esque performance with
three and a half out of four but he
needs a couple more accurate moves I
think he should start by eliminating
Black's only active piece opening up the
D file but what that also does Tanya is
it separates Black's pawns so you could
play Rook B1 to B4 uh on the next move
and if you win the C4 Pawn you can force
a queen trade you can go after Black's
King either way I think this game is
nearly over
wow and I like that Anisha slowed down
he's trying to be precise here it is a
critical moment for him he knows if
there are any chances at least he needs
to do his bit he's got a shot against
Alexander Alexander down to seconds
you're pointing out a trade on e4 a very
committal trade giving up that fan
shattered Bishop looks extremely strong
but a niche of course he's got other
options as well he is perhaps
considering placing the queen uh to a
more active Square Queen B2 hit that
Bishop on B7 threaten Queen B4 check as
well he reaches out for his Mouse he's
about to make a move here Daniel he is
about to make a move I think it's Bishop
takes either but lots of Alternatives uh
on Deck as well Rook D4 centralizing The
Rook is in a niche-esque type of move so
I don't have anything I like that I
don't have any doubts Tanya with six
seconds for the rest of the game Queen
BT you called it he hits the bishop
Anisha is going to win this game but bad
news for the chess Bros on another one
of the boards Sean rodrigue Lemo has
made a serious mistake against Katarina
lagno who punished him immediately you
can see the Rook on F4 that's the bottom
left of your screen it's pinning the
Knight on T4 yes White's Queen is
hanging but so are all of Black's pieces
let's go to that game I think this might
be close to over
wow and queen F2 just you pin that
Knight and you win that night because
you can't even defend it there's no way
there's nowhere home Rook D4 is coming
in and Shonda is shaking his head what a
performance by Katrina Lano she is she
knew what had to be done but this could
be decisive with this if Katrina takes
this it's match over it's tournament
over for chess bras it is and I think
the only way to stay in this game is to
deliver a check on e4 your only hope is
that Katarina airs in time pressure
after Bishop E4 check White's gonna take
that Bishop obviously then White's
probably going to take the Rook on E8
but Sean still has a couple of really
good pieces he has that passed Pawn on
C3 and he's really good at creating
chances in Lost positions but it
certainly has been a very very
disappointing run for Sean rodrigue Lemo
who was hoping to score at least an
upset Katarina could indeed end this
match with a victory in this position
oh and I don't see another option for
black hair as you're pointing out Bishop
E4 seems like the only move otherwise
you just end up losing an entire piece
on D4 but it doesn't solve any of your
problems because white takes takes the
Rook eventually takes that pawn on e4
you're mentioning uh Daniel that Sean is
really known to create chances but I
don't believe that'll happen in this one
meanwhile Anish giri wraps up his game
his win a huge win for him against
Alexander grishek what a way to finish
the day for an individual result at
three and a half out of four but it
looks like it's not gonna be enough to
take the match home for the chess bras
and what a heartbreaker this will be
because the ornament Forest is also
pretty close to converting his extra
Pawn against MBO we don't have to go to
that game because it's actually the
least interesting of the three positions
that we have remaining but Jordan is
doing a an Exquisite job of continuing
to put pressure on mvl he's got that
extra Pawn on a D4 he's forced Black's
Knight which he used to stand proud on
C4 it's now back on D6 tied down to the
pawn on B5 and more concerning news for
the chess Bros Jennifer you has been
struggling all game long she's been
struggling all match long and this game
is no exception I held Boyer could also
ensure that this match doesn't go any
further with a victory I think he stands
much better he's got more time and uh
Jennifer has just been struggling
mightily in the PCL this has not been
her season
and we see the bar seems to agree with
you with Mahal's position improving
slowly and steadily we've got the bishop
pair black snide on A6 out of play
doesn't have a future can't jump onto C5
D5 is a weakness if anyone's winning
this it's got to be Mahal Boya but
Daniel I really think we have to get our
bird's eye view back up again and jump
over to the Katrina Lano game because
that might just decide and end this
match it
played an ink
and attacking tactical chest Bishop E4
on the board picks that up and remember
if Llano takes this it is match over
we've been talking about incredible
women players and their performances in
the protest League it might just be Lano
who takes the blitz to the playoffs 94
after Sean picks that up The Rook will
be snapped up if black picks up the
bishop the E4 Pawn fall oh watch out
nasty trick
you mentioned this he's so sneaky
weasel Queen B7 threatening the
discovery now Tanya white could play
Rook F7 but the black queen is going to
stay on this diagonal with Queen D5 and
an additional problem Katarina has to
deal with is that putting the queen on
E3 runs into the fork with black snake
so this game is far from overcast Arena
senses the gravity of this moment she
knows that Victory is assured if she can
win this game I'm actually thinking
about the crazy looking Bishop G6 in
order to meet E3 check with Bishop E4
Katarina investing her last minute and
getting out of the pin with King to G3
that is a good move and it does keep a
decisive Advantage but can Sean continue
to muddy the waters if you take the
bishop you lose the Knight that is the
biggest problem here for Sean he's down
a full Rook
and that was very precise because if
Katrina would have come back with the
King let's say to G1 there was a night
check on F3 if you go King F1 there were
all these ideas with E3 and the queen
from B7 jumping over to H1 it's a very
precise defense there by going up the
board with the king with King G3 but how
do you muddy the waters more you're
talking about the E8 Bishop cannot be
picked up with the D4 Knight hanging
perhaps you start thinking about pushing
that seat he does it C2 on the board and
now Queen B3 is a threat so even though
black is dead lost practically white
needs to be careful here oh yeah I mean
listen how many of these comebacks have
we seen in the PCL when you're down
below a minute you're nervous you know
that you can end the match sometimes
your fingers turn into thumbs and you
just don't use your brain as well you as
you normally do but Katarina has kept
her composure thus far and I think
she'll continue to do so she's a great
Blitz player and that is so important in
these moments she plays rookie one as
long as white does not allow black to
promote the pawn I think Katarina is
safe and queen takes B3 check it was a
threat but it's not a very strong one
because white can jump back to G2 with
her king the king is supported by these
heavy pieces or is it they might have
three
I thought
she doesn't
Rook D2 is a massive threat notice how
The Rook on E1 needs to be on the first
run to stop the C Pawn from promoting
this has turned around this has turned
around you're absolutely right Tanya
Rook takes it oh my God maybe it's
possible but there's Knight no Knight H4
checks white can take that with a queen
then maybe a check on D2 can be
delivered I'm trying to force whites
King back to the first rank so that I
can promote with track I think Knight H4
check is a brilliant move that gives
black chances maybe you can promote
immediately but Katarina is planning to
deliver a check on before are you sure
is on the board
she has to take that night
Sean with Knight into a water move Queen
H4 played Rook D2 and now if you come
Rook F2 you want to just Queen because
there's no more Rook B4 Black's gonna
win this game he's gonna have two queens
the evil bar isn't showing Tanya
decisive Advantage because white has a
lot of pieces for the queen
Daniel that means if Anish has won his
game yard and Van Forest if he wins his
and this one with a big Swindle Sean
takes it we've got a match on our hands
we absolutely do and queen to D5 is
going to end this game if Sean finds it
but generally
struggling it might come down to my hell
Boyer's ability to convert that
advantage
against against Jennifer you who is
defending very very well and now she's
better as well
what is happening Sean is made in
Katarina I mean I'm still I'm still
trying to understand this bottom left
board there are like three queens on the
board black Rook on D2 this looks
absolutely busted can we just need F3
can we go back to that can we just pull
up the Katrina game and see the end of
this because this has to end in
Checkmate if this is
nothing's Checkmate what is happening
Tanya Queen C3 check King G2 and queen
D1 to F3 was made in two moves or you
could just take the Rook but Sean's
getting nervous he's finds Queen C1
Katarina with King H3 this is still
completely winning we engage one mate
made in one two different ways Queen G1
he doesn't different one but it's
amazing Sean takes the spine Katrina
loses let's go back to our life because
Daniel the magic of life
Bonnet is giving up an exchange Jordan
has blundered in exchange
wow
who was the first to take the lead we've
got to go to Jennifer use board right
now because we see big action there
Mahala is going to be the one to take
this home this is absolutely over you
take on D3 the kingpawn ending is lost
as White's King is just in time and
finally the blitz on this board take the
win oh my God
believable and Jennifer Jennifer was
better at one moment at the end of this
game Jennifer had a big chance to seize
the initiative she missed it and it's
gonna be a very very frustrating display
for her and it's official the blitz on
the strength of my hell Boyer smile my
hell you just won a ticket to the
playoffs for your team
what a moment and he's had some
difficult ones in this match in the
early rounds but he gets the job done
when his team needed it the most when
Alexander Griffith lost his game when
Katrina Lana lost her game it was the
board for Mahal Boya who showed up for
the team and took that one point and
with that even though the Canada chess
bras scored their first win in this
match it's just not enough it's far from
enough as the blitz take the win with a
9-7 margin and with that go into the
playoffs it is goodbye to Magnus
Carlson's team
close in the end Jordan van Forrest
unable to convert that extra Pawn
against mvl who takes a draw he probably
was aware that Victory had already been
clinched the result of the game doesn't
matter in the end what a final route it
seems like every single time we think
that Victory is assured crazy things
happen and for the Canada chest press
four Magnus Carlson's team a
disappointing exit as they win two
matches and they lose three they are
eliminated as we said at the start Tanya
you want to take your opponent into that
deep and dark Forest that's what the
blitz did and they emerged in one piece
grishook and mvl and of course Katarina
lagno with one and a half crucial points
despite the last loss in the last round
she did what she had to do
right and read the protest league is a
deep dark and a dangerous Forest that we
can see with the matches that we've had
uh Daniel just incredible stuff here
with the blitz going through only one
team as you mentioned can get through
that narrow path and it is going to be
Blitz it is the end of the road for the
chess bras and we saw that in our
overall scores really it is all about a
consistent top to bottom performance for
each player to contribute for each
player to get those points in for the
team and the blitz just seem to do that
and what a day of Chess it's been and
one of the players who has been The
Shining Star along with Maxine
basharella Graf today has been Alexander
christchak with his big
we do indeed Alexander grishok is going
to be joining us for an interview of
contributions he has made a tremendous
contribution to the success of the blitz
it's been an up and down regular season
but now they are in the playoffs and
they could have done it without
Alexander grishook we will set Sasha up
you will not want to miss his insights
we will have Alexander grishak for you
you're watching the PCL we'll be back
with the interview with Alexander
Grisham in just a couple of short
minutes
[Music]
foreign
and instead the gloves came absolutely
off the wheels came off wow the sip of
tea the celebratory we did it when I saw
that reaction I felt what you were
feeling like I felt this this transfer
of energy of like that kind of moment
that kind of of upset is uh is so
exhilarating so can you just talk a
little bit about like how you're feeling
in that moment what was going through
your mind uh what it means to you
yeah I mean it was very difficult to
believe
like I don't know I just didn't see this
scenario happen we're actually it was
funny we were in trainings Camp until a
few days before this were the German
national team and all the guys from my
team were there
and we were at lunch and I said for fun
okay don't worry I will take care of
Hikaru yeah
hello and welcome to this video
my name is Christoph zileki I'm an
international master in chess from
Germany and I'm here to share with you
why the opening plays such an important
role in modern chess the opening in
chess is like coming prepared with a
battle plan you play a move but it's
part of a larger strategy you want to
have an idea what to do against every
possible response that your opponent may
play against you want to have a plan a
strategy laid out before the game even
starts this can be really deep on the
top level move 10 20 30. you don't need
that much but you want to be prepared to
get a game that you enjoy playing it's
more fun to play and give you more
chances to win more games I've always
loved starting the opening figuring out
new ideas how to beat my opponents and
set traps this is now my profession
writing courses on openings for
chessable I've created more than a dozen
the most popular ones being of the keep
it Sim simple series I have received an
award this year the author of the year
what I invite you to do is go to
chessable.com and check out how to play
the opening better get fun positions and
win more games
foreign
let's call it a huge win against the
Canada chess bras and with that they
punched their ticket into the pro chess
League playoffs now the one player who
showed up every week for the blitz is
Grand Master Alexander gristook his role
today was super important in this
Victory firstly Sasha congratulations on
this big win
yeah thank you thank you it was a very
tough Journey for our team to get to the
playoffs
hey today was the first match that we
won without Blitz portion the first two
was after eight eight only
I want to ask you actually that was
pretty prophetic of the team you named
your team Blitz and then ended up
deciding most of the matches on Blitz
playoffs how did that even happen and
and why do you think a team like Blitz
with you and Maxime uh struggle to get
into the playoff we thought you guys
were going to have a smooth sailing into
it
I don't know I think there are so many
uh strong teams
like there are some completely super
teams and but every team is dangerous
and strong so no it
it could not be easy yeah
uh Sasha you're obviously known for your
incredible ability in time pressure but
you've also increased your online rating
through the years do you feel more
comfortable than you used to uh playing
uh time scrambles on the computer or do
you still prefer rapid and Blitz over
the board
uh I guess it's a bit simpler for me
over the board but of course with years
uh going by it becomes tougher and
tougher
I mean and speaking about online chess
and you were mentioning that today was
the one match Sasha where you know it
looked like it was in fact an awesome
convincing performance by Blitz what do
you think clicked today for your team
uh I don't know today we had a very
how to say a very stable team everyone
contributed greatly uh to the victory
so yeah that's important I think you
really need your
all your four boards to score
considerable points because otherwise
it's just too difficult I mean today
today this Saint Louis
caruanas they managed to score four out
of four on board one but overall it will
not be easy like this I mean you cannot
go too far with you know trying to score
four on board one and zero on board
it will not work out everyone has to
contribute more or less evenly
I'm gonna have one guy consistently
scoring 60 points it's true if you want
to win a championship it should be all
players contributing
Steph Curry scored 50 points yesterday
in my team The Warriors lost so uh very
timely analogy uh Alexander you will
probably face the Indian yogis next week
uh all hands on deck will be required
can we expect to see you in that match
and what are your overall thoughts on uh
the all Indian team that includes vidit
and other very talented players will you
be able to deal them their first loss of
the PCL
uh they won all the matches here
yeah they're 3-0
oh okay but they got somewhat lucky
against the chess brox I remember Magnus
lost to visit they didn't Checkmate him
in three
so okay I mean as I said all teams are
very strong but there are no
invulnerabilities so everyone can be
beat it as well
hmm
Sasha you mentioned a really important
point that how it's important to not
just be have a heavy hitter on the first
part but a more balanced approach where
you've got players performing and
contributing uh top to bottom on the
lineup now the one thing that we've been
talking about the blitz team has been
well the Family Affair that is there
we've got you playing we've got Katrina
Lana playing and I've got to ask you
that before the matches you guys end up
preparing strategizing together what's
that like
no not really it's not
I'm just saying come on let's go
like Doc River and the same type of
Coach I think Daniel will understand
what I mean yes
yeah he's he's had a couple tough
Seasons but
um I I like that comparison uh Sasha we
will let you go but we have two more
feature chat questions the first one
from VHF
hgidj rolls right off the tongue how
does it feel to play against Geary
instead of Magnus and were you excited
about the prospect of facing Carlson or
were you happy uh to see Anish instead
no at least for myself I was a bit upset
I would prefer to play against Magnus
but I guess for the team I thought it
might be better
well Anish did have a good performance
but it wasn't enough and I have another
chat question for you uh Sasha now you
also commentated on chesscom for the
2021 World Championship so I think
everyone in chat wants to know that when
can they expect to have you back as a
commentator
of it's it depends search of all on
chess.com yeah I mean
I'm not invited to commentate I cannot
commentate
so it's
but also I think I will have um how to
say already an appointment to commend
for some Russian side
but the world championship match
yeah yeah
but of course it's uh it's a pleasure
commentating the world championship
a very interesting event
well we commentated some of the world
championship in 2021 that was a great
honor so we I'm sure everybody will be
very excited to see you comment Satan
whatever language uh Sasha we will let
you go I know it's it's late
congratulations on your Victory and good
luck in the playoffs to you Katarina and
your entire team
yeah thank you thank you and uh just
regarding the world championship match I
have one wish and I guess all the
commentators
will sign
under my words that we all hope there
won't be such a long game in this match
like it was game six in the travel
a half hours I think and we of course
were doing that one
yeah something like this okay thank you
thank you
thank you so much Alex
you're joining us and congratulations
once more time to make it to the
playoffs
wow and then we have Sasha with his
usual advice he says that he just says
let's go and that seemed to have worked
the Perfection Daniel in today's matchup
against the Canada chess bras the blitz
take a very very critical match Victory
with that punching their ticket into the
playoffs but it means it's heartbreak
for the chess bra fans as it's the end
of the road for them in the protest
League 23 season
unfortunately come to an end there were
UPS there were Downs there were four out
of four performances by Magnus Carlson
but in the end it wasn't enough
Alexander he pointed this out it has to
be a team effort everybody has to
contribute it for Jennifer you it has
been a very tough sledding but you can
sympathize the PCL is one of the
strongest tournaments in the online
circuit we see that again and again so
she's going to analyze the games and
come back stronger next year I think the
chess bras are a very well assembled
team Tanya at the end of the day this
can really go either way things aren't
dependent on these Grand narratives they
really are dependent on the result of
like one or two individual games that
can tilt uh the scales in either side's
favor this week it was the blitz's
moment in the Sun and they will have to
repeat this successful performance
because a very difficult trial awaits
them in the form of the Indian yogis
absolutely it only has tougher from here
and as you mentioned that it really is
about scoring on every board and in fact
once we look at the score line seven to
nine even if Magnus did play on that
board one scoring four out of four it
would indeed not have been enough for
the chess Bros did all that he could
three and a half out of four only
dropping half a point against Maxim a
fabulous performance but it wasn't
enough for the chess bras we had Eric on
earlier who mentioned that there's a lot
of thought to be put into a lot of
takeaways from this protest League
season and I have no doubt that they
will be back next season stronger and
better a bit of course for now this
means that today we've had two teams go
through to the playoffs the St Louis
archbishops with a very difficult start
at the protest League season and three
back-to-back wins qualify into the
playoffs and we saw Blitz make their way
as well
and perhaps the greatest storyline one
of the greater storylines of the PCL
season is The Comeback initiated by the
St Louis archbishops they were oh and
two they were dead in the water they got
crushed and that after winning the pro
chess league in previous seasons and now
they occupy their rightful place in the
playoffs I think the archbishops are a
team to be reckoned with and nobody
wants to face them they have found the
lineup that I think they're going to
stick with for uh as long as they remain
in the competition Fabiano caruana is on
fire he's gaining confidence theodoro
and Bach are just an incredible Trifecta
and Alice Lee What a fine if she has
been so Tanya these playoffs are going
to be something else
in fact that's been that squad for the
three winning matches that they've had
uh back to back so I completely agree
with that sentiment they have zero down
on the recipe that works for them that
gets them the wins and I think we'll be
seeing a lot more of them and of course
as these teams have punched their way
there have been teams that have been
eliminated today let's move on and take
a look at the other half of our
standings and there we see the Croatia
Bulldogs and the chess bras with that
dreaded red mark joining the eliminated
theme it is the end of the road and we
see in the middle there with two wins
and two losses MGD one and the Garden
State passes So Daniel one hot spot
remains for the playoffs two of these
one of these two teams either the MGD
one or the Garden State fossils will
make it through
there's room for exactly one more team
as you pointed out Tanya we want to see
all of these teams make the playoffs God
knows that they are deserving James
Canty's team has been one of the most
fascinating to watch Sam stephian's
outstanding performance has propelled
them to a 2-2 record but now they need
one more clutch performance against a
incredibly well-assembled team in mgd1
they're one of the most well-rounded
teams in the league so this match
promises to be a barn burner and it is
coming your way bright and early
tomorrow that would be Friday at 7 30
a.m Pacific 10 30 a.m New York time
Tanya this is unmissable chess action to
see which last team makes it into that
final playoff spot
wow I mean just a
just a tab the kind of results that
they've been showing now there's a part
of me Daniel that really wants to see
mgd1 go through as well no prizes for
guessing why that's the case but of
course James Candy's team the Garden
State passes with Sam Savion on the top
board with phenomenal performances by
Alexander botnik it's not gonna be an
easy one but also for the MGD they've
got Arjun leading the team water roster
these two teams have for that one spot
once again it is the deep dark dangerous
Forest off the protest league and the
path is narrow enough for only one team
to make it through we will be back with
that action Daniel today has been so
much fun thank you so much for joining
us and to chat as well what an
incredible ride we've had well thank you
Tanya it's been a great pleasure as
usual uh covering this match and
watching uh your your amazing commentary
with Robert in that first match so yet
another day of of just Breakneck
non-stop action in the protesting I
can't believe that we are five weeks in
but the best part is that the playoffs
are still ahead of us but before the
playoffs we of course have one decisive
regular season match between mgd1 and
the passers I will be watching that on
at the edge of my seat but Tanya as
usual these hours they flew by
they really did right I mean the kind of
action that we saw on the board there
was so much going on but I have to say
the second match with a blitz
performance it was some phenomenal play
and having Eric on this show it was
clear that he could feel the tension he
knew that things were not working chess
bra's way now it is all about the final
day of the final week which starts
tomorrow the Garden State passes taking
on the mgd1 team and Daniel it's also
the nerves the pressure you know as the
weeks go by that spot the elimination
spot it becomes a reality and it all
comes down to tomorrow and the teams
have to give their best they have to
give it their all they have to play
their heart out they do indeed and you
will be covering that match on the call
with Robert Hess I will be once again in
The Spectator position but it promises
to be a fascinating Affair we had two
fascinating Affairs today but it's time
for us to bring this day to a close we'd
like to think everybody in the chat for
supporting your favorite teams the PCL
wouldn't be as hype as it is without you
to our amazing team working hard behind
the scenes to make these broadcasts as
professional and seamless as they are
and another thank you to you Tanya this
was a pleasure you have been watching
the pro chess League week five we are
international Master Tanya and
Grandmaster Daniel nariditsky and we
will see you tomorrow at 7 30 a.m
Pacific for the final regular season
match but for now have a great rest of
your Thursday so long
foreign
[Music]